what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so about a month ago at least I
want to say about a month ago egoraptor
over at game grumps had a question about
Marvel you know he was like well I just
finished reading house of M I want to
read more x-men where do I go next and
it was a really good question because I
was sitting here thinking about this and
I was like man that's true like a lot of
people don't know because the x-men just
kind of like spun out into a litany of
titles it's always been that way you
originally had x-men back in the 1960s
and then you had uncanny x-men in 1975
which was like the creation of a second
line of titles and then in 1992 you had
x-men vol 2 so then you had x-men and
uncanny x-men as two publications
running at the same time and as the
x-men grew to be more and more popular
he had all kind of things you know x-men
deluxe and yet x-men unlimited you know
and then eventually that's spun out you
had extreme x-men and then you had new
x-men and astonishment and you had so
many different x-men publications then
it just baffled the mind people didn't
really know where to start or where to
go so ah this video goes out to
egoraptor and whoever else is interested
in this but when joe cassano took over
Marvel in the early 2000s Marvel was
coming out of the comic bust writing to
mean the comic-book industry almost
collapsed Marvel had to sell off the
rights to a bunch of their characters
and movie form in order to stay afloat
which is why Fox has the x-men the
Fantastic Four that's why Sony has
spider-man that's why Universal had the
Incredible Hulk for a while I think they
might still have the Hulk now that I
think about it but you know Marvel was
was selling off things left and right
and joe cassano said okay here's the
problem we spent far too long building
you know doing world building what we
need to do is we need to get back to
basics we need to get back to a core set
of groups we need to get back to a core
set of people focus on those and then
basically rebuild it was effectively a
reboot in a lot of different ways
it's just Marvel doesn't do new 52 they
don't line wide reboot they don't start
everything back at zero again they just
say let's revamp it and change things up
now joke decided to this in a couple
forms it was Avengers disassembled -
in-house event The Avengers were very
very easy to basically reset I mean
they're just a team all you have to do
is just break the team up no you have to
do is just give a reason for why the
Avengers can't be Avengers anymore the
issue was a Tony Stark bankrolled the
Avengers team those are guys were
wondering how the Avengers made their
money how they got paid Tony Stark was
the one that took care of all that he
gave them a place to stay he basically
paid their bills made sure they had
money they received a stipend but it was
enough for them to take care of the
things they needed to do all joe cassano
did was come along and say hey look if
we're basically going to reboot the
mutant landscape if we're going to get
rid of the Avengers there why not kill
two birds with one
stone and so what he did is he grabs
Scarlet Witch a character whose powers
had been ambiguous for years and years
and years and said okay let's go ahead
and just change this up of it let's go
ahead and just use her as a way to get
rid of the Avengers and then eventually
reboot the mutant landscape and so what
he did is or at least what Marvel did
with Avengers disassembled is they had a
segment in the story where the Scarlet
Witch had basically controlled the mind
of Tony Stark or at least modified his
body's physical structure to the point
that he appeared drunk and the result
was that because people thought that he
had relapsed about gonna back into
alcoholism as bad as he was during the
events of demon and a bottle the stocks
of Stark Industries just plummeted now
they didn't fall so bad that Tony Stark
couldn't take care of himself but they
fell bad enough that Tony Stark could
not fund the Avengers anymore and so the
Avengers basically had to break up now
of course the whole basis behind this
was because of Scarlet Witch was
convinced that the Avengers had taken
her kid she was convinced that her kids
were real the Avengers had taken him and
she basically waged the war against them
but at the end of Avengers disassembled
after this great big huge conflict in
the death of Hawkeye and so on and so
forth Marvel went into the house of M
and that's what this does this basically
picks up with the idea that at the end
of Avengers disassembled magneto had
taken his daughter Wanda Maximoff and
said I'm sorry I had I'd abandon you for
so long I'm sorry I ignored you for so
long
clearly you have a serious illness that
we need to sort out an illness of the
mind
come with me to Genosha and we will go
sort that out of course Genosha being a
mutant refuge that was wiped out during
Grant Morrison's new x-men by Cassandra
Nova you'll find that video down in the
description by the way where Cassandra
Nova's sent sentinels had wiped out 16
16 million mutants but this initially
picks up with with Wanda Maximoff giving
birth to children now this is really
kind of cool because keep in mind for
years and years it was one to maksimov
and it was vision they were not really
like a power couple but they were an
interesting couple within the realm of
Marvel Comics essentially an Android in
a relationship with with a biological
woman of course the question being how
in the world are they going to reproduce
but somehow they managed to find a way
but remember this is basically Wanda's
perfect dream this is her you know
situation where she's like yeah you know
we finally had kids myself envisioned
finally have a family everyone who loves
her is there she doesn't feel neglected
she doesn't feel abandoned of course
Doctor Strange was delivering the
children her brother quicksilver's their
magneto is there this is a perfect dream
the issue with this is that Xavier
appears and says you need to stop you
have to stop doing this and this is the
first step to casada and Marvel showing
us the powers of Scarlet Witch up until
this point it had basically just been
probability manipulation it was a plot
device it was scarlet witch's powers do
whatever it is that she needs to do in
order to defeat whatever villain she's
facing at any particular point in time
that's basically how her powers worked
now it wasn't as though she would single
handedly do it it would just be like oh
man the x-men are on the ropes if only
we had this one thing with Anne suddenly
it's there
suddenly the one break they need to when
the battle is there because that's just
what scarlet witch's powers do and so
because of that she was basically this
character that was just kind of out
there in left field and because there
was no real foundation for her abilities
because there was no real you know solid
concept for her powers aside from some
measure of magic or hex or something
like that that eventually fans just kind
of stopped caring about her and so
because of that this is basically
cassada and everybody's saying The
Scarlet Witch is warping reality she's
literally changing reality around her
and that's what's happening here not
only that something else that I'd like
you to notice is that with regards to
her powers they're growing they're
progressing they're becoming more and
more potent to the point that Xavier
can't curtail them anymore and that's
effectively what's been happening here
during the time when she's been in
Genosha during the time that she's been
under the care of magneto that somewhere
along the line Xavier that basically
arrived here and he had shown up for the
purpose of trying to figure out how to
control Wanda Maximoff hours how to
bring them back under her ability to
maintain and again this is always one of
the focal points with Charles Xavier
because keep in mind with a Sun Legion
legions multiple personalities always
ran amok you never knew if you walked up
on David holler you wouldn't know if you
were talking to David holler himself if
you were talking to Susan and sunshine
if you were talking to the origamist you
wouldn't know which personality you were
talking to you could have been talking
to like in-game for all you know so the
idea was for Xavier to always go through
and try to find a way to keep his son's
powers under control and so because of
this this you know history with dealing
with Legion is basically brought over to
Wanda Maximoff the issue is that as far
as savior is concerned this can't be
controlled her powers can't be contained
they're growing too extreme they're
growing too potent to the point that
she'll become a threat to the entire
multiverse and that's actually something
that will focus on once we get to the
end of house of M it's how far-reaching
the powers of Wanda Maximoff
really go because at the end of this
story she basically becomes a
multiversal threat like it's it's stupid
how powerful she is at the end of the
story but in response to the increasing
powers have wanna match them off the
fact that they can't be kept in check
Xavier basically calls a calls a meeting
of the Avengers and the x-men now the
reason why this is done is because in
the end these are the two
top teams and Marvel Comics it just
makes good sense right I mean you know
sure he could call together the group of
the x-men but there are individuals who
have a lot of experience with Wanda
Maximoff because she was part of the
Avengers at the same time the x-men have
faced off against her and so it's just
one of these things was kind of grabbing
everybody this had any kind of a role in
in Wanda's life and the reason why is
because Xavier is quite seriously
pondering the idea of killing one two
maxima
it's him basically saying her powers are
growing too extreme to control somebody
is going to do something and for all we
know she could just destroy the universe
itself and so he says her powers are too
extreme we basically have to find a way
to bring it down now the cool thing
about this is the way that Bendis wrote
the story business is really really good
when it comes to like interpersonal
relationships among comic book
characters he's extremely good when it
comes to writing characters and how they
relate to others is one of the things I
love the most about a stories that's why
Doctor Doom being Iron Man right now an
infamous Iron Man is so cool because
it's a huge change for the status quo
that were used to when it comes to Tony
Stark but the idea here is a Quicksilver
essentially has to you know it's
confronted by Magneto
of course Quicksilver spending all this
time you know with a son but the issue
here is a Quicksilver is like you got to
do something you know they're going to
kill your daughter and you have to do
something now the funny thing about this
is that when it comes to magneto he's
always been a bit disconnected from
everyone from mutants from humans so on
and so forth sure he's looked to protect
mutants but in this scenario he's
basically walking a knife set on one
hand his daughter's powers have grown to
the extreme and they can't be controlled
on the other hand it's his daughter and
it's one of these situations where it's
like you know a father of any real
measure would stand against the world
and would watch the world burn if it
meant that he could keep their child
he'll keep his child alive that's the
kind of sentiment that Magneto's feeling
right now but the issue is he's kind of
torn because it's like the world could
literally burn because of garlic which
at her stream extreme powers and this is
a question that he has to Quicksilver
what would you have me do would you have
me just kill everyone would you have me
just stand guard here like a sentinel in
Genosha and anybody who comes knocking
on the door of our home willing to tell
you check out one a Maximoff gets killed
what would you have me do you know and
so it creates this really weird
situation because in the end there's art
there's arguments on both sides for
example Cyclops is like this Charles
Xavier
you've stood for the preservation of
life even preserving the lives of people
who would see you dead you stand for the
preservation of life this is no
different but it is and that's the huge
thing here this is
Legion all right it's not like he's just
gonna read the minds of people I mean
surely Jeanerette launched Legion quest
he went to the Past he intended to kill
Magneto Xavier jumped in the way but he
was him doing what he thought was the
right thing to do he was still in full
control of his faculties The Scarlet
Witch is not it would be like if Robert
Reynolds turned into the void lost his
mind and decided to eliminate all things
in existence you know if the century
basically became the bad guy that's
basically what's happening here and
that's the case of Charles Xavier is
making this is not her in full control
of her faculties she's insane she's lost
her mind and so in the end what they
agree on is I say look if we're really
pondering the idea of killing Wanda
Maximoff if we're really pondering the
idea of killing someone who's been in
friend and enemy and Ally you know one
of the most powerful beings we've ever
met then the very least we should do is
ask her how she feels I mean at least
ask her what she thinks now I don't know
I'd love to see how that conversation
goes now hey Wanda we're thinking about
killing you but we just want to know how
you feel about the fact I'd love to know
how that conversation would go down the
problem is that once they all race over
to the location of where Wanda Maximoff
is supposed to be she's gone
not only that Charles Xavier is the
first one to disappear now we'll find
out why Charles Xavier is the first one
to disappear but Charles Xavier is the
first one to vanish after that people
just start disappearing left and right
they're just gone no one knows where
they go to they just vanish from one
location to the next
finally spider-man's the last guy left
things just sort of distort and then we
wake up with Peter Parker when he's in
at his apartment you know with a baby
crying and he's married to Gwen Stacy
now this is one of this is already
cyclists dealing the scar of which
effectively created a perfect world
that's that's kind of you know what she
did not really perfect perfect but
perfect in you know 90% of the time I
mean there were some people for like Ben
Grimm the wall just absolutely sucked
but for the most part it was perfect in
in almost every way in the sense that
everybody basically got their heart's
desire for example we initially picked
up with Steve Rogers and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because for him he
basically didn't have to outlive his
friends he was able to fight in you know
continue fighting a world war two he
survived the experience and he lived a
life alongside his friends now there is
a tie-in for Captain America and it
focuses on all that basically how
married to Peggy Carter for a while they
eventually got divorced but it was the
idea that for a time he got everything
that he wanted his life progressed the
way that he wanted it to initially but
that was the whole crux here is Steve
Rogers was literally always living in
the past and so what he got was the life
he wanted in the past the problem is
with the modern day he was never
about the president he was ever thinking
about the long-term all he wanted to do
was go back where his life left off pick
up from there and continue on that's
what he got but then everything began to
go south from here we actually end up
joining with Cyclops and Emma Frost now
this actually makes a lot more sense and
one of the reasons why I say that is in
Marvel Comics Cyclops and Emma Frost
being together was something that had
long since been running I mean really
you know with Jean Grey where their
character kind of being out of the
picture with her being killed off coming
back and then being killed off again it
basically set the stage for Grant Morse
and it kind of mixed things around you
know dance things around it was a chance
for Chuck Austin to do the exact same
thing and to basically remove Jean Grey
from the equation and to pair up Cyclops
and Emma Frost the result was that once
they became headmaster and headmistress
of the Xavier Institute after the events
of the house of M that it made sense of
the two of them were gonna be together
but it was really this idea that they
always shared a connection and so even
if their minds had changed only recently
the two of them very much saw themselves
together they saw themselves as a
legitimate couple but again this is
really only because Jean Grey is not
part of the picture
but even if she was it wouldn't matter
because this is still part of Cyclops
if this was a perfect world Jean Grey
could be brought back by Scarlet Witch
Jean Gregg could be resurrected and
Cyclops would be with Jean but instead
he's with Emma Frost and so from here we
kind of pick up with with the irrelevant
characters that became relevant and this
really hits home at the heart of what
the Scarlet Witch did we're basically
talked about the idea of characters who
basically get a perfect life who get a
perfect world for example we pick up
with Allison Blair we pick up with
Dazzler and no matter what it's super
effective might say no matter what else
might say Dazzlers never been relevant
she was never a relevant character but
neither was Simon Williams and neither
was Carol Danvers now people will look
at me and they'll say Carol Danvers was
never really relevant character no she
was cool while she was on the Avengers
but she was never able to hold a solo
title for any measure of time outside of
her initial appearance and the reason
why was because back then she was a sex
object she was one of the earliest
characters that was used in order to
bring in young boys in the comic books
but once more and more characters
started popping up like that road and so
on and so forth when mystique was kind
of transformed her physical design was
transformed to make her very you know
very interesting to young boys
the result was that you know Carol
Danvers just kind of took a backseat
nobody really cared about her character
that much anymore we know that just
because of all the changes our character
went through and so on and so forth and
so you know her and Anne in Simon
Williams and Allison were kind of like
the the lower echelon of characters and
Marvel Comics but in the house of them
also
has her own TV show Simon Williams is
wildly popular Carol Danvers is the most
popular superhero on the planet they all
have the lives that they were looking
for they all have the lives that they
were wanting now from here we actually
switch over to Cincinnati Ohio and this
is kind of cool because what this shows
us is that not everybody goes on to live
this huge grandiose life or even amount
to any measure of a superhero
instead we actually end up joining Kitty
Pryde and Kitty Pryde is just a mutant
who's a teacher now that's the cool
thing about that is because what that
tells us is that Kitty Pryde is when she
was part of the x-men all she ever want
to do is be a teacher she just wanted to
teach the next generation of kids that
was it she didn't want to do something
great big huge grandiose thing she
didn't want to be massive in terms of
being a superhero so on and so forth she
just wanted to make sure the next
generation was able to function
adequately when it came to understanding
their abilities understanding what they
were capable of now from here we
actually end up joining with with Doctor
Strange and this is actually kind of a
cool moment here and the reason why I
say that is because Doctor Strange is
actually speaking to his client Robert
Reynolds now the funny thing about this
is this basically shows us how the void
compares to Scarlet Witch one of the
questions that I get a lot is when it
comes to the ability of beings to warp
reality how do they compare to one
another is one stronger than the other
when it comes to that level of power
it's really not a measure of which one's
stronger than the other just because of
the fact that if they were to actually
fight and use the full potential of
their powers it would just lay waste to
the universe I mean it would just it
would just results in the end of all
things I mean that that would really be
what would happen we saw that during
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers wouldn't it beyonders these you
know beings that were just stupid
powerful from beyond the multiverse
invaded the multiverse started killing
off all the cosmic entities and then
fathe fought the Living Tribunal it just
resulted in the death of everything I
mean everything all these different
cosmic entities started getting
obliterated because they couldn't stand
against that kind of power with regards
to the void the void is the evil aspect
of the century Robert Reynolds novel
Reynolds again is one of Marvel's
versions of Superman alongside Hyperion
gladiator a few others here and there
but the other half is he basically deals
with multiple personality disorders the
void represents every dark ambition
every ounce of hatred every bit of
distrust that Robert Reynolds has in his
body the problem is that the void being
so filled with anger and power is
insanely powerful there's the what-if
story for siege I think it is with a
void kills the Marvel Universe it wipes
out everything in existence of course
you'll find that video
in the description as well but what this
also tells us is that within the house
of M the void still exists and so this
gives us two ideas here the first is
that the void is an intrinsic part of
Robert Reynolds as long as Robert
Reynolds exists the void will be there
the second is that the void is too
powerful to contain the void is too
powerful of a being for the Scarlet
Witch to just eliminate because if this
was the dream life that everybody had
Robert Reynolds wouldn't have the void
the void wouldn't be there and so
because of this this basically tells us
the Scarlet Witch cannot contain the
power that the void possesses the void
will always come back the void will
always be there and of course we find
this when Robert Reynolds is talking to
dr. strange about how there's this black
wall this this black darkness it always
tries to encroach on him but it always
ends up going away and so of course what
we also learned here is that dr. strange
is not the sorcerer supreme dr. strange
is just a psychiatrist that's it like he
literally just listens to people's
problems all day long and again this
ties into the idea that dr. strange was
just tired of listen you're tired of
being the sorcerer supreme he was tired
of having a jump from dimension
dimension losing his humanity he wanted
his simpler life and a simpler life is
exactly what he got and so from here we
actually ends up to end up transitioning
over to what Colossus and that's one of
the coolest things about this is we guys
with the character of Colossus he
doesn't he's never part of the x-men the
x-men were never formed and what this
basically tells us is that was his sole
purpose the only reason why Colossus
ever came to America in the first place
was because Charles Xavier went to him
and said we want you to be part of the
x-men I want you to be part of a team
that can helps you know help fight off
evil in the world and Colossus said ok
without Charles Xavier being there and
we'll find out why Charles Xavier isn't
here now but without Charles Xavier
being there Colossus didn't have a
reason to leave Russia and so he's
basically been there ever since he has
his mutant powers but he's not a
superhero he just lives a solitary life
in Russia by himself and so it creates a
really interesting situation but at this
point we basically pick up with
Wolverine himself and I know a lot of
you guys were kind of like women do we
get to all right we pick it with
Wolverine himself and then the issue
here is that Wolverine basically just
remembers everything he know he
remembers everything before the events
of house of M now Bendis does not tell
us why and at least not initially he
does not tell us why it is that
Wolverine remembers everything before
the House of M he just does now bindus
will do this Dennis will do this in
stories that he writes he'll basically
introduce plot devices he'll introduce
some character that will just serve no
other purpose than to give him a way out
then to give Bendis a way to end the
story it doesn't mean it's
and everybody does that but doesn't mean
it's bad it's just sometimes the way he
does it is bad for example Ulysses in
Civil War - bidness didn't know what to
do with him so he basically just made
him a cosmic entity and then little
ulysses just kind of went out into the
universe and that was the end of him
he'll probably never be seen or heard
from again
but that's essentially what happened to
his code that's what Bendis does
sometimes when it comes to these things
and so with Wolverine waking up right
off the bat he wakes up to what appears
to be Jean Grey but has actually
revealed to be mystique not only that we
actually also find out that like toad
that Jessica drew that all these people
are here and then he finds out that he's
actually on a shield Helicarrier but
it's not shield that is basically
Magneto's own personal Helicarrier or I
guess is one of the the mini
helicarrier's that magneto has at his
disposal and so again it's kind of
jumping through these memories of of
Wolverine is he's you know recollecting
all the way back to and his powers first
manifested his first battle with the
Incredible Hulk the Weapon X project you
know his wife the conflict with Jean
Grey Charles Xavier all these different
things and it's basically him saying
what in the heck is going on here right
now things are not supposed to be this
way now something that I want to talk
about here for a second is the nature of
reality warping when it comes to Marvel
comics
whenever a reality is distorted or
whatever reality has changed like a new
reality a new universe is created like
the house of M what happens is it's not
like it just picks up all of a sudden
it's not like if you were walking down
the road you know you're walking down
the road of this universe and then you
just hop over to the sidewalk it's not
like there's nothing behind you there's
everything behind you there's a whole
backstory to the House of M universe
there's all kinds of things were there
and so essentially what is happening
with regards to this House of M universe
with Wolverine is that this universe
when the Scarlet Witch created it she
created this universe dating all the way
back to its initial introduction you
know during some Big Bang that led to
the creation of this reality and things
began to unfold the way universe is
always unfold the creation of planets
and creation of solar systems and
galaxies and so on and so forth all
leading up to this point essentially
what's happened is it's like the mind of
Wolverine has been transferred over to
this House of M reality version and the
result is that he just kind of wakes up
now the way this was initially written
it wasn't that way the way this was
initially written the main Marvel
Universe had just been gone it was just
it just disappeared and this took its
place but when Marvel went through
following the events of house of M and
they started talking about this universe
and how everything was affected Marvel
basically said this was an alternate
reality
the main Marvel Universe still continued
on but Wolverines mine had just kind of
been sent over it was it was a strange
situation that's one of the issues that
Marvel had with their multiverse and one
of the reasons why they got rid of it
going up into Secret Wars was because it
got to the point where was really
difficult to maintain and it was really
difficult to explain it and to
understand what was going on in
comparison to normal stories but the
long and short of this is that
Wolverines basically coming to the
recollection that everything is wrong
here you shouldn't be in a relationship
with mystique or they shouldn't be
sleeping together at the very least you
know he doesn't know anything that's
going on his recognize any of these
ships you know when he jumps off the
Helicarrier he lands on the ground you
know you've got Simon Williams who's
really popular you've got Mary Jane
Watson who's an actress out of Hollywood
that has anything you know one of the
best actresses in Hollywood you know
you've got people that are celebrating
spider-man you know you've got all these
weird things going on and he doesn't
understand why so for him he's like
reality's been screwed up reality's been
destroyed and so of course the journey
of Wolverine takes him to the most
logical place right I mean when it comes
to Wolverine I wouldn't really say that
he trusts people but I would say that he
does have things that are familiar to
him and the most familiar thing resides
in Westchester County in New York which
is of course the Xavier Institute and so
when he gets there he literally just
kind of breaks into the home only to
find out that it's not Charles Xavier
home this has never been the home of
Charles Xavier this was just the home of
some random family and he literally just
kind of showed up in their house and it
was just a really weird situation but at
this point he kind of takes off to a
local diner you know basically calls for
one one says I need a name Charles
Xavier based out of New York Charles
Xavier doesn't exist Charles Xavier
isn't there and so what this does is
it's basically follows Wolverine as he
begins to try to go through and try to
discover everything that's happening and
that's what makes us kind of cool
because of the fact that we're literally
following him we're following the only
guy that seems to know what's going on
the only guy who seems to realize that
this reality has been distorted this
reality has been screwed up and so of
course along the way he's being chased
by mystique by Jessica drew Nightcrawler
toad and rogue but this is basically
kind of like a reimagining of Team X you
know when it came to the concept of team
X that was basically where Wolverine
first got his start you know Wolverine
of course developed his powers when he
was a kid and he just kind of went on
the run for a little while he was part
of the Civil War World War One World War
two he fought alongside and in a lot of
these event conflicts this all
eventually led to the 1960s when he was
paired up with with Sabretooth and a
handful of others in a joint venture
between the United States CIA and
Canada's clandestine group Department K
to basically operate his team action
they carried out a bunch of black ops
emissions but because of the fact that a
team actually basically governed by the
CIA eventually he was rolled into the
Weapon X project was led to the
adamantium bonding process and all that
kind of good stuff but the idea here is
that this is basically a reimagining
that it's a government-sanctioned black
ops team that carries out missions for
really for magneto since by Eidos one
running the show here but again this
really just kind of unfolds with him
just be going against his own team and
it really makes sense here because if
the thing you got to keep in mind is
that Wolverines basically the leader of
this team because he knows how to
counter every one of them and that's one
of the cool things when it comes to his
character in the House of M universe
it's still intact his history is still
intact
you know his experience as a fighter is
still intact his ability to to basically
challenge a multitude of people and
fight all them at the same time whether
they have powers or not is still intact
and so he can literally take on the
entirety of his team and hold his own
against them the problem is that as he's
making his escape from you know this I
guess his former teammates he suddenly
met by cloak now cloak is one of these
characters alongside dagger that just
kind of appears on the background of
stories they're basically just kind of
exist for the purpose of forwarding the
plot I hate to say that because I'm
really excited about the cloak and
dagger TV show but that's all they ever
really were they were just kind of plot
devices they just serve the purpose of
helping the story move forward they were
always background characters they were
always small Todd they had some
important roles here and there for
example you know cloak had a really
important role during Civil War when he
teleported the entire conflict from the
negative zone all the way to New York
but it size on that he was always just a
small-time guy but cloak basically has
the ability to imbue people in his you
know in his cloak and then just teleport
them to any location and so because of
this Wolverines teleported to Luke Cage
now Luke Cage runs this kind of criminal
underground to a degree and it's
interesting because again this basically
shows us that Luke Cage himself while he
was a hero for hire
he rather would have been a guy on the
ground level he rather would have been a
guy that was you know I guess not really
fighting crime so much as maintaining
control of the streets and so this seems
to be more like a power play for his
character and the sense of when it came
to Luke Cage being a good guy was cool
but he rather would have been a god that
was running more of a show that had more
of an influence on what happens on the
street level and that actually makes
sense because that was the same thing
with like with old man Logan and old man
Logan we saw were the villains took over
the world dr. doom had his own section
of the country and dr. doom turned it
into a safe haven he was like anybody
who comes here will be safe from all the
other villains
out there from all the other bad guys he
made it a refuge instead of ruling it
you know with an iron fist like kingpin
did by The Incredible Hulk did like Red
Skull did dr. doom turned his area into
a refuge and that's really seeming what
was going on with Luke a Luke Cage ran
for the streets with an iron fist but if
you were an innocent if you were a
bystander if you were doing the right
thing
he would make sure that no harm came to
you and so it was really kind of cool
with regard suited to his character and
what he did but with regards to Magneto
this is basically switch over to Genosha
and again Genosha was a safe haven that
it existed for quite some time the way
this worked we just went all the way
back to the 1990s and magneto was
basically being re reworked as a
traditional villain in the 1990s because
under Chris Claremont magneto had kind
of been changed up to where he was he
started out as a villain he became an
antihero then he became a good guy where
he was leading the x-men but Marvel had
always kind of felt especially when it
came to the Scott Liddell era after
Chris Klieman and Jim Lee Marvel always
felt that magneto should have just been
an archetypical villain he should have
been V villain of the x-men the one they
keep facing off against and so this led
into the events like fatal attractions
this led into onslaught saga it led into
a lot of these really really cool
stories but magneto had basically
threatened to wage war against the earth
and the governments of the world gave
him Genosha and island unto himself
we're mutants could be safe from the
persecution of humans eventually this
led into Grant Morrison's new x-men in
2001 with the first story arc es for
extinction which saw this weird persona
this weird aspect of Xavier 's sister
something strange like that basically a
chick named Cassandra Nova taking
control of sentinels and wiping out 16
million mutants in Genosha and so after
that after the events of use for
extinction Genosha was always just a
wasteland it was always just this barren
place that was once the home of millions
of mutants and nobody ever really wanted
to go there it was like you know there's
this place that magneto ruled where
there was no one to rule but it was the
place he always called his home and so
again with this House of M this shows
Genosha restored not only that Genosha
is much greater than it ever was it's a
huge illustrious futuristic city is how
magneto always envisioned it is how we
always imagined it and so again this is
just kind of us being told everything
that's going on not only that the
Scarlet Witch has children but her
children have the ability to control
reality as where kids are wildly
powerful in terms of their capabilities
but this is when bindus starts to
introduce a plot device and it's what he
always does in house
it's a girl named Leila Miller Leila
Miller is presented to wolf rain by Luke
Cage and the reason why is because
Levine says this isn't how things are
supposed to be this reality has been
screwed up this reality has been
distorted now Leila Miller the reason
why we say she's applied device is
because her powers are never explained
her powers there's there's no real
explanation in terms of what it is that
she can do it's just she knows how
universes work she's like I just know
how things work I just know how things
supposed to be there's no explanation to
exactly what her powers are she's just
there and she's just like I know that
things have been screwed up I know the
things have been distorted that's it
that's and that's that's basically been
to say here's a character that's going
to get us out of house of am now from
here it's a matter of going through and
waking out people and that's what Leila
Miller had been doing Leila Miller had
been going from person to person
initially starting out with Luke Cage
going to cloak going to you know these
various individuals and waking them up
to the way that things are supposed to
be and the first person they go see is
Emma Frost of course again will range
basically kind of guiding them here
because he remembers all these different
members of the x-men and who it is
that's the most prominent who it is it's
the most powerful and who it is that
would likely be on their side because
the last thing they want to do is wake
up somebody like juggernaut who's gonna
turn around and just start attacking
them all so that's that's something they
don't want to do here it'd be funny but
it's something that they don't want to
do so waking up Emma Frost this is when
we basically find out that when scarlet
which had worked reality that she had
done it using the mind of Charles Xavier
that's why he's not here of course
Charles Xavier is also basically dead of
course we find that out you know and
we'll find that out in the next video
but it's something that I think is well
known with a story being twelve years
old or something like that but the idea
is that she it basically sees the mind
of Charles Xavier she had used his mind
to read the minds of everybody in the
world and what she did is she altered
the house of Emma she altered the
universe to give everyone in the world
their hearts desires now it wasn't
surface thoughts it wasn't like they
were walking down the street and they
were just thinking at the time she
happened to read their minds man I
really wish I was the most popular
superhero it wasn't like that it was her
basically reading the core of who they
are the most fundamental part of who
they are and what they're about what it
is that they want the most in their
heart and soul and gave them that and so
even if they didn't know what they
really wanted the Scarlet Witch did and
she used the mind of Xavier and then she
altered reality in order to achieve that
and so this is when Emma Frost
basically lashes
this is her saying this entire place the
you know the reason why magneto is
running the show here is because magneto
always wanted to run the show that he
always wanted to be the one in charge he
always wanted newtons to be at the top
and humanity to be subservient to
mutants in return Magneto's you know I
guess monarchy is called the the house
of Magnus as why it's called the House
of M it's the house of Magnus it's the
house of magneto he's the most powerful
being in the world he's the one that
runs this show and so in response to
this Emma Frost basically says we have
to go find Magneto and we're gonna kill
him because if all this happened then it
had to have been because of Magneto it
had to have been because he basically
got his daughter to do it he told
Scarlet Witch alter reality change
things to this perfect world and then
everybody will be happy everything will
be okay
okay so continuing with House of M now
that I think about it after recording
that last video because I haven't
uploaded I usually record like four or
five videos in a day but after recording
that last video I was sitting to
thinking I was like maybe we should like
do a really quick explanation of what
happened in the House of M universe so
for the Civil War event there was a
house of M taya actually there was a
handful of House of M times I want to
say it was a story arc but the idea was
it basically laid out how magneto rose
to power and all that really happened
over the course of those stories was
that magneto was basically attacked you
know he was it was an attack on mutants
in like the late 1970s I want to say
close to 1980 and that resulted in
magneto discovering a plot between the
government and basically the military in
an attempt to get rid of mutants and the
result was that the president of the
time I think it was Richard Nixon was
basically Elstad and then mutant lives
were put at the top of the list in terms
of priority that is to say mutants could
not be harmed now this had the benefit
of making sure that Xavier dream of a
peaceful coexistence came to fruition
but it was only ever temporary what end
up happening here was that mutants
basically began to infiltrate all
different forms of government because
nobody could attack that nobody could
harm them going through and in killing a
mutant who was treated harshly and then
killing a human and the result was that
new laws were passed by mutants for
mutants and that eventually magneto used
the entire conflict as a rallying point
took over Genosha and then made himself
leader he literally became Charles
Xavier but on a more on a not really an
evil scale but on a more power hungry
scale and the result was that magneto
basically rose to prominence as the most
powerful being in the world in terms of
political power as well as his
capabilities because remember magneto
controls anything that has to do with
metal with the electromagnetic spectrum
and so he could kill people by just
pulling the metal out of their bodies so
on and so forth and he's wildly capable
in terms of his abilities but again you
know kind of following out to where we
left off in the last video this is again
another instance where Venus just kind
of shows in depth nobody knows what Lela
Miller's powers are and the reason we
say that is because when it comes to
fleshing out people's a people's
abilities this is one of the foremost
traits of Emma Frost it's not the sole
purpose she serves but when it comes to
different mutants whose powers are
investigated it's usually Emma Frost who
does that for example she took control
of ice man's body one day and then came
to the realization that if he ever
gained full control of his abilities and
pushed them to the extreme he would be
mega level mutant the same thing with
Jubilee that you believes basically
detonating matter on a subatomic scale
she's just not doing it on a huge degree
but if she ever tapped into the full
gambit of her powers the result was that
she'd be able to display secrete nuclear
explosions on the world she could just
detonate matter on a scale that would
just create the equivalent of atomic
blasts she'd be able to wipe out entire
cities it'd be insane how powerful she
is Emma Frost is always kind of the
go-to person for figuring out how it is
to people's powers work and even non
mutants for example during the events of
New Avengers which will actually come
out after this Brian Michael Bendis lost
the story reintroducing Robert Reynolds
as who is the century and the idea was
to basically explore the personas of
Robert Reynolds and the void and this is
when Emma Frost began to dive in and
began to realize if the void ever
reached full potential full power it
would be totally unstoppable
and so again Emma Frost serves this
important role and so with her showing
up here and basically investigating the
mind of of Layla Miller trying to figure
out how her powers work and then saying
well we don't know and Layla Miller just
kind of saying well I just know stuff
again as Ben is basically saying she's
supposed to be a throwaway she's
supposed to be a character that's
supposed to go away at the end of all
this now the cool thing is that she
won't
and in fact Layla Miller will become one
of the coolest characters in Marvel
Comics for a little while like she was
really interesting for time especially
with her whole part of I want to say
x-factor investigations is that right
extract or investigations with Jaime mad
rocks I want to say that's what x-factor
became following the House of M and I
want to say he was they operated out of
mutant town he's I'm pretty sure that
was the case but that was all part of
decimation which comes directly after
this but the idea is it again you know
with Cyclops coming back again Cyclops
and Emma Frost being a couple Cyclops is
woken up as well and this is what
Cyclops is just like what you know and
he just kind of starts puking his guts
up after realizing that he and Emma
Frost were kind of together not only
that it was also the notion that
everything around him has been screwed
up everything a man who's been changed
now at this point it's just kind of like
this mad dash to start waking up people
left and right first they go to Peter
Parker and I think Peter Parker is one
of the best parts of this because in
this world that Spiderman lived in this
house of M universe Peter Parker was
married to Gwen Stacy Aunt May and which
was still with opal Ben because Uncle
Ben was still alive he literally had
everything he wanted the issue here is
that for his character he basically had
a kind of masquerade as a mutant he had
to pretend that he was a mutant because
if people found out he was a human he
wouldn't be in
we're near the same kind of freedoms
that mutants have and so instead of
simply saying well hey I was bitten by a
radioactive spider one day and I gained
the powers of spider-man he just said
well it was a genetic mutation I have a
genetic mutation that gives me the
abilities of a spider and so because of
this where he's waking up is basically
him realizing it's all gone you know the
death of Gwen Stacy at the hands of of
Green Goblin venom being married to be
married to Mary Jane Watson all these
aspects are part of his life that
everything he's left is not real and
it's a crushing experience for him
because he learns this while he's out
shopping with Gwen Stacy Uncle Ben and
on May so he basically has to look
around and has to realize that everybody
that he knows is gone everybody knows
that everybody that he cares about is no
longer part of the equation here but
continuing this trend of going through
and waking up various people I mean this
extends to Kitty Pryde to dr. Stephen
strange to Carol Danvers Carol Danvers
is kind of the messed up one because
it's light it's like they go to her and
they're like hey look remember you know
like you're the most popular superhero
in the world and she's like yeah it's
like well you're actually really
irrelevant like you're powerful but like
no one really cares about you that much
sorry it's kind of a mess it's kind of a
messed up situation but again you know
daredevil Matt Murdock I mean all these
people are just being woken up now the
cool thing is they actually run up on
Steve Rogers and the idea is like well
they know who he is because remember in
the immortal colonies Captain America's
a rallying point
I mean Captain America but what he says
is is almost lost like when Captain
America comes along and says hey guys
look I think we should take this course
of action the discussion is over people
are like okay let's do that like Dutch
that's how Captain America functions and
Marvel Comics and it's so cool it's one
of the coolest things because people
trust him that's one of the reasons why
Hydra Captain America is so cool and
that's why I am a hide for secret empire
because it's gonna be it's gonna be one
of the coolest things to see what
happens when the superheroes learn the
hero they trust the most is a bad guy
but in the end they basically say look
it'd be cool to have Captain America on
our side Steve Rogers is an old man
physically he can't fight and so even if
they were to wake him up and let him
know what was going on I mean one the
shock might kill him and two he would be
virtually useless to them because
there'd be really nothing he could offer
which is a total change over from the
things that were used to seeing I mean
it would almost be like Steve Rogers is
the one guy you want in your corner but
they don't have him there's there's no
need for him because he's not there now
from here we also end up picking up with
Clint Barton now
and Clint Barton effectively learns that
he was killed by Scarlet Witch remember
during the events of Avengers
disassembled we talk about to this in
the last video during the events of
Avengers disassembled when the Scarlet
Witch basically attacked the Avengers
and started manifesting all these Kree
warships out of thin air that Clint
Barton basically sacrificed himself to
destroy the Kree mothership now why he
couldn't just take the quiver off his
back so he wouldn't die I have no idea
but the fact remains here that he ends
up just sacrificing himself because of
what it was of the Scarlet Witch did he
learns that here he learns you're
supposed to be dead
but you're not supposed to be alive
you're supposed to be gone and so for
him as a crushing experience because
what he does is he temporarily runs out
now of course he ends up coming back but
this also coincides with the arrival of
like toad mystique Jessica drew rogue
all these characters basically being
told hey look what you know in this
house event is not how things are
supposed to be their memories are
basically restored or at least they're
woken up to how things are supposed to
be now the funny thing about this is
that it is that when Miss Nude finds out
that she was sleeping with with
Wolverine the two of them were together
like she freaks out and slaps him how
dare you like she just freaks out and
slaps him and it's just a funny reaction
because you know it's a very human
reaction for her but mystique is very
inhuman in a sense that I mean she's a
mutant but like she's really cold and
calculating too and so it's kind of a
funny situation here but with Hawkeye
effectively running out the idea is look
we don't have time to worry about him
because only really does to shoot arrows
anyway who cares we have bigger fish to
fry and so what happens is that all this
should we start making these battle
preparations they start making these
battle plans of course they take over
one of the shield helicarriers and the
idea is we have to go take out Magneto
we have to force him to basically set
things back to the way that they're
supposed to be now from here is kind of
like this ribbit huge gala that's being
held this day there's almost like all
roads are leading to this particular
moment and we have the arrival of dr.
doom now this is a tie-in that came into
the house of him by way of the Fantastic
Four and Victor Von Doom really you know
like Reed Richards Susan storm all those
guys they were dead the only one that
survived the experience of the whole
cosmic radiation thing was was Ben Grimm
but the idea here is that Victor Von
Doom isn't so much like an equal to
magneto I mean nobody is but he has been
plotting to overthrow him but even then
Victor Von Doom knows this is a fool
Aaron just because of the fact that
magneto could easily kill him if he
chose to but the whole idea was that
Victor Von Doom was trying to find a way
to subvert Magneto's control of the
world and what
does is this really begins a sort of go
into what Jonathan Hickman would focus
on some four or five years after the
story was written with the Fantastic
Four when the Council of reads that has
to say this council of all these
different Reed Richards from the
multiverse would basically say no matter
what universe you're in Victor Von Doom
will always try to acquire absolute
power that's what he does that's how he
is no matter what his circumstance is he
will always try to attain absolute power
it's the intrinsic basis behind himself
now in terms of the house of him being a
dream the universe and in terms of
Doctor Doom getting everything that he
wanted this is basically him you know
replacing the Fantastic Four the
Fantastic Four never existed here but
again this is just kind of a business
interpretation of what it is a Doctor
Doom would want in truth I think the
best interpretation of what Doctor Doom
wants most was during the ultimate
Fantastic Four when he switched bodies
with Reed Richards when he became Reed
Richards that was one of the coolest
things when it came to that that line of
stories but that more or less seems to
be the goal here within this story that
there are no Fantastic Four there's no
one there to challenge the rule of
Doctor Doom except for Magneto and even
then he's working against Magneto to
take his place now magneto knows this
and Doctor Doom knows that he knows but
magneto pretends that Doctor Doom
doesn't know and Doctor Doom pretends to
believe that he believes that magneto
doesn't know but he knows that he knows
everybody knows under siege to dark
territory I love you but regards all the
characters that are going on you know
all the things that are happening here
by now this is again really just kind of
like a last-ditch effort I mean you have
really like a combination of heroes and
villains working with one another for
the purpose of setting thing is setting
everything back to right so what this
does is this coincides with a sentinel
basically crash landing or intending to
crash land in Genosha of course magneto
is able to keep this from happening but
that is basically this huge onslaught by
spider-man she-hulk all these different
characters all showing up at the same
time in order to basically fight off
Magneto now the cool thing about this is
that while that main conflict is going
on it serves as a distraction that's
really all it is pay a lot of attention
to everything going on here so that you
don't look over there and the reason why
nobody wants anyone to look over there
is because cloak-and-dagger Leila Miller
and Emma Frost
are going to try to find Charles Xavier
but the issue is they basically run
across his headstone and remember
because of the fact that Hooke can
teleport make himself intangible he goes
on the ground only to find out that
there is no casket there's no body
there's no nothing this is more of a
memorial than an actual grave for
Charles Xavier
so the question is where is Charles
Xavier now at this point we transition
over to dr. Stephen strange who
basically makes his way into the
personal quarters of Scarlet Witch and
this is cool because Scarlet Witch knows
everything I mean it's not like she
altered her own memories in the process
she remembers everything that's going on
here right I mean she's just like when
dr. strange shows up and he says you
have to set everything back you have to
make things normal where's Charles
Xavier she's like I don't know where
Charles Xavier is and then this is when
she basically starts to go through and
give everybody or at least give us as
the reader an explanation of what's
going on and what we learned was that
back in the earlier part of the story
when Quicksilver and Magneto had this
great big huge argument it kind of left
with Quicksilver and Magneto in the room
and then switched over to Xavier is
meeting with the Avengers and the x-men
that magneto basically left and
Quicksilver was talking to Scarlet Witch
and said you know you could fix this you
can make everything right you could
basically warp all existence you could
change reality and give everyone the
world a dream of you could give everyone
the world that they loved now this was
done by Quicksilver out of love this was
done for the life of his sister to make
sure that she stayed alive but it was
also done for the purpose of the family
it was done to basically make sure that
no one would have a reason to seek out
her death and destruction and so with
this particular revelation coming to dr.
strained of course it gets passed on to
Emma Frost but then they're interrupted
by magneto now this is probably one of
the coolest moments in the story
absolutely loved this story and the
reason why is because when magneto is
basically woken up by the way things are
supposed to be he's woken up with the
memories he had Plus whatever everybody
knows at the time and so it's kind of
like this shared state that is to say
you know Emma Frost just kind of gives
him the knowledge of what led up to this
moment and this is when magneto
basically learns that Quicksilver
screwed everything up and so this one we
get this really cool moment where Maggie
you know just kind of lashes out and
just shouts what have you done in my
name boy and I love that so much because
this is Magneto at his angriest and
we've never really seen him in this
state before we've seen magneto
irritated we've seen him IFFT
we've never seen him like lashing out
angry at the world I think the closest
that we ever really saw to this was when
he ripped out the adamantium of
Wolverine but even then he was more like
irritated he was it was more like I'm
tired of the x-men getting in my way let
this be an example you know which of
course led into the onslaught saga when
Xavier shut down his mind but in his
wrath in his anger
Nino kills Quicksilver and in response
to this Scarlet Witch loses it now this
is why I say this is called a twitch at
her most powerful the most powerful that
she's ever been in the history of Marvel
Comics because her emotions come into it
for those of the guys who don't know
when it comes to characters with
superpowers in Marvel Comics their
emotions usually govern the state of
their powers it is to say they usually
keep their powers in check with rational
thinking they keep their powers in check
by trying to make sure things don't
spiral out of control but when a
person's emotions get the best of them
their powers just run amuck those mental
safeguards they put in place to keep
themselves protective end up losing it
they end up going absolutely insane
the only real exception to this that I
could probably think of would be like
Franklin Richards like Franklin Richards
in its most powerful state was during
Hitman's Fantastic Four but that was
because he had lived long enough that he
was able to channel his powers in
whatever way he needed to plus he
basically absorbed the powers of his
younger self so it was like - Franklin
Richards in one but that's just an
instance of how a person can basically
control themselves without allowing
their emotional state to cause their
powers to run amok molecule man's the
same way but with Scarlett which she was
already mentally unstable right I mean
she was already basically insane now
she's insane and she's grieving so she
literally lashes out at Magneto and
takes his mouth away
I mean alters reality so he doesn't have
a mouth anymore he can't talk and that's
why I say these are kind of crazy
because when it comes to people who can
warp reality on a on a cosmic scale
they're usually just kind of like modify
things or they use their powers to make
other people go away they don't usually
use them for like small purposes like
taking someone's mouth away the only
time I've ever actually seen this done
or seen something done like this where
reality itself was distorted in such a
fashion was during the crooked world
storyline with Matt Jim - purrs ahh
where you literally had Captain Britain
trying to face off against Jim Jasper's
and Jim Jasper's kept changing reality
around him we're like you know Captain
Britain would suddenly be like in a
schoolboys clothes
it was weird the way things were
unfolding but it was basically showing
that there was nothing he could do to
stop Jim Jasper's was actually kind of a
cool moment here but this is also a
Scarlet Witch effectively lashing out
now something to keep in mind here is
this not just her emotional state I mean
it is she's very very emotional here I
mean she literally you know she's really
just like resurrects Quicksilver ah but
it's also all the pain and all the
suffering that she's experienced and the
reason why is because you got to keep in
mind she remembers everything from
before she altered reality with the
House of M so she remembers being chased
after by people in
all villages who considered her and
Quicksilver to be freaks she remembers
being abandoned by Magneto
but then magneto coming back and using
them for his own ends for his own evil
schemes she remembers having a
relationship with vision only for it to
come crashing down when visions
basically his personality was removed
and he was just reduced back to a
sentient robot she believed that she had
kids and she did at one point only to
find out but they were basically just
the shards of a demon entity named a
Fisto who had been conquered or been
defeated by Franklin Richards
all she's known is struggle and strife
all she's known is lost that's it and
all that emotion all that anger all that
wrath all that pain and suffering all
finally comes to a boil it all finally
comes to a head and when it does just
like anyone who can't take anymore she
just lets it all out the problem is that
when it comes to someone like The
Scarlet Witch and the kind of power she
possesses there splash over all right
everybody gets a piece of the pie
whether you want it or not and so she
ends up just saying no more mutants and
so things just kind of snap back reality
goes back to normal but when it does 98%
of the mutant population lose their
powers now this is not something known
right off the bat and said it's
discovered over the course of a few
minutes instead well I guess it is kind
of right off the bat it is a few few
minutes but basically we just kind of
jumped back to New York we pick up with
Layla Miller and then of course we end
up joining an Avengers tower or Peter
Parker is back with Mary Jane Watson but
then we jump to the Xavier Institute and
what we end up having is Emma Frost
outside the Xavier Institute with a full
recollection of everything that had
happened during the events of house of M
with the last utterance being no more
mutants when she gets into the Xavier
Institute all but 27 kids have lost
their powers they're all gone
I mean vanished they're humans they have
no abilities whatsoever now there are a
few people here that do have powers for
example Nightcrawler still has his
abilities wolf rein ironically enough
remembers everything like from his whole
life every single thing all the memories
that he had that were screwed you know
that were scared that were screwed up
where he couldn't tell what was true and
false all of those have come back to him
and he remembers everything and it's
kind of interesting because this is
basically a soft reboot for the
character of Wolverine that's basically
what had happened to him because one of
the intrinsic aspects of his character
over the course of his publication
history was his memories I mean let's
say that like tomorrow you wake up in a
house of people that you don't recognize
you
seen any of them before and you say what
in the hell's going on what am I doing
here and they said what what are you
talking about this is your home you've
always been here I mean you you wouldn't
know what to expect well then let's say
like as you're trying to figure out
what's going on some you know kid comes
to you and says hey like they're lying
to you you've never been here before
this is not your home well then what's
true and what's not suddenly you're your
entire life's in a tailspin because you
don't know if you've really been in that
house the whole time you don't know if
they kidnapped you and and mess with
your head
you don't know what's going on that was
always the aspect of Wolverine and one
of the core concepts of his character
was trying to flesh out the memories of
which ones were real and which ones were
false now he remembers everything and so
again this is Marvel kind of going back
and clearing out a lot of that history
removing a lot of those things the
downside to this is that this will began
the downward slope of wolf rain this
will begin the downward fall of
Wolverine where's character will become
more and more of a plot device of a
punchline within the realm of comics as
opposed to becoming someone that you can
really kind of not really identify with
but you can really kind of follow the
struggles up as he's trying to regain
his life now with regards to the huge
impact of the Scarlet Witch when Emma
Frost goes to cerebro remember this
device that allows her to are really
allowed Xavier and those who use it to
see the entirety of the mutant
population they find out there's only a
few like a handful here and there
there's you know five or six dots kind
of scattered around the world what this
means and what we'll find out is the
entirety of the mutant population has
been reduced down to 198 people where
previously there were hundreds of
thousands if not millions of mutants
around the world now there's only 198
now keep in mind this happens before
civil war and so this is the reason why
during the events of civil war the
mutants never became involved there was
a time where Tony Stark showed up and
said hey like I would really love to
have you guys on my side Emma Frost and
Cyclops said no we're we have a hundred
ninety eight mutants we're certainly not
gonna put those lives in jeopardy for
your stupid civil war against Captain
America so they basically stayed hands
off the entire time now the reason why
they were able to do that is because as
this story goes on what we end up having
and going into the events of decimation
which we'll talk more about that in
another video
but what ends up happening is with the
mutant population so low humanity says
well we kind of have to step in we have
to do something because of the fact that
something happened here even if it's
only for the sake of self-preservation
to make sure that we keep all the
mutants in one place they basically turn
you know the Xavier Institute into a
safe haven whether
198 meetings were at least a handful of
them most of them end up residing there
and so they were basically under
government protection the government was
basically saying you guys are not bound
by the restrictions of the superhuman
Registration Act that Act doesn't apply
to you you do not have to register your
identities which doesn't matter anyway
because we all pretty much know who you
are and we have you in one location but
of course with magneto being one of the
people who lost his powers as well the
question everyone has at least those who
remember the events of house of M the
question they have is where is Scarlet
Witch where is Wanda Maximoff magneto
has no idea and so what this does it
just begins to sort of bring this story
to a close and we end up joining this
this really cool monologue with Hank hem
and what Hanks basically saying here is
that when it came to mutant powers they
were composed of things they were
composed of matter they manifested
themselves as physical matter and they
resided within the body whether it was
you know Wolverines healing factor
whether it was somebody's ability to
warp reality whatever it was those
powers manifests it physically which
means they couldn't all simply just
vanish they couldn't just disappear into
thin air those powers had to go
somewhere either those powers formed
another planet those powers became a
star those powers are just kind of
dispersed on the atomic level and just
floating out in the atmosphere floating
out in space but they had to have gone
somewhere and the question is where did
those powers go now eventually this will
all sort of come to a head and Avengers
vs. x-men almost 10 years after the
story was written but following the
house of M going into the future of
Marvel Comics it stopped being about the
x-men versus the x-men and it started
being about character development it
started being about growing or kind of
reestablishing the x-men mythos with the
numbers being reduced how the x-men deal
with that that all these different
concepts that delve into that very idea
okay so uh I am moving I am moving to
Colorado and usually whenever I go on
like trips around moving or something
like that um I just kind of throw out
some pretty easy to digest stories
nothing too complicated or nothing too
wild we finished Jason Aaron's run on
the Incredible Hulk which i think is a
pretty good stopping point after that I
think it doesn't really get very
interesting and we can just kind of dead
end into the events of of all-new
all-different marvel but for this video
I wanted to cover the 198 because this
deals with the god Newton it deals with
mr. M Absalom Mercator this guy is nuts
like it's crazy the kind of things that
he can do now he had appeared in Marvel
Comics prior to the events of house of M
and he take up residence in a place
called mutant town now those are guys
who don't know mutant town was one of
these places in the realm of Marvel
Comics and it was basically home to
mutants for a lot of different people so
the idea was that it was really like a
mutant only area but it was really kind
of like for castoffs or people who
really hadn't just found their way who
weren't part of the x-men they weren't
part of a villain team it's kind of like
a no-man's land for a lot of the mutant
population some chose to live there some
chose to live regular lives and live
other places but the fact remains that
Absalon it kind of found a place for
himself there by just being a handyman
that's really all he did he just kind of
hung out and that was really about it
but he's a guy that has the ability to
work reality and so it was really kind
of crazy in terms of stuff that you
could do
truth be told what we see here in this
story I think is about as extreme as his
powers ever got in terms of us seeing
what it is we can do but it's pretty
impressive to some of the things that he
can pull off but the 198th this story
takes place almost immediately after the
events of house of M which is to say
after the Scarlet Witch works reality
and in fact it actually picks up with
magma now magma is a character who's
been around for a long time she was made
by Bob McLeod I think it was in Chris
Claremont but she goes back quite a way
she was part of the New Mutants she was
part of the Hellions she had a
relationship with empath for a while
which is actually something this invoked
in the story but at the time that this
aspect is being done you know this era
in her life she is a teacher for the
Xavier Institute and had actually gone
on vacation with her boyfriend Antonio
now as far as I'm aware there's not a
lot of information given about Antonio
where magma has the ability to you know
literally manipulate magma and so on and
so forth and Tonio it looks like a guy
who can manipulate fire and the two
actually go together pretty well
so he actually convinces her to
leaf-like to take an extra extra week on
a vacation
let me just go so like la cumbre thing
is what it is
to a volcano basically and just kind of
poke around and have fun and explore
their powers and so on and so forth the
problem with this is that remember when
the Scarlet Witch warped reality and she
basically created house of M and then
said no more mutants and set everything
back what it did is it created this wave
that spread throughout the world and
just started stripping people of their
powers so it's like an ocean of power
that was just riding around the planet
and people were just losing their
abilities when it passed over them in
this instance the loss of Antonio's
powers coincide with the fact that
they're inside a volcano so he's
literally melted alive just by the sheer
heat and the magma itself magma would
have been able to stop this right like
she would have been able to prevent it
but it happened so quickly and so
suddenly that there was no saving this
guy so in a fit of rage she loses her
mind and lashes out now from here we
pick up with a couple of ancillary
characters you know for example a group
called purity now purity is not to be
confused with William strikers purifiers
there are a whole different organization
and they'll be focused on you know in
the events of Messiah Complex assuming
that we get around to it but the purity
group is really more of just like street
thugs masquerading as hey we're making
the streets pure of mutants so on and so
forth but following the events of house
of M with word getting around to a lot
of people in the world that you know 2.8
some odd million mutants have basically
lost their powers that what this does is
it sets in motion the idea of a lot of
these anti-mutant groups rise in a
prominence more so than they were before
instead of slinking around in the
shadows taking potshots here and there
they effectively came out of hiding
because now they have the courage where
they're being so few mutants left and so
because of this it immediately draws the
attention of a guy by the name of toad
of course a young woman is attacked you
know because of the fact that these
purity guys are kind of crazy but toad
of course helps her out where this girl
is basically scalped in the process now
in terms of Absalom mercator himself we
actually end up picking up in bellevue
hospital with the psychiatric wing and
the arrival of Absalom Mercator now of
course what he does is he actually meets
a girl by the name of Hannah Levi now
Hannah Levi was a girl who basically had
a tongue like a prehensile tongue like
toad but she has no real like crazy
powers right like she's not like a
telepath or a telekinetic or anything
like that what she's drawn the attention
of mr. M because they were friends of
mutant towns so again mr. M's kind of
going after those people that he was
friends with individuals who may have
lost their powers or something along
those lines but Hannah Levi is basically
a crazy chick you know she's more or
less insane and Absalom mercator
actually cures her of her insanity by
basically reworking this
she's in her room but of course
absalon's also aware of the fact that
mutants everywhere have been deep
powered and so hannah basically you know
beseeches him to actually travel over to
the Xavier Institute and see if it's
possible to fix the various mutant
population to see if he can either
restore their powers or the very least
try to provide some measure of order now
the crazy thing about his character is
he actually arrives at the Xavier
Institute and when he does he phases
through a solid wall and immediately
takes out the sentinels now these are
not the signals that you're used to
these signals belong to the office of
national emergency now the office of
national emergency was basically
organized and structured up for two
purposes the first was to deal with the
possibility of mutant threats and the
second was to protect the mutant
population in the event that something
like this happens and so what happened
is you know following the events of
house of M what we had talked about in
decimation was the idea that the office
of national emergency was mobilized the
sentinels as they exist here are
actually man meaning they're not
autonomous they're controlled by
individual people and they basically
stand outside and around the Xavier
Institute to keep people in and to keep
people from getting out and so because
of this with epsilon just kind of
showing up and just walking through
walls effectively uh some people view
him as something akin to a to a mutant
Messiah
while others view him as a dangerous now
of course the x-men are the ones that
view him as being the most dangerous in
this example Emma Frost and Cyclops but
of course they're also in somewhat of a
weird situation too because prior to
this there was a lot of Xavier going on
the since the prior to Xavier taking off
hanging out with magneto while The
Scarlet Witch was being dealt with
before she warped reality Xavier would
basically answer these questions teach
people the things they needed to know
but right now Cyclops and Emma Frost are
flying by the seat of their pants
because the first instance in which they
basically become headmaster and
headmistress of the school officially
meaning that they are basically running
everything on their own
absent Charles Xavier in his entirety
which means no one knows where he is
things go absolutely arrived everybody's
looking at the Xavier Institute as a
safe refuge things are about as crazy as
they can get and then suddenly they have
this guy epsilon to just shows up and
he's doing things like automatically
evolving organisms manipulating reality
on a scale that people can't really
begin to comprehend not only that this
girl Lorelei who had basically you know
been scalped by these purity guys he
just immediately regrows her hair this
is the kind of power that we're talking
about here and so leading to the war
room a conversation between the x-men
you know the core members of the group
addressing everything that's going on
the
first thing that comes up you know for
discussion is mr. M himself now of
course going through their analysis
looking at his powers looking what he's
capable of the first thing they say is
this guy is an omega-level mutant now in
truth mr. M is beyond omega-level
there's only a handful of mutants who
are like that but he is a beyond
omega-level mutant meaning that there is
no limit to the abilities that he has
and he's a universal threat which means
that he could presumably be you know
kind of evolved into this Universal
being a cosmic entity or something along
those lines now that's usually the case
when it comes to people who can warp
reality on such a scale in the same way
that he can't so force where the x-men
can't really wage war against a guy like
this because of the fact that he seems
to be coming in peace they just kind of
let things go and say look you know
we'll keep an eye on and put us kind of
keep things in check and we'll
eventually see what's going on now with
regards to the 198 in this sort of
turmoil that begins to erupt this all
really starts from the idea that some of
them want to leave and this is when we
start running into the issue of no one
gets in no one gets out so for those
people who are in here some of them look
at it as a safety place you know look at
it saying look these various extremist
groups cannot get to us
for others they look at it and say this
is a prison we're not allowed to leave
now of course what this does is this
brings in Valerie Cooper now Valerie
Cooper has a long-standing history in
Marvel Comics she was basically you know
the the government liaison for X Factor
but by being associated with the X
Factor team which in turn was associated
with the x-man it made her friends to a
wide array of the mutant population when
it came to superheroes and it made her
an enemy to a lot of villains Valerie
Cooper's about the closest thing the
x-men have to a friend when it comes to
the government sector of the United
States so because of this Valerie
Cooper's the one that basically
organized all this stuff she's head of
the office of national emergency she's
the one that's basically safeguarding
the mutants but ultimately this
rebellion are this this revolution of
sorts is leading to some turmoil just
because of the fact but there are those
who want to leave but they're not really
allowed to leave now of course Absalom
Mercator steps up yet again in the
middle of this conflict and basically
says look you guys don't need to be
fighting he literally brings everything
to a halt like he just stops his
sentinels and simply just again gives us
another display of the extreme power
that he possesses here this is just the
tip of the iceberg the stuff he's gonna
do later on it's gonna be absolutely
nuts but we also picked up with a guy by
the name of John Dee now John Dee's kind
of a weird situation here and the reason
why I say that is because of the fact
that that John Dee or Johnny D or
whatever you want to call is basically a
new introduction
to marvel comic's but he's kind of
strange he has this weird appendage in
his chest but what it basically does is
it creates voodoo dolls of people so all
he has to do is introduce a strand of
DNA and it'll pop out this little voodoo
doll that he can basically control to
make it do almost anything he wants to
in this first instance because of the
fact that he had spoken with magma
because he had pulled a piece of her
hair it ultimately gives him the ability
to make a sort of voodoo doll of her
that he can use for you know whatever
purpose and her physical body will do
whatever it is and he does with that
doll now of course from here we pick up
with his first major revolution among
the 198 and the reason why is because of
the fact that these mutants who are
residing within the Xavier Institute are
basically told look because of the fact
that some of you guys wanted to leave we
can allow you to do that but the problem
is you cannot leave unsupervised and
this is the danger of this whole thing
and truth' valerie cooper has the best
interest of the mutant population at
heart she's literally doing what she
believes to be the right thing and what
she says is we are going to allow you
guys to leave under two conditions the
first is that you guys carry an
emergency cell phone you know so that
you guys can basically contact the
office of national emergency if anything
pops off people try to attack you or
ever the case may be but we're also
going to tag you guys so that we can
keep track of your location now the
first part isn't a huge thing walk
around with a cell phone whatever most
folks will probably just make
long-distance calls and probably abuse
it but the problem with being tagged is
that now they feel like animals and
rightfully so because that's the whole
crazy thing about this one thing you
guys got to keep in mind is that when it
comes to a lot of these mutants who are
residing within the Xavier Institute
they all come from different walks of
life some of whom who have extremely
exotic appearances took up residence in
mutant town where they didn't have to
worry about the oppression of people
others were Morlocks they resided
underground not all of them had the
benefit of walking around like Emma
Frost with no one having any idea that
they have telepathy or some power that's
simply undetectable by physical
appearance and so for a lot of these
folks all they've known is struggle and
strife all they've known is people
giving them a hard time because of their
physical appearance or because of the
way their powers manifest or because
they can't control their abilities or
any number of things and then to be told
hey look this is a safe haven that you
cannot leave unless you allow yourself
to be imprinted with a tag this
inevitably leads to conflict it
inevitably leads to battle between all
these different individuals now of
course what also ends up happening here
is we end up finding out that again
Johnny D's been going through and making
all these different voodoo dolls
of all these different mutants that
reside within the Xavier Institute now
he doesn't have all 198 but that still
makes it pretty dangerous because he had
single-handedly instigate a rebellion in
and of himself now at this point we
actually pick up with a guy by the name
of Mamo max I think it is how you
pronounce his name but he's a guy who
basically has the form of an elephant
for the problem with this is he's one of
a handful of individuals who left who
agreed to getting tagged and then
ultimately ended up taking off the
problem with this is that when he's
basically insulted by a normal person
and begins to lash out what we end up
finding out is that where Valerie Cooper
was told these tags only serve the
purpose of monitoring where these
mutants go we actually end up learning
that these tags also contain an electric
shock that will literally keep them in
check that will keep them from lashing
out and if they do lash out it'll
basically shock them and subdue them now
the reason why this is so significant is
because of the fact that the fear of
these mutants comes true they're
basically being treated like animals if
they act out they get an electric shock
and so they learned what to do and what
not to do they're very much being
treated like dogs the other half of this
is that one of these guys basically goes
about sort of you know doing his own
thing but he's a drug addict now we're a
voodoo doll had been created by Johnny D
Johnny D begins to experiment begins to
toy around and in the process strangles
the voodoo doll which in turn kills this
mute now the problem with jazz basically
dying here is that people don't know
exactly why and mutants see various
mutants who feel threatened begin to
make false corollaries what they
basically say is well mammal max over
there said that he was shocked by his
tag and jazz over here died so that
means that the tags are killing people
that's the conclusion that they come to
you now Valerie Cooper is basically told
look here's the whole reason why this is
being done of course getting the
information from her superior general
laser at the Pentagon who's really the
guy kind of spearheading this whole
thing and what he does is he actually
makes a legitimate case he says look the
reason why we tagged these guys is
because when you have that many people
from that many walks of life who are all
confined in a singular space it's only a
matter of time before something pops off
whether we're the ones that caused it
whether they caused it on their own they
were inevitably going to lose their
minds
you know the paraphrased Star Wars
they're animals and we're treating them
like animals because in a lot of ways
they're acting out just like children
but the other half of this is that
they're terrified all they know is that
some of them died and they don't know
why or at least one of them died and
they don't know why and so when their
life is on the line and they feel like
prisoners it's a return to the life that
they
to escape from when they join the Xavier
Institute in the first place and so
ultimately what ends up happening is in
the middle of all this fray
Absalom Mercator shows up and starts
taking people's tags out of their necks
you know because the tags are attached
to their skulls they can't pull them off
on their own but he begins popping out
you know their tags using his ability to
transmit matter and basically says look
by the declaration of cyclops himself
those who don't want to be here are
allowed to leave so if anybody wants to
leave with me we're walking out of here
and there's nothing they're going to be
able to do to stop me which there isn't
there's nothing they can do to stop him
and this is when we get another example
of his reality-warping power he walks up
to the eastern wall and transmits matter
so he basically breaks the wall apart
and creates a doorway for himself that's
the kind of power we're dealing with
here that's why it's so crazy and that's
why it's so extreme because what do you
do with a guy who can literally do
anything when he's leading all these
people when he's doing things like
walking on water
that's why things become so dangerous
because now Absalom Mercator is not this
mutant that has the ability to warp
reality now he's a messiah people look
at him and say oh he's gonna lead us to
the promised land they look at the
extreme power he possesses and they
start viewing him as a mutant God and so
that's why things get really really
dangerous here because now faith comes
into the equation this inevitably leads
to Cyclops and Emma Frost and so on
these guys showing up where Absalom
Mercator has taken these mutants this
little island right outside of the UK of
your Institute and says you guys have to
come back now keep in mind
Cyclops does not want a battle here one
because they have no hope of winning if
they were to actually find Absalom
Mercator under normal circumstances and
to because of the fact that he's trying
to preserve what's left of the mutant
population the mean population when it
comes to people who gain powers it's not
like normal humans with mutants there's
no guarantee that if meat was procreate
then another mutant could be born we've
seen a litany of stories where the
mutant gene suddenly just ends it just
stops and that's really the concern that
mutants have here is because with there
being no guarantee that two mutants
procreating will lead to another mutant
their numbers at 198 are small enough as
it is and it's entirely possible that
with 98% of mutants losing their powers
there will be no mutants born now of
course that's really the premise of
everything that takes place between this
story and Messiah Complex with the birth
of Hope Summers but that's still a very
legitimate concern for Cyclops and his
crew and so what is up happening here is
where a conflict initially you know
begins to erupt and we
end up finding out that Johnny G is
basically manipulating the bodies of
these various mutants to instigate a
conflict we also end up learning that
Johnny D is basically working for the
office of national emergency working for
general laser and putting his powers to
nefarious uses literally instigating a
conflict that will result in this sort
of mass destruction among all these
mutants and so what is up happening here
as epsilon just kind of lets loose he
literally just like in cases everybody
and says no one is going to fight there
is not going to be any conflict here you
will not harm my people now again this
is an extreme demonstration of power
because of the guy that can work reality
if he's angry at you then you're
probably done with all your living and
that's exactly what's going on here I
mean he's not really killing people but
it's the possibility that with a wave of
his hand suddenly everybody except his
people are gone any number of things
could happen that's the kind of power
that you're dealing with we end up
having Johnny D using his powers along
you know to basically create this
conflict between these mutants but with
Absalom mercator having such extreme
abilities his attention immediately
focuses on him and so where a lot of
these mutants are acting against their
own characters where they're doing
things they wouldn't normally do Johnny
D basically uses the power of leech to
touch
Absalom Mercator and take his power away
now this is a pretty significant thing
because remember when it comes to the
character of leech he was always
identified as a mutant that had the
ability to touch other people and
suppress their mutant powers but we
didn't know how far that went really up
until this story we didn't know if there
was like an upper echelon where there's
just a level of power they just cannot
deactivate because it's intrinsic to the
environment around them that's really
the way a lot of heating powers work
whether the character of Absalom
Mercator if he can work reality on a
universal scale does that mean that he's
part and parcel to the universe itself
and if so is leech trying to deactivate
his power the exact same thing is trying
to destroy eternity Absalon being able
to manipulate reality is just a
byproduct of his mutant factor and if
leech can shut off his power he can shut
off the power of anybody that he comes
across so I would surmise that in truth
leech is probably the most powerful
mutant in the world by virtue of the
fact did the best defense or the best
offense is a strong defense if you can
shut off the power of any body that
exists who's going to oppose you I mean
all the way take his leech with a
handgun walking around the world and the
mutant population doesn't exist anymore
the fact remains shutting off the power
of Absalom Mercator also allows Johnny G
to basically manipulate the power of
magma and destroy absalon's physical
body so
it's kind of a MacGuffin kind of a
caveat that leads to Absalom Mercator
being defeated and it's effectively
demoralized the entirety of the rebel
population among this mutant group but
ultimately what this means now is they
just resigned to their fate they don't
know what's going to happen next and so
in this last little moment here what we
end up finding out is that we're
funeral's more or less being held this
kind of visitation for mr. M that his
coffins actually empty and that he's
kind of evolved into a next you know
stage of evolution in the sense they
just kind of manifest as butterflies
it's kind of weird the guy like two
butterflies he comes back his
butterflies I don't really know but it
really just kind of ends on this high
note basically saying that nothing ever
really dies things just sort of evolved
and this is this kind of positive note
that is going it's kind of the calm
before the storm in the sense that
everything following this gets pretty
dark for the x-men things get pretty
brutal okay so we are jumping into our
x-men chronology and I'm not sure what
day I'm gonna upload this on but
whatever day it ends up being will
probably just be our x-men day x-men
I've been reading forever I mean it's
the first you know one of the very first
comics that really got me into comic
books per se the first comic I ever
owned was sovereign 7 and something by
Batman although I cannot remember what
in the world it was there's an old
Batman comic and I cannot remember what
it was but the villain was like this guy
that were all black and he had like
sharp claws it looked like and like you
tried to drown Batman and like the
sewers I think maybe he was after
nightfall I'm not a hundred percent sure
I mean I'm I'm pretty sure it was but I
remember if it was Bruce Wayne Batman or
if it was like John Paul Valle Batman
but I cannot remember for the life of me
but it was just a Batman comic and I
know it's a needle in a haystack
considering we've got nine hundred
some-odd Detective Comics and god only
knows how many hundreds of Batman comics
but I've been trying to figure out one
in the world that is I'm trying to
figure it out forever so if anybody
knows if just on that little description
alone you have an idea of what I'm
referencing post it down in the comments
I will be checking so hopefully somebody
has it but when it comes to the x-men
it's interesting because the x-men have
existed in Marvel Comics for a decade
the problem with this was that with
Chris Claremont riding the x-men for 17
years after he left after Gimli left as
artists in the early 90s the x-men just
sort of began to falter because nobody
was really able to bring the kind of
character development to the x-men
comics that Chris Claremont was able to
do this was compounded by the mid 1990s
comic bus and we don't need to go into
that suffice it to say it was a point
whereby marvel almost went bankrupt and
so by the early 2000s
Marvel was basically reshuffling
everything and the result was that we
got something called x-men reload now
x-men reload was this mid 2000s
initiative that was really kind of this
idea of just reshuffling the whole x-men
mythos and then just kind of boiling it
down to its core roots because over the
course of the 17 years Chris Claremont
wrote the x-men over the course of the
subsequent years and other writers like
Scott Liddell and Eno Grant Morrison and
so on and so forth with the x-men the
issue was you would get mutants who
would be rolled into a story they would
appear once and they would never be seen
or heard from again and the problem that
Marvel faced was that the number of
mutants out there had just grown too
high and so because of that x-men reload
was designed to literally reduce the
number of mutants down to the most
popular characters that's why we got the
event called House of M it was designed
to basically eliminate so many mutants
that were there and just boil it down to
its core roots and so following the
events of house of M we got this sort of
branding initiative called decimation
and so with uncanny x-men what this does
is this picks up with the fall of the
graves and I remember with our x-men
days we're covering almost everything so
you guys will basically find out what
all was happening unlike the x-men
universe side of things of Marvel Comics
we've done with almost everybody else to
this point you I mean we're in the
process of doing it with Avengers and
New Avengers we've done it with Captain
America we've done it with Ironman we've
done with spider-man because of that
with death of the greys this is designed
to actually wrap up in a lot of ways the
character of Rachel summers none of the
sense of its gonna kill her off but in
the sense that is basically sort of
allowing her to quote-unquote
start anew now under normal
circumstances I probably wouldn't have
covered this but Rachel summers is gonna
have a pretty significant role once we
get to the story of x-men deadly Genesis
which basically brings back the
character of Vulcan which is the third
summer's brother who's an omega-level
mutant but Rachel summers will be the
means by which he basically learns
everything that's going on but with
Rachel summer she's really really
intriguing
so in Marvel Comics as most of you guys
probably know they had a story called
x-men Days of Future Passed
an x-men Days of Future past at the time
that it was written was basically a
worst-case scenario right it was the
answer to the question what if the x-men
failed
what if Charles Xavier more macabre the
mutant geneticists and what if a
political figure Senator Robert Kelley
were all taken out by the Brotherhood of
Evil Mutants what would humanity's
response to that be well of course as we
know from the story humanity responded
by restarting the signal program the
Sentinels became autonomous they
conquered the entirety of North
humans and mutants alike and set their
sights on the world and so the story was
kind of a race against time because it
was the idea that the very various
European nations had effectively bonded
under one goal of eliminating the
Sentinel threat or North America so it
wouldn't infect anything else and so
they were basically launching nuclear
weapons at the US the result is that
Canada the United States all these
different territories were at risk of
being totally obliterated and so you
basically had the efforts of a handful
of mutants who had survived and we're
living in internment camps that were
trying to keep this from happening
Rachel summers is one of them
now the way in which this timeline fits
in is a little bit weird so bear with me
here for a second and Marvel Comics when
you see a story that takes place in the
future for the most part that's the
guaranteed future usually the story
involves somebody going back and
changing things the Days of Future past
was a story where the Sentinels
conquered North America and so the
question had to be asked if that was a
future were sentinels conquered North
America and they were trying to stop
that future then what happens to it when
they succeed to that universe where the
Sentinels conquered North America it
becomes an alternate reality is exactly
what it does and so essentially with
Kitty Pryde mind being sent to the Past
one of the x-men what was going to
happen and ultimately saving the day it
made the Days of Future past future
became an alternate reality
the future was unwritten we had no no
indication of what the future was going
to be until somebody came along and
wrote a story that involved the future
and the Days of Future past reality Jean
Grey and in Cyclops had had a child and
that child's name was Rachel summers but
Rachel summers like her mom was a
telepath and telekinetic and that was it
that was really all there was to record
her initially but she was the one who
sent the mind of Kitty Pryde into the
past and won the x-men days of future
past would happen and what would start
that whole process the problem with this
was that because it became an alternate
reality the future was basically
unchanged in that universe Days of
Future past progressed just like it did
the long and short of this is that
because Rachel summers basically looked
around and realized the future didn't
change the question was why why is her
world still the same and so what ended
up happening is Marvel wrote a story
called days of feature present and what
that was designed to do was role Rachel
summers into the main Marvel Universe
and so what she ended up doing was in
truth basically jumping from her own
universe into the main Marvel Universe
and into the past of the main Marvel
Universe and so the result was that we
basically got this new character who was
the daughter of Jean Grey now all of
this came out of the death of Jean came
out of the Phoenix saga the Dark Phoenix
August
it's up worth so Jean Grae had been dead
for quite some time you know she had
been gone for a little while and then of
course she ended up coming back as we
all know but the idea of bringing Rachel
into the fray
you know really kind of brought in a new
dynamic and it was really interesting
following Chris Claremont leaving the
title she just sort of bounced around
from one story to the next and nobody
ever really fleshed her out there were a
couple times where she went to go visit
the home of Jean Grey but she never
really tried to bond with the family or
anything along those lines and so
following the events of house of M
because of the fact that Rachel Summers
was basically in the white hot room
which is to say this sort of multiversal
space meaning that when house have been
happened and all the mutants lost her
powers she was unaffected when she
showed back up in the main Marvel
Universe she realized everything had
just sort of gone to pot and so what
this did is a kind of Center on an
existential crisis because deal with her
being a mutant and so many mutants
having lost her powers and her having
been you know one of the few who
retained her own that it get really get
kind of you know inspired this desire to
travel back and visit her family now
remember this is not Rachel's real
family and I say that because of the
fact that she's from a different
universe she's the daughter of Jean Grey
and Scott Summers from an alternate
reality so but the bonding process
happens almost immediately I mean
basically she kind of shows back God she
starts talking everybody and this had
been something that had been a long time
in coming I mean she'd met them like
once or twice but they knew who she was
I mean in terms of her being the
daughter of Jean and Scott you know from
different universes so on and so forth
but it was cool because this bonding
basically gives her a home that she
never experienced before because one of
the things about rachel is that because
she was universally displaced admit that
she didn't really have a home of her own
but for her it wasn't that bad because
the home she came from was was awful but
the cool thing is that with her bonding
with everybody learning about her own
past talking to various people one of
the other people that she comes into
contact with is basically her grandma
and the irony of all this is that her
grandma doesn't like Rachel she hates
Rachel in every sense of the word but a
lot of this really stems back to you
know this woman and her husband giving
up Jean Grey to Charles Xavier now I
remember at the time when Jean first
started to manifest her powers it was
one of those those things where no
parent really knew what to do because
Jean Grey was one of the first of a
handful of mutants that publicly began
to display powers so it's not like her
parents had a template it's not like
they knew where to go Charles Xavier
popping up and basically saying I went
to school for gifted children for people
that have abilities like your daughter's
I can help your daughter cope with her
power so on and so forth it was a
welcoming thing the problem with this
was that Jean Grey's
Furion says a lot of us know as part of
the x-men was tumultuous she was the
weakest member of the team she
eventually was catapulted to the
strongest member of the team she was a
harbinger possessor of the Phoenix force
she died she was resurrected she died
again she was resurrected and then
finally died I mean a lot of these
things started taking place with her
character bouncing around and all these
sort of scenarios happening but at the
end of the day her parents were largely
left in the dark they weren't really
told everything that was going on
instead it would just see their daughter
on TV fighting crime it would learn that
their daughter had died and so it
created a really strange sort of
scenario you know Rachel summers being
there basically reminds the parents of
Jean Grey of all the things they missed
out on and the idea that it may very
well have been a mistake to am I'll Jean
to go with Charles Xavier so again you
know she's very much a reminder of the
mistakes they feel they've made and so
ultimately what isn't happening is
there's this massive family reunion that
takes place and is cool because Rachel
gets to meet all these members of her
extended family that she never knew
about before the problem with this is
that almost immediately after this this
family you know begins to have their
whole get together people start dying
rapidly and it all happens within the
span of 24 seconds from right now until
I say that we've moved on everything
that we talked about happens in the span
of 24 seconds first member of the family
dies John grey following that we end up
having Fred Harriman he ends up dying to
all these members are killed from being
impaled they're killed from having all
these assassins start jumping in out of
nowhere and they all start dying
we have Nightcrawler who immediately
teleports in alongside a handful of
other x-men you know getting people out
as best they can and the reason for this
is because of the fact that when Rachel
summers immediately starts realizing
that people are dying she sends out a
kind of psychic backlash now this is
kind of a a side effect you know so to
speak for lack of a better word of her
being in the situation that she's in
remember Rachel summers having operated
having lived in Days of Future past
hardened her in a lot of different ways
she was combat trained combat focused
and so in this scenario when you
suddenly have all these Grey's dying you
know that so far happened in the span of
eight seconds rachel panics this massive
psychic backlash that goes out hits Emma
Frost first Emma Frost immediately picks
up what's happening alerts the x-men
Nightcrawler teleports in all that
happens in the span of eight seconds and
so it's crazy because these assassins
take no prisoners they're there for one
goal and that goal is to take out every
single member of the gray family they
can find this is a very powerful and a
very capable group and the reason why is
because this group is part of the Shiar
Empire they're basically an elite squad
of assassins they were sent here for the
purpose of eliminating what was left of
the Somers line now remember Rachel is
not a weakling she's not a person easily
taken out and by all standards of
measurement by this you know she our
assassin group they can't really kill
her she's still in possession of the
Phoenix force to a degree and the result
is that she can't be killed through
traditional means instead what they do
is they effectively brand her and what
this means is they'll be able to find
her anywhere in the universe no matter
where she goes now the other half of
this is that because this is a she our
elite guard this allows us to sort of
bring in a discussion about the Shiar
Empire now in Marvel Comics you got a
lot of different empires that exist out
there humanity is just a bunch of folks
who live on earth and there's some
really powerful people but that's it we
reside on one planet most people don't
even know about the various alien races
that are out there and so does she our
Empire is a massive Empire it basically
spans almost the entirety of its galaxy
consisting of thousands and thousands of
worlds but they are an amalgamation of
racism you know unlike the the Scrolls
which is basically the scroll Empire and
they're all scrolls the Shiar is a
variety of different races who have all
sworn fealty to the to the magistrates
or the Magister whoever it is that's
running this show at the time but this
assassin group going through is is
designed for one purpose to take out
these various people now the x-men are a
threat but at the end of the day they're
not necessarily in defeatable by this
group and in fact because of the fact of
the x-men have faced off against the
Shiar empire at different points over
the course of their publication history
what this means is that the Shiar does
have a pretty solid understanding of how
to get into earth deal with the various
superheroes who were there how to avoid
them if at all possible how to get their
target and how to leave without being
being seen the problem is they didn't
really bank on Rachel summers being
there and that was the cog in the wheel
broke the whole scenario wide open the
other half of this is that the
grandmother of Rachel summers the mother
of Jean Grey despises her existence and
this is one of the crazy scenarios
because her mother is basically grieving
within the span of 24 seconds which you
know we've basically ended this 24
seconds every single member of her
family has been totally obliterated
they've been totally wiped out destroyed
in a multitude of different ways it
happened so fast that half the people
who were there
didn't even know what was happening
before they died the whole idea of a
lane looking around and saying
everything I know and love is gone and
it's because of you she blames Rachel
the cool thing about this is her blame
is not necessarily misplaced while Jean
Grey was the Phoenix force and while
Jean Grey had died following the battle
between the x-men and the Shiar Imperial
Guard during the original you know
Phoenix and Dark Phoenix saga what this
meant was that the Shiar Empire was
largely hands-off the problem with this
was that when Rachel summers appeared
and then basically wielded the Phoenix
force for the first time what it meant
is that the Phoenix cannot only be
possessed by Jean Grey it can be
possessed by the bloodline of Jean Grey
and that presented a whole new credible
threat because with the Shiar Empire
looked to the Phoenix force and sees it
as a harbinger of the end of all things
meaning when the Phoenix force if it
loses its mind it'll destroy all that is
the Shiar Empire is operating in the
preservation of the universe but if
Rachel grey can have the Phoenix force
Rachel Gray's child can have the Phoenix
force and her grandchild can have the
Phoenix force and so on and so forth and
so even if Jean Grey was able to
maintain control to a degree even if
Jean Grey was a benign host for the
Phoenix force even if Rachel hasn't
necessarily displayed herself as an
overt villain with the Phoenix force it
does not mean that a grandchild or a
great grandchild or some descendant
later on down the line would basically
use the power of the Phoenix to destroy
everything in the universe and so this
is an act of preservation by the Shiar
Empire is not an act of aggression in
the sense of being rooted in malice and
so because of this the anger of a lane
is not misplaced
Rachel summers is a good person she is a
hero but she's the cause of all this
whether it was her intention or not is
irrelevant the fact is her actions
brought this down on everyone now of
course with the rest of the x-men
showing up the battles of foregone
conclusion there's no possible way for
this Shiar assassin group to possibly
succeed it's not gonna happen as a
result the Shiar assassin's group
basically bails out and they essentially
just take off and so what ends up
happening here is this religious sort of
this bonding moment between Rachel and
Scott Summers when it came to Rachel and
when it came to Cyclops their bonding
was strong insofar as they were more
friends as opposed to father and
daughter and it's been that way with the
offspring of Cyclops and Jean in a lot
of different ways Kable who was time
displaced and came back to the
the relationship between the two was
very strenuous at first it was really
one of those things where cable was more
like look your emotional attachment is a
distraction and I've got a mission to
fulfill so I'll catch you later
while you did know they were father and
son albeit cable looking vastly older
than his biological dad
they weren't didn't really bond as a
father in son only did it took quite
some time in Marvel Comics before that
was fleshed out but it was interesting
because with the character of Rachel she
never really bonded on the same level I
mean she did to a degree but it was
really one of those things where it was
hard for her and Jean Grey to bond
together it was hard for her and Cyclops
to bond together because Rachel
represented a future where they died and
everything had failed she represented
the worst case scenario for everything
the x-men did as basically all for
nothing so it's sort of it's sort of
interesting the problem with this is the
story sort of putters out it sort of
ends in a lackluster way in the sense
that Jean Grey basically takes her
family into the white-hot room that
afterlife more or less that's really
kind of it the reason why I say this is
kind of lackluster is because I mean
with the white-hot room it's weird
so okay here's one thing I want to flesh
out in this view I want to talk about
this for a second I want to talk about
the afterlife in Marvel Comics Marvel
has depicted the afterlife in a variety
of different ways where does an average
person go when they die in the Marvel
Universe so originally you just had
hella and Marvel coming so I know this
has almost nothing to do with the x-men
but bear with me for a second originally
you just had a helot and when the old
Stanley Jack Kirby's stories were
detailing you know tales of Asgard and
you know that oz Guardian mythos
basically anybody who died went to the
realm of health and that was it those
individuals who died in battle they went
to about how when mistress death came
along then it was basically an argument
of okay we have to split the difference
we have to find a way to reconcile the
tube so what Marvel said is you have the
realm of mistress death and you have the
realm of hella hella takes the souls of
those individuals who believe in Asgard
but did not die an honorable death those
individuals who believed in Asgard and
did die an honorable death in battle
presumably they've got about how
everybody else goes to the realm of
mistress death and that's it well then
you had Chris Claremont come along and
he started writing the x-men Jean Grey
becomes the Phoenix and she learns about
the white hot room which is depicted as
one of the various iterations of death
and so then that question becomes how
does that reconcile into everything now
if I remember correctly
Jean Grey met with a guy when she was in
the afterlife and that guy
was an aspect of mistress death and it
was basically mistress death saying that
when people are in the afterlife how
they perceived that afterlife is
contextual based on the life they live
so not everybody goes to like heaven not
everybody goes to like Hell or someplace
like that but then again you also have
all those realms that exist out there
you've got the realm of Mephisto
basically this demon entity who takes
the souls of those he tricks you've got
a heaven in Marvel Comics you've had an
actual Hell in Marvel Comics there
really hasn't been this sort of
consolidation and Marvel about how all
those things intertwine and how all
those things reconcile with one another
and so the white-hot room is just kind
of this place where the Phoenix goes to
do its work and that's really yet that
was the explanation that was given by
Grant Morrison that was the explanation
that was continued by Greg Pak during
Phoenix in song but the general gist of
this from what I've been able to grasp
when it comes to the white hot room is
that Jean Grey is basically able to take
those individuals to sort of Usher them
to the afterlife this is the only
instance that I believe I've ever seen
Jean Grey lead anybody to the afterlife
but it does bring that into the equation
and it does say it's possible but it is
kind of interesting because it does
bring a lot of these things into fray
and so ultimately what is of happening
is that with her entire family being
totally eradicated by this assassin
group from the Shiar Empire what is up
happening here is Rachel summers
basically swears revenge and so what
this is going to do is lead directly
into the events of deadly Genesis it's
going to lead into the events of Rachel
summers coming across Vulcan Vulcan
basically waking up and then her meeting
in omega-level mutant so powerful that
he can overwhelm and overpower Rachel
summers even with the power of the
Phoenix force okay so picking up with
our whole x-men chronology at this point
we start to transition away from the
traditional x-men team and we kind of
jump back to really the aftermath of the
whole event of decimation remember this
was a huge branding initiative so I mean
almost all the x-men related titles tied
into it in some form or fashion but the
other thing to keep in mind is that
because this was x-men reload and
because it was designed this sort of
reworked the x-men mythos that's exactly
what happens here the whole publication
with regards to new mutants and new
x-men and the x-men title and uncanny
x-men all that kind of stuff because the
publications had grown so just out of
control for the most part the idea was
to consolidate them all down into a
handful of titles and progressively
start reading out other publications and
condense them into a more manageable
form and so really while this is
called new x-men it's kind of a misnomer
this is really more of like a
continuation with regards to like
Generation X so a little bit of history
here in Marvel Comics you have different
versions of the x-men teams for the most
part originally you just had x-men by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby because it
wasn't that popular Marvel relaunched it
under Chris Claremont as uncanny x-men
and it stayed is uncanny x-men for
something like 17 years this continued
on until about 1992 and then what Marvel
did is they split the publication in
half and they basically launched the
second run of the second volume of the
original Stan Stan Lee and Jack curry
run and that's where you get x-men vol 2
but the whole idea is you had x-men and
then you had uncanny x-men and there
were two different publications and of
course you had the x-men roster split in
half which was you know the Gold team
and the blue team by the time we got
into the early 2000s we started getting
things like the extreme x-men we got
things like new x-men from Grant
Morrison which was kind of like a
reworked x-men vol 2 we got all these
different publications that sort of
tapped into the whole x-men roster the
x-men line so on and so forth but
Generation X was actually a really
really popular x-men related team and it
really focused on the nature of a
character by the name of Emma Frost now
Emma Frost was really really interesting
in Marvel she was introduced by Chris
Claremont all the way back in 1981 I
think when she was actually the leader
of a mutant school of her own called the
Massachusetts Academy and the whole idea
behind this was that it was one of those
really prodigious prep schools that also
had ties to the Hellfire Club of course
the Hellfire Club of least talked about
before being one of those organizations
that kind of operates behind the scenes
the whole idea behind this is that su is
part of the Massachusetts Academy where
Charles Xavier had the x-men at the
Xavier Institute Emma Frost had a group
called the Hellions and the whole idea
behind this was that it was a way to
sort of provide an antagonist ik team to
the x-men but really more to the New
Mutants in the sense for the new mutants
were the younger generation of x-men and
the x-men comics themselves and so for
the main x-men team had like the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants as their
main villains the new mutants had the
Hellions to face off against but the
idea with this whole thing was that what
we found was it eventually in the 1990s
I think they introduced a villain called
Trevor Fitzroy but basically Trevor
Fitzroy had shown up in the present day
and launched an attack using the
Sentinels the problem is that because of
the fact that it was kind of a
reshuffling of the x-men in the 1990s as
a response to the comic bus at least I
see
what Marvel ended up doing was killing
off the Hellions and then bringing Emma
Frost into the x-men proper and so when
she was basically vouched for by Charles
Xavier 'he's having basically turned
over a new leaf the result is that she
taught a new generation of mutants
within the Xavier Institute called
Generation X and they were largely
hands-off I mean there was really no
involvement from Charles Xavier
it was strictly ran by Emma Frost
herself but by the time we got into the
early 2000s Marvel had revamped you know
some of the x-men titles to new x-men
and that was basically this idea of
Grant Morrison coming on as writer and
revitalizing interest in the x-men and
so that runs all the way up to this
volume which is really kind of like
volume 2 of new x-men but while it's
titled that it's really more akin to new
mutants or to Generation X but what this
does is again because of the fact that
this picks up immediately after the
events of house of M we basically end up
joining with a guy who wanders into a
church that belongs to someone named
William Stryker now we have talked about
William Stryker so much on this channel
really you know we've talked about
immoderately you know recently but I
love the character of William Stryker
God he's one of the best villains in
Marvel because he's one of the most
dangerous villains who has no powers
instead he is extremely good at just
swindling people to his cause and we're
gonna find out exactly what do you know
how he does that in this story he
basically travels to this place two
years before the events of house of M
and of course you know swearing and
being angry at God because he believes
God forsaken him suddenly he's met with
a massive bright light and we never find
out where it's coming from
instead what we do is we pick up to the
morning after house of M happens and
it's cool because we're a lot of the
excellent stories after house of enemy
ordering destination follow the main
x-men team this follows the teenagers so
it's an immediate aftermath with regards
to the kids who are being affected and
the kids who are losing their powers so
we have all these different former
mutant sees of different teenagers Kevin
Ford known as wither who basically has a
death touch that he can't really control
Dallas Specter who could kind of put on
a shadow form he got all these different
characters who were basically waking up
and all their powers are gone
some people are terrified and some
people love it and that's why I love the
x-men story so much is because when we
look at superheroes we imagine man you
know what would it be like if you could
fly or how awesome would it be to
shape-shift or something along those
lines but for a lot of these kids even
if the powers they have is something
that we would
they don't want it because it makes them
a cast-off in society because a lot of
these kids have powers that don't take
on physical forms you wouldn't know they
had any powers if you walked by them
down the street but because of the fact
that they know because they're educated
in a special school different things
like that there's kind of a stigma
that's attached to them but a lot of
these folks are celebrating a lot of
these folks are excited about it while
some are terrified of it because when
they gain mutant powers they finally
understood their place they finally
understood where they resided in the
grand scheme of things but when that's
yanked away they end up right back into
the this existential crisis they've been
suffering the whole time well they
didn't know what their place was anymore
but we also end up doing is picking up
with Emma Frost who basically
communicates with the three-in-one now
the three-in-one is actually a really
cool concept the best way to think about
these is really just kind of going by
their name the Stepford cuckoos but they
were basically in attempt by weapons
plus the creators of Weapon X to clone
Emma Frost now originally there were
four but the idea is that I think you
had a Quinton choir who launched a sort
of revolution in the Xavier Institute
and then one of them died but basically
they're one of these things where they
have a hive mind but they are individual
telepaths they're not nearly on the same
level as Emma Frost but they are pretty
powerful the problem with this is that
the Stepford cuckoos are sort of
experiencing this massive backlash from
all these people who are panicking this
huge surge of emotions from all these
kids who are freaking out but we also
end up learning is that where Kevin Ford
had this death touch and really praised
the idea that he'd be able to touch
people now suddenly that's not the case
anymore and so again it's kind of crazy
and it's kind of wild because for some
of these kids for a brief moment they
believe they have a life of normalcy for
others they want a life of normalcy in
the case of melody Guthrie you know
arrow she has the ability to fly leaps
out a window believing that she still
has her powers to be saves her on the
off chance that she doesn't now one of
the saddest things that takes place is
with a kid named hydro now hydro was
interesting because he basically had the
ability to control water in a lot of
ways but the problem with this is that
he basically drowned he ends up dying
because of the fact that he loses powers
in the process and so it kind of shows
us this impacts people in a multitude of
different ways now one of the
individuals who does maintain his powers
is Josh Foley he's also known as a lick
sir he's basically a character that has
bio manipulative healing what this means
is he can heal anybody from virtually
anything but again it's cool because
we're sort of getting this refresher for
a lot of these different characters but
one of the
I hope you guys notice is much like the
main x-men story in the aftermath of
house of M were rapidly figuring out who
the stars of this story is going to be
the ones who maintain their powers and
get the most limelight are the ones who
are gonna be the stars everybody else
their background characters or they get
sent away what this also does is it
picks up with Danny moon star Danny moon
star was one of the original New Mutants
when the first story was when that story
was originally launched she's been part
of the x-men line for years now where
she did have the ability to sort of
create these telepathic illusions
meaning that she could basically create
the sword of a holographic constructs
using her mind based on what other
people were feeling at the time her
powers are gone and Emma Frost immediate
response is you have to go and that's
was so ruthless about this Emma Frost
and Marvel Comics in a lot of ways is
pretty hardcore she's pretty cutthroat
and it did work for her students in some
ways but remember all the Hellions died
so while she is kind of hardcore here
she's not nearly as hardcore she was
when it came to the actual opinions
themselves but the other half of this is
this stance of Emma Frost is that this
is a school for mutants this is not a
school for humans if mutants have lost
their powers they have to go and that's
pretty cold-blooded and so because of
this we of course pick up with Wolverine
with regards to the character of x-23
now remember Laura Kinney has been part
of the XR have been part of the Marvel
Universe for a little while now by the
time this took place so for the most
part Laura Kinney was always just kind
of off by herself the idea of the
Wolverine is to say if you still have
your mutant powers intact then you have
to come here it is interesting because
you basically you know like any parent
says you need friends
you have to basically form social
attachments because remember she doesn't
have friends and so grabbing those human
aspects and saying you need to be able
to socialize with people you have to be
able to like start conversations is
basically an attempt to bring her back
and to try to you know continue this
connection that he's been trying to
build all this time and so again
following this what we end up doing is
picking up two weeks after the events of
house of M and we basically join with a
kid named Jay who simply shows up with
his wings having been amputated so it's
really a crazy scenario so what we end
up doing here is we jump back to a year
before House of M so remember we're kind
of following William Stryker here but
what he ends up doing is basically
grabbing a guy named Jack Abrams but
notice what William Stryker does here
who you have Jack Abrams who's gonna
catch a cab and then William Stryker
pulls him off sends the cab away
the cab is hit by a bus and basically it
would have killed jack Abrams if he'd
gotten into it but William Stryker
doesn't pawn himself office oh man I am
a guy who has all these abilities and
the answer to life's mysteries no no no
it's subtle it's easily believed all he
simply says when Jack Abrams says you
know how did you know that all he simply
says is do you believe in God because
God believes in you that's why I love
his character because it's not some
grandiose display of power or anything
like that is basically him just kind of
subtly manipulating people now of course
the aftermath to this is exactly what we
would expect it to be with regards to
the whole event of house of M mutants
losing their powers you know the kids
are channel surfing they're sort of
going through all these different things
and the news broadcasts are all the same
that you know there's this reported
massive reduction in the mutant
population but following this they
basically end up on this broadcast with
regards to William Stryker who's
directly addressing all these different
people but notice the people in the
purple cloaks those are his followers
they are basically the purifiers and
it's kind of crazy because once he
actually does this full-on interview we
get a little bit of the backstory you
know with regards to his character the
fact that he first popped up he was
basically a mutant hunter he was on TV
pulled a gun on Cyclops he was arrested
ultimately freed there was a massive
battle took place between him and the
x-men in Madison Square Garden so on and
so forth all these different things that
go on to the history of his character
but notice the things he says he
constantly brings in religious tones
that God has a plan that God has a goal
if this happened is because God wanted
it to happen but what he says here
really one of the final statements he
makes is of the most ominous one of the
things he says is that sure all this
happened because God said it in motion
now is up to us to take the next step
he's advocating for the elimination of
mutants he's telling everybody mutants
have to go away but from here we really
kind of joined back in with it with the
students and dealing with issues and so
on and so forth one thing to bear in
mind is that with Emma Frost basically
sort of you know coming back to the
Argos going to the Xavier Institute sort
of launching her own out her own
training program so on and so forth
inevitably a group form that was kind of
like a continuation of the Hellions it
was sort of Emma Frost favourite kids
more or less now of course with this
whole scenario you gotta have infighting
among these kids you have those who are
aspiring to be x-men bushes those who
are aspiring to be hellions and so it
creates a little bit of infighting but
also notice the interpersonal
relationships the argue
the fighting the romance you know you
have like Hellion who's chasing after a
girl this girl doesn't really like him
you know Julian's like look you're kind
of a jerk I don't want to have anything
to do with you he insults one of the
people who have gone back to being a
normal human while insulting her at the
same time it's the the nature of what it
means to be a teenager and so what we
end up doing is of course joining with
Wolverine showing up alongside x-23 and
basically saying this is your new
classmate she can kill every last one of
you if you wanted to so don't give her a
reason to you guys are introduced peace
it's classic Wolverine a man of few
words but with regards to the whole idea
of Cyclops Emma Frost the the arguments
that go on between the two you wanting
to bear in mind is a cyclops is very
old-school when it comes to the x-men
Charles Xavier believed in a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
and as terrible as the circumstance is
with regards to so many mutants losing
their powers in the mind of Cyclops it's
an opportunity to extend an olive branch
and to show humanity mutants are not a
threat why because some of the kids who
are mutants lost their powers they're
human now
but they're still allowed to stay there
in the mind of Cyclops all Emma Frost is
doing is driving a wedge between
humanity and mutants even more so than
their re is they both have these
diametrically opposed views but they're
both right in a lot of ways in the mind
of Emma Frost you know if these kids are
here it's gonna make them a target it's
gonna draw people here but if the kids
go out into the world they're also gonna
be targets as well that's the argument
of Cyclops but in the minds of both of
these characters they staunchly believe
they're right when it comes to their own
viewpoints so of course at this point we
have the Hellions and we have this you
know the new mutants more or less kind
of coming together into a makeshift
Danger Room that have been you know they
prepare for themselves and it's kind of
cool because we get throwbacks to a lot
of these old stories for example fall of
mutants and elixir Joshua Foley's kind
of like you know I don't I have no idea
who I am right now you know I've got a
mullet and I got blond hair he's
actually a character called longshot one
of them becomes destiny another one it's
arc angel another one's havoc is a
classic story there's the whole scenario
with the brood all these different
things are going on you know these last
little tidbits of storytelling that are
jumping in with regards to getting some
history here but at this point we jump
bat six months ago continuing to follow
William Stryker
with regards to a guy who's taking out
someone named Bob forward now Bob
forward isn't really relevant here but
this guy gets a call and basically says
if you don't get your family out of
their house by 4:01 a.m. which is
roughly 45 minutes from now they're
gonna die and so this guy of course
Matthew Richman who's basically an
assassin for hire treats it as an
absolute truth and then runs grabs his
family just because of the fact there's
a storm there's a mudslide gets them out
of the house in time and he's met by
William Stryker this is why I say I love
his character you know he basically
called this guy and said your family's
gonna die if you don't get him out of
the house soon enough when he shows up
he's there to greet the guy and to say
look just because of the fact that
you're a man who's done some bad things
does not mean that you don't stand the
right to be in God's army God needs
soldiers just like anybody else and
sometimes what you need to catch the
sinners is a sinner himself William
Stryker is so charismatic he's so good
at drawing people in praying to their
weaknesses and inducting them into his
ranks and so it's really interesting
it's really fascinating to me how his
character is written the other thing I'd
like you to take note of here is how
Emma Frost views x-23 with Emma Frost
herself her perception of Laura Kenney
is that she's a killer and she's nothing
but a killer and in a lot of ways Emma
Frost is right Laura Kenney was trained
to be an assassin for hire she would be
sold out to the highest bidder who in
turn would have Laura Kenney take out
whoever it is they wanted to have taken
out the result is that where she's been
trying to find her way ever since Emma
Frost does not see her as a potential
asset to the team
she sees her as someone who's a
legitimate danger now remember this was
kind of cool because in a lot of ways
this is designed to mirror the original
x-men stories when Wolverine first
showed up there was a lot of opposition
when people learned about Wolverines
past what little tidbits that we got as
a reader that kind of thinks he's done
how ferocious he is there was a lot of
opposition to Wolverine being on the
team this was compounded by the fact
that Wolverine was basically sniffing
after cyclopses girl he was gunning for
Jean Grey and it was kind of funny in
terms of how all that works because
Laura Kenney is much the same way but
where Charles Xavier gave a shot to
Wolverine and said you can be on the
team but mind your P's and Q's Cyclops
is extending that branch to x-23 because
Wolverine vouchers for now that's
designed to show the trust that's formed
over the years despite the fact that
they don't always see eye to eye despite
the fact that there have been times
where Wolverine and Cyclops have gone to
blows where you're not sure if one of
them is gonna survive at the end of the
day when it comes down to it they've got
the others back 100% of the time every
step of the way and that's the kind of
camaraderie that forms in the x-men team
Emma Frost
doesn't see it that way Emma Frost's
argument is this girl is evil she starts
playing mind games with x-23 tricks x-23
into seeing her dead mother trying to
run
23 out of the school trying to get Laura
Keaney out of there the response is one
way or another you're going to leave
this school whether it's because you
leave in a body bag or if it's because
you leave willingly you're going to be
gone and so what we end up doing here is
we basically pick up a little bit when
it comes to William Stryker again
joining right after the events of house
of M so again this is the point at which
you know the characters are starting to
realize their powers are gone you know
and so on and so forth again this is the
multi-faceted nature of William Stryker
it's not always calling somebody up and
saying hey man your family's gonna die
you got to get in there you got to save
them sometimes it's just preying on the
weak and emotional when people are in a
weakened state when they're in a
vulnerable state they will believe
almost anything they want to believe if
it makes them feel better and where
William Stryker shows up to Jay who's
basically questioning his role in life
whether or not he should really be part
of the Xavier Institute so on and so
forth his idea with William Stryker
showing up is to basically say hey look
man there was an angel there the day
that you lost Juli and these terrible
things happen in your life God has
angels to protect people you have
angel's wings you are a servant of God
and you are going to send a message to
the x-men and so what seems to be
happening here is that William Stryker
is the person responsible for severing
the wings of Jay when he showed back up
at the Xavier Institute with his wings
amputated now that is classic William
Stryker on the surface he's nice you
could see him being the kind of guy who
would show up to his grandkids give him
presents you know and they were bouncing
his life and he tell him stories be the
nicest guy ever and then as soon as they
go to bed he's plotting and scheming on
how to kill all the mutants that's
classic William Stryker but of course
Emma Frost basically initiates an
exercise to essentially stem out those
who can't hack it those of you who
succeed will become the new mutants
you'll become the new x-men those of you
who don't will be dismissed you'll be on
the sidelines and we'll use you if we
need you now what she's really doing
here if she's using this as a scheme as
a smokescreen she basically tells
Hellion I want x-23 taken out of here
this is all designed for the purpose of
trying to find a way to get rid of X 23
but by happenstance everything seems to
benefit X 23 even when Emma Frost shuts
her body down and keeps her from being
able to move where other members of the
hell use try to take her out where other
members of the x-men try to take her out
at the end of the day Hellion is the one
who basically saves her and tells him a
frost I'm not gonna take this girl out
we need this girl just like we need
everybody else now of course initially
x-23 is not given a spot but of course
Cyclops steps up and says yeah
she is she's gonna be given a spot on
this team and so what we do as this
starts to wind down is we pick up with
William Stryker who's basically amassed
a massive following there's hundreds of
thousands of people here to say nothing
of the millions who are watching again
feeding on the weak feeding on the
desperate and so the result is that he
basically comes out and he says God's
taken the next step it's up to us to
finish it the mutants are a credible
threat we have to get rid of them
because they're not like us and instead
of people shying away instead of people
saying this is bigotry this is racism
this is evil people celebrate people
cheer but notice this they're not
thinking rationally because what would
happen if somebody came along and they
said you know if magneto popped up and
they said ladies and gentlemen you know
because of everything that's going on
mutants are in danger now in order to
keep things safe we're gonna kill all
the humans we're gonna kill every human
we come across because look at their
history the world is better off without
humanity how many of these people would
celebrate that how many of these people
would cheer and say yeah yeah humanity's
dangerous we all need to go away of
course they wouldn't because the
standard is OK when the standard doesn't
affect them and so again it's
interesting with regards to how this
whole thing unfolds and how these people
view the world and so what we end up
having is basically all these kids who
have essentially lost their powers and
they're basically sit on a bus you know
when they're sent about their ways I
mean presumably they're gonna go back
home you know they go back to their
families but before they get even 20
feet from the house a missile comes in
and blows the whole bus up killing
everybody on board
okay so following up to decimation what
I want to do here is I want to cover
Wolverine origins and endings because I
think this is gonna give you guys a
pretty good idea of the direction that
Marvel was going in with regards to the
different characters and teams of stuff
like that so this focus is almost
entirely on love reign it involves Bucky
Barnes Captain America so on and so
forth but this is an example of where
Marvel was kind of going back to the
drawing board with characters because by
this point we're at the tail end of
Wolverine vol 3 and what this story does
is it actually sets the stage for the
start of Daniel weighs Wolverine Origins
which was really kind of cool and
involved Romulus and involved the
introduction of bacon and involved all
kinds of really cool things but what
this does is it kind of follows up to
Wolverine regaining his memories because
remember at the end of house of M
Wolverine remembers everything about his
past and so this is a little ambiguous
in terms of how it starts because it
initially just kind of starts with a
conversation between Wolverine and Emma
Frost over the phone but this was the
most logical course of action because
with Wolverine regaining his memories
now we had a lot of questions and that's
one of the things that he says here is
that for him regaining his memories he
thought would be like an answer to all
of his life's problems but all it's done
is open up more questions in terms of
what's been happening so far and so what
happens is his journey has basically
taken him to Tokyo Japan and the reason
why is because he's basically tracking
down the Prime Minister of Japan now on
the surface he's not intending to find
the Prime Minister what he's intending
to do is find the captain of the Prime
Minister's personal security detail the
silver samurai now the silver samurai is
the son of Shingen Yashida I think it is
as part of Clan Yashida it's one of
these many clans that existed in Japan
for quite some time that was involved in
criminal activities but the silver
samurai have served a pretty significant
history in the realm of Marvel comics
not really popular the silver samurai
was like never part of the avengers or
anything like that but he was part of
like the Japanese Japanese team big hero
six different things like that and by
the way that was kind of an interesting
thing what Disney did with big hero 6
was borrow the name from Marvel Comics
just because of the fact that I wouldn't
really go see a movie about the big
about big hero 6 and my whole comics but
it was kind of a cool cool situation of
a big hero 6 was really like a like a
Japanese oriented a-team who is based
with like like I want to say Sunfire a
silver samurai a handful of small-time
characters and it was kind of
interesting but the reason why Wolverine
is here this is a basically question
silver samurai just because of how far
back his his knowledge in Japanese
history goes the various ties that he
has to
his aspect or their being the son of
cleinias Sheeta it makes a really
interesting situation because Wolverines
basically trying to retrace his steps
now what he's doing is basically
tracking a guy down and who that person
is we'll find out but what we end up
doing is we basically switch over to two
dum-dum Dugan along with Captain America
Jessica drew Spider Woman and Iron Man
the reason why is because they're
panicking at the mohuru Burt Wolverine
is a one-man army I mean if you want to
wipe out a government you send in
Wolverine like we saw that with enemy of
the state right I mean when when war
ring was brainwashed by the hand and
Hydra he ended up going through and
fighting off against a multitude of
superheroes now the what-if story that I
covered where he kills the entire Marvel
Universe saw the the fruition of that
where every single time superheroes try
to stop them he killed him and it got to
the point where he killed them all
eventually Kitty Pryde had to kill
Wolverine by phasing her hand through
his head and basically destroying his
brain she lost her hand in the process
but by the time that happened heat
killed Captain America he had killed
Iron Man he killed most everybody at
shield and when he killed every single
person that tried to track him down so
it was a really cool situation and
that's what Emma Frost says Emma Frost
says you know we're we're shield what
everybody wants to know what Wolverine
was doing why he went after a head of
state you know the the or at least it
was believed to be the Prime Minister of
Japan the question they have is why is
he doing this and Emma Frost says
because he's regained all of his
memories and this sends the world into
absolute panic or at least a sim shield
and absolute panic and the reason why is
because now wolverine remembers all
those all those abuses wolverine
remembers all the times that he's been
tortured he remembers all the times that
he's been used and his memories been
altered so he would forget I mean the
shield is just kind of in a position now
where they're just like oh my god
because now there's no telling what
he'll to you with the memories of
Wolverine while Logan himself is kind of
a mishmash
the different people in shield dum-dum
Duke and of course the one-time friend
of Nick Fury at least fighting alongside
Nick Fury that eventually you know took
the Infinity formula to keep him young
as part of shield they were able to
consolidate all these different pieces
of Wolverines life and kind of bring
them together to figure out what
direction his life had actually taken
but even then a lot of things were left
ambiguous and so between this fight with
Wolverine and with silver samurai what
is up happening is the journey basically
takes him or at least it leaves him
injured to the point that he kind of
makes his way aboard a ship at least
aboard a a ferry of sorts and then just
passes out from the experience but what
it does is it allows Daniel way to kind
of go back a little bit focus on some of
these memories at Wolverines having
about a wife that appears to be pregnant
so on and so forth but it creates kind
of a funny situation because there was a
person that apparently killed his wife
and we don't know who that person is the
question being who was that they killed
his wife eats ooh which is the person
he's presumably tracking down now of
course once he comes to what this does
is it leads him to Canada's department
cake now this is when Daniel way begins
the process of going back and retconning
a bunch of things we talked about this
before in our video on the origin of
Wolverines adamantium where we talked
about how you know the adamantium
bonding process was done that he had his
home memories based on that what Daniel
was gonna do is he's basically gonna go
through here and he's gonna begin
changing things up he's gonna begin
altering the history a little bit and
the way that he does this is by showing
that Wolverines time of the facility was
not exactly what he expected it to be
where he believed there was you know
Carol Hynes dr. Cornelius all these
different people where he believed that
they may have been there where he was
lashing out and he was going through and
he was tearing things up what he's
coming to realize is that his memories
were not exactly like that that his
memories were not exactly in the same
capacity where he believed but he had
escaped the containment unit where he
believed that he had gone through killed
all these different members as part of a
part of candidates department Kane and
the whole Weapon X project that instead
it wasn't just him that in all reality
he had help escaping the Weapon X
facility somebody engineered his escape
somebody went through and they basically
let down the security precautions so
that Wolverine would escape in an
animalistic state kill everybody and
then get away and that's what Wolverine
himself says he says in his mind the way
that his memories were before they were
restored during the events of house of M
that he was able to make his escape from
the Weapon X facility because the people
who are running it just got careless
that they considered him to be an animal
but he still had thinking ability he
just waited for a moment when they were
at their weakest when they were at their
most careless and then engineered his
own escape basically got away that is
not actually what happened now in terms
of who it was an engineered his escape
will basically get to that here in a
second but whatever happening is that as
he's making his way through this weapon
X facility
he basically contacts Captain America
and when he gets ahold of Steve Rogers
Steve's is like him and like you got to
come back in they literally try to
corral him back and Wolverine says no
I've got stuff to do but one of the
people that I'm looking for is your old
friend Bucky Barnes and so what this
does is this transitions over to
Belgrade Serbia
how you pronounce the vel agree I'm not
really sure but it transitions over to
Serbia where Wolverine is trying to
track down Bucky Barnes now with regards
to Bucky you got to keep in mind this is
that whole point where he's still
underground like he's still operating
hidden away from the world because
remember following the return of Bucky
Barnes in male comics during Edie
Brubaker's Captain America vol 5 that
Bucky Barnes had basically had his
memories restored by by Steve Rogers and
then Bucky Barnes just kind of taken off
that was really kind of like the magnum
opus of that whole run of a true Baker
the whole idea was bring Bucky Barnes
back he doesn't know who he was he's
still operating as the Winter Soldier
half Captain America used the Cosmic
Cube Bucky Barnes memories restored and
then he just kind of goes back to
recollect himself so it was very similar
to what you guys saw in Captain America
the Winter Soldier when Bucky saves
Steve Rogers and then just kind of roams
off and tries to go understand or try to
piece his life back together that's
really what was happening here now what
uh what Wolverine did when he had left
Canada when he had left Canada's
apartment department cave is he
basically put the word out but he's
looking for for Bucky Barnes now here's
how things work when it comes to Marvel
comics with regards to this whole
criminal criminal underworld there are
all kinds of contacts that are all sorts
of resources is really just like this
giant underground now a lot of it has
roots and mad rapport which is basically
this city where all the criminals hang
out and even shield doesn't go there but
when someone says I'm looking for a
person word will get back to them people
will whisper you know birds will talk
and they'll say hey like somebody's
looking for you they're trying to track
you down and so by the time that
Wolverine got to Serbia where he
discovered that Bucky Barnes was hanging
out Bucky Barnes was lying in wait now
when he gets in of course he's basically
being shot out by somebody on the roof
and when he gets in he basically walks
into an old news facility into an old
you know newspaper facility and the
reason why this is so significant is
because this goes to the intelligence of
Bucky Barnes it shows us how smart he is
and that's one of the great things about
his character when Bucky Barnes was part
of the old Captain America stories back
in the 1940s the 1950s other to the
point where Captain America was
basically killed off and Bucky Barnes
was gone when he was brought back in and
Brubaker basically wreck Honda's history
and said the Bucky Barnes wasn't just
like a 1940's you know sidekick like
yeah I love you Captain America that he
was actually uh he was trained to be an
assassin but the reason why Bucky Barnes
was paired with Captain America is
because Bucky was willing to engage in
torture he was willing to engage in
murder if it meant that his mission
would be achieved he was willing to do
things the Captain America wouldn't do
and Captain America tolerated that
because they were in World War two
because there were some things that were
necessary in order to in order to ensure
the axis didn't succeed and so it was
really just kind of like the lesser of
two evils but once Bucky Barnes time had
basically come to an end once the
explosion that led to the presumed death
of Captain America when he was frozen in
ice once Bucky Barnes was taken by the
Russians and transformed into the Winter
Soldier well then at that point he just
kind of became an assassin like that's
all he did he just went around killing
individuals carrying out all kinds of
different missions but what that did is
it honed his skills as an assassin it
made him more capable he had a mission
and it was complete this mission
do whatever you have to do and he would
have to learn to adapt with regards to
Wolverine Wolverine senses are some of
the best in Marvel Comics his sense of
smell is sense of sound his ability to
see so on and so forth are some of the
best in Marvel Comics Bucky Barnes
leading Wolverine into a printing
facility into a newspaper facility is
done for the purpose of Bucky Barnes
covering himself in ink and so basically
Wolverine senses cannot detect him he
wouldn't be able to smell him he
wouldn't be able to track him down he
would just have to rely on his sense of
sight now this is genius because it's
almost like that instance from the movie
predator when all Schwarzenegger covered
himself in mud so the predator couldn't
see him because a parent wouldn't be
able to see through the mud to detect
body heat that's basically what's
happening Bucky Barnes hides himself
from the senses of will range so it's so
cool because it's basically him just
drawing on all this experience as an
assassin that's one of the reasons why I
love Bucky so much in the end Bucky is
able to get the upper hand on Wolverine
and the womanís that was on the roof
that were shooting kind of shoots
Wolverine from behind and effectively
kills him and so the result is that
Wolverines more or less dead or at least
it seems like he is now of course the
cool thing about this is that there's an
exchange between Bucky and this woman
that he hired and this woman says you
know I'm staying here until I get paid
Bucky says go to this location get an
ATMs ATM card take money out of this old
slush fund from the KGB and then get out
of here like just go into hiding never
allow anyone to see you know when the
question is asked why it is Wolverine
had come after Bucky Barnes in the first
place
Bucky says he came after me because I
killed his wife and his unborn child now
this is a huge red con in the realm of
Marvel comics that that Bucky Barnes
basically killed the wife and and the
unborn child of Wolverine because what
this does is it goes to the heart of the
fact that Bucky Barnes had
many things that he didn't read did so
many things that he wasn't aware of
because remember when he was the Winter
Soldier he would go on a mission his he
would be brainwashed his memories
wouldn't really be wiped away so much as
they were replaced and then he would go
on and complete another mission he was
kept constantly in a docile state and
while he is still recovering a lot of
his own memories this particular memory
of being involved in the the death of
Wolverines wife is something that's come
back to him and so that's why he
realizes that's why Wolverines there now
for here we transition to a place called
Jasmine Falls and we actually jumped
back to the past to this memory of
Wolverine and what had happened is over
the course of his life following his
experience as part of a candidate's
department Kaye following you know his
whole time being a killer kind of being
this mindless animal that he had
traveled to Jasmine Falls for the
purpose of trying to basically find
solace and he comes across a man by the
name of bando Sbarro
and this is a guy who is essentially
kind of like this instructor or this man
who's at peace with himself but Jasmine
Falls is basically where we're assassins
go in order to find inner peace and
that's the whole basis behind this
that's what Saburo says that at this
location this is where men who are
previously killers go to cast off who
they were before and become better men
and that's why Wolverine is here
Wolverines and Jasmine Falls to cast
aside that dark nature of himself and to
be a better man now the cool thing is
that master Saburo goes to him and says
this plot of land will be your home and
when Wolverine goes to lay down to
basically sleep Saburo says you're not
an animal you're a man this will be your
home when you build it and that's the
cool thing about this is because it's
very Doctor Strange esque in terms of
Stephen strange more or less tearing
down the barriers of his own mind it is
Wolverine tearing down the barriers of
who he was to reveal who he can truly
become and it's really cool because with
each brick that he builds with each you
know piece of of wood that he constructs
to make his home he's building himself
up to be a better person along the way
he falls in love with eat sue and the
two of them basically become become
pregnant they bear a child now the cool
thing about this is that this also
initiates a ceremony when each is
revealed to be with child
Wolverine basically celebrates with
master Samara Master saguaro says this
is a time of celebration this is you
becoming a better man because now you
have something to live for
and that was really the significance of
Wolverines wife being pregnant that's
why it was so big for him is because now
he had someone to live for now he had a
reason to be a bo
and that's one of the reasons why this
whole wolverine dichotomy works so well
is because for us is people for you and
me right like if we have a goal to
aspire Schwarz if we say you know well
I'm having a son I want to be a better
man then that's what you become that's
one of the reasons why they say
motherhood is when girls were when women
stopped being girls and they become
women they step into motherhood they
begin to realize that they have a
responsibility to a life beyond their
own and in turn they stepped into that
role and become better people and that's
what Wolverine was doing he was trying
to become a better human being now the
issue is that in the midst of this
celebration the celebration is designed
to serve a couple purposes the first is
to literally just be a celebration is to
say yeah man like Wolverines wife is
preggers but the other half is to also
show what Wolverines become just to show
that he's left his animal instincts
behind that he's left his darker nature
behind the problem is that in the midst
of this whole dance his animal instincts
take over temporarily and in doing so
his claws come out and he accidentally
injures one of the guys that he's uh
that he's kind of dancing alongside or
fighting alongside and the result is
that he's basically failed this test of
him leaving his darkness behind now what
this also does is this coincides with an
explosion out in the mountains and this
is when Saburo reveals the identity of a
guy named Muramasa and so this ties into
that whole origin of the Muramasa blade
those of you guys who were intrigued by
that element of Wolverines Wolverines
were that you know how to kill Wolverine
those of the guys who were intrigued by
that whole more Amasa blade concept this
is where we basically learned about this
you know Wolverine origins and endings
and so what Saburo does is he basically
gives us rundown on Muramasa but you
know we're Saburo says that he exists as
a man that's designed to basically
cleanse men's souls to help them become
better people to help them remove the
stench of past beads and lay the
foundation for them to become better
than what they've been that Muramasa is
the opposite that Muramasa is basically
a bad guy we're a masa Pheebs on the
darkness of men's souls by putting that
darkness into weapons forged by Muramasa
which in turn those men use to carry out
evil deeds and so with Logan kind of
taking time to himself and I you know in
the mountain side and sort of realizes
that he had basically failed his test in
the sense that he had lashed out
accidentally during this dance that he
wasn't quite at peace enough with
himself to raise his own son that he had
gone back to see Itza but when he got
back there that she was dead of course
having been killed by Bucky Barnes and
so what this does is jump back to the
modern day and this is the conversation
that he has with Bucky Bucky basically
says look my mission at the tar
was to lure you out my mission was to
kill eat sue and to get you to follow me
and then lead you to Matt report now the
reason why this was done leads into the
introduction of a character named
Romulus and that goes into the whole you
know Daniel way Wolverine Origins think
and that's him basically retconning the
entire origin of the Weapon X project it
wasn't John sublime or anything as crazy
as that that instead it was Romulus
running the whole thing what Bucky
Barnes says is where you were supposed
to follow me instead you didn't that you
traveled up the side of the mountain and
you went to go see Muramasa and that's
what happens here is what we went to go
meet Muramasa and he told Muramasa i
want a weapon
I want a blade that will kill them all
and so a Muramasa says fine I will help
you I will take a fraction of your soul
I will take out the darkest elements of
it and I will put it in this weapon the
issue is he says it'll take me years to
do this
it'll take me years to make it happen
what is up happening here is Wolverines
basically kicked off the side of the
mountain and no uncertain terms and he's
more or less just sort of left out there
and muramasa's argument is if Wolverine
is able to survive however long it is
that he's out there he's able to survive
the rest of his life then in the next
few years he will come to me and he will
look for this weapon and so what this
does is it kind of wraps back around
with with this this conversation between
Wolverine and Bucky Barnes and Sophia of
course Wolverine says hey look you know
you and me aren't done but the reason
why he doesn't kill him is because keep
in mind all these things that Bucky
Barnes did prior to really his return
and we know when when Captain America
used a cosmic key bond and all those
things were done without Bucky intending
to do it he was basically being used and
Wolverine understands where it is a
Bucky's coming from because there in
terms of how their minds work they're
skewed memories the fact that they don't
remember everything about their lives
the way they actually work did they
share that concept they share that that
entire standard now Wolverine will come
back for Bucky Barnes eventually but in
the meantime he basically just sort of
dumps a whole bunch of information on
Bucky Barnes with regards to the past
deeds that he done now I don't really
know what it is that he said and as far
as I know Bucky I don't think had an
origin story or had a solo series at the
time so I don't really know what it is
it ends up dropping here but what
Wolverine does is he basically throws on
you know a fake identity and he
basically takes back off to jasmine
falls again and when he gets there he
comes back into contact with Muramasa
and Muramasa says I finished crafting
this sword I finished crafting the
Muramasa blade this blade will give you
the tool to kill anyone that you come
across wield it like an angry god so
again this sets the stage for Wolverine
Origins by daniel way this
stage-four that a great big huge channel
how long it was 30 40 50 issues long it
says a stage for that whole great big
huge story art with the introduction of
the Muramasa blade itself so keeping on
with our whole x-men chronology for the
next few videos we're gonna be covering
Wolverine Origins just because when you
go through the chronological order of
the x-men you pick up with like new
x-men or I guess new mutants really is
kind of what it is it's really called
new x-men but it's basically new mutants
you pick up with like uncanny x-men
follow the greys and then you go into
like three stories of Wolverine Origins
now this is kind of weird because I feel
like I've done this before I know we did
origins and endings and that picks up
immediately after house of M and is
basically what happens when Wolverine
first gains as memories back which is
kind of the after effects that happen
instead of him losing his powers he
regained all his memories but that goes
into like the formation of the Muramasa
blade which of course is one of the only
blades that's out there that's capable
of shutting off the healing factor of
Wolverine if it's plunged into him and
left there for any real measure of time
and so because of that I was going
through and I was like I feel like I've
done this before but I searched all over
my channel and I have been able to find
it so it may just be one of those things
where it's like I read through it a
whole bunch of times there's something
along those lines and it just feels like
deja vu but regardless of the
circumstance Wolverine Origins by daniel
way is one of these stories that Marvel
produced where it got mixed reviews on
one side you had Wolverine
traditionalist people who didn't want to
see things change and who liked the way
Wolverine have been progressed over the
years in this publication Wolverine vol
1 Wolverine vol 2 his run and car mats
x-men all those different things that
have been fleshed out the Weapon X story
you know the 12 issue limited series on
the other side you had people who kind
of said Wolverines origin is an absolute
mess like you have to go through all
these comics you have to read you know
three four hundred comics in order to be
able to gain his overall origin and so
it was easier if it's all just in a
concise location overall the idea is at
a desk consolidate things it basically
goes through the whole origin of
Wolverine introducing his son all the
things he'd done in his past when he
first met Deadpool all those things go
into this great big huge fifty-some-odd
issue thing I think was 56 issues but I
kept him off top my head but it goes
into all this stuff but initially this
basically just kind of picks up with
Wolverine kind of going on this mission
of sorts because remember with him
regaining his memories what Daniel Way
does is he grabs a lot of the things
that we know and then he makes up things
that we didn't know about and then just
kind of throws them all into this
comic and so what we actually end up
doing here is picking up where the
Secretary of Defense or whatever it is
for the president United States there we
go and the whole idea behind this is
that it basically just sort of coincides
with Wolverine breaking into the White
House now this is a huge deal
the idea of Wolverine breaking into the
White House is huge because it's
designed to say two things the first is
that he's brazen that he's really like a
man on a mission but the other half is
to show the ingenuity the stealth the
guile and the kind of espionage that
Wolverines involved in because remember
for a guy this lived for a couple
hundred years he's seen and done it all
for the most part I mean he's fought in
various wars he fought alongside Captain
America too as part of Weapon X he
worked with the CIA as part of Team X
he's very well-versed and how to
infiltrate out places that are not
supposed to be accessible now all hands
are on deck here the president's Secret
Service response the military responds
and shield response and so Wolverine has
in the blink of an eye
become the most wanted man in America by
finding a way to get into the White
House at the same time somebody fired a
missile that offered some measure of a
distraction now it wasn't designed to
actually hit the White House the missile
was basically designed to take
everyone's attention away from the
actions of Wolverine so that's why it's
kind of a big deal because when it comes
to shield their main goal is to
basically maintain safety in the United
States but monitor all these different
threats different things like that and
where Wolverine is a blip on a radar
where suddenly someone's in the White
House that that's not supposed to be
there and the Secret Service is
responding a missile comes flying in
that's where Roddy begins to panic and
everybody begins to scramble but with
Wolverine making his way in there what
he immediately does is seemingly go
after this secretary now how long that's
because of the fact that what's
established here is that she's not
supposed to be in it though she's
basically working for another agency
where Wolverine goes after her he's
basically met by the arrival of a Shiva
which was stationed inside the rocket
which crash-landed on the grounds of the
White House now the Shiva's are pretty
interesting they're basically robots but
they were designed for the purpose of
tracking down and neutralizing members
of the Weapon X program that went rogue
that's one of the reasons why Wolverines
memories were kind of scrambled for a
time is because over the course of the
Weapon X project what you had before
Wolverine is you would have people who
would be inducted into the project
individuals would go in they would
receive whatever kind of training
something along those lines and then at
some point their memories would come
back to them and when they did they
would basically defect from Weapon X the
shiva's would be tasked with finding
them and either bringing them back in if
at all possible or so
neutralizing them ie taking them out and
so because of this these Shiva's are
designed to withstand a pretty
significant amount of punishment now one
thing to keep in mind is that the
Muramasa blade because it's designed to
basically nullify healing factors and
it's kind of a combination of some of
the hardest metals in existence come on
with a little bit of mysticism and magic
and so on and so forth
makes pretty quick work out of this
Shiva the problem is that Wolverine
comes to the realization whoever sipped
that Shiva was also the same person this
Secretary was working for and so
ultimately they end up taking her out
now in response to this the federal
government taking shield off the whole
thing and saying look if you guys
couldn't even stop a rocket from crash
landing on the White House then we're
gonna take things into our own hands and
the result is the federal government
initiates the launch of Frank Simpson
also known as nuke now nuke has been a
long-standing member of the Marvel
Comics landscape for a really really
long time l'm he's been around for ages
and ages and the cool thing about this
is that he was always one of these guys
that was kind of tied into the Weapon X
project and it really kind of goes back
to like 1989 with Wolverine vol 2 in
terms of you know the the kind of
stories that dealt with a little bit of
Wolverines origin different things along
those lines but again this is designed
to sort of consolidate all that
information and bring it together in a
easily accessible way and so this is
gonna kind of retell the origin of Frank
Simpson to a degree but the idea here is
a French Simpson as a guy over the
course of his life he's basically had
various aspects of his body replaced
with cybernetic implants and so at this
point in time he's more machine than
human but he still functions according
according to the wishes of what the
federal government wants to do the other
half of this is that instead of having
him pop pills which are something that
he can either choose to do or choose not
to do what's happened here is they
basically replace the red and blue pills
by putting in a second heart and so what
this does is it allows the government to
remotely decide whether he gets amped up
or whether he whether he calms down now
in terms of his actual origin this is
where things get kind of interesting we
actually sort of jumped back to 1968 in
the Vietnam War and this is really just
Wolverine operating as part of weapon
acts remember because weapon acts in his
earliest days was kind of a joint
venture between the CIA and Canada's
Department K what this men is that
Wolverine as part of Weapon X would
carry out missions for Weapon X and the
result was that during these early days
when he was part of the black ops team
before he underwent the Weapon X project
he was basically just kind of carrying
out these various missions one of these
missions dealt with the idea of Frank
Simpson being brought
and kind of being transformed into a
sort of killer where he was kidnapped
during the Vietnam War and then you had
Wolverine who is part of the CIA and so
on and so forth operating as a Russian
advisor for the for the Vietcong what
this meant was that he jumped in and
started going through and torturing
Frank Simpson but while he was doing
that he was planting a keyboard which
comes with a phrase of no VC and what
this means is that no VC was basically a
way of saying I'm not Vietcong the idea
behind this was that by planting that
phrase in there Frank Simpson when he
hears the phrase no VC will simply snap
he'll lose his mind and he'll just start
killing everything in the vicinity again
because of this what it also does is it
picks up with the silver samurai
conversing with the federal government
now silver samurai is a guy who's been
around for a really really long time I
want to say he was introduced in
daredevil number 11 back in like 1974
but he is a guy and I can never
pronounce his first name so it's like
it's like Kenny you Oh Chi Hirata I
think it's how you pronounce his first
name I apologize if I butchered that
I've never been able to pronounce his
first name but silver samurai is
actually the illegitimate son of a guy
named shin Jin Harada now a shin shin
Hirata is actually the father of a woman
named Mariko Yashida and Mariko Yashida
was at one point the fiancee of
Wolverine so it really all kind of goes
back to Waring himself now of course
Shinji and ultimately met his demise
which meant that Mariko became the head
of Clan Yashida
and then following her death silver
samurai took up leadership of the group
but the idea behind this is that silver
samurai is very much honorbound you know
he's really one of these guys where he
sort of maintains this old-school code
of honor among his own people as well as
when he makes a vow of silence meaning
that he won't tell anybody anything
about what he's heard he takes it to the
grave so he's like one of the most
trustworthy people out there the kicker
to all this is that what he ends up
doing is kind of spilling the beans to
the federal government not in terms of
what he was asked not to tell but what
he was asked to tell in the sense that
Wolverine basically says look tell them
about the Muramasa blade and let them
know what's going on because in the end
it doesn't matter so this is really kind
of like Wolverine taunting the feds in a
lot of ways now of course silver samurai
basically says hey look there's this
thing called the Muramasa blade it's the
only thing capable of destroying
Wolverine but he asked me to tell you
this which is why I'm telling you it's
kind of interesting because this isn't
this is you really serve like any major
purpose it's just kind of again a little
bit of a reminder that Wolverines life
and times span of
great deal amount of time in Marvel
Comics and there's all of these
different characters that he's impacted
over the course of his life now because
of the fact that nuke has been sent in
what this means is that his Wolverine
basically confronting Frank Simpson now
again this really kind of hits home at
the nature of the fact that Wolverines
regained all these memories from its own
life and so the reason why this matters
is because him confronting Frank Simpson
is not necessarily for the purpose of
killing him it's for the purpose of
making amends because Wolverine was the
one that transformed him into the person
that he is and the reason how that
happened is it all really kind of goes
back to the early days of his life and
this shows us how involved will rein in
the CIA and the Team X and even the
early stages of the Weapon X project it
shows us how it all kind of came
together when Frank Simpson was a little
kid the government had basically
targeted him for project homegrown now
in truth there wasn't really a rhyme or
reason for it it was just we need
someone and so this kid's gonna be it
what ended up happening is the whole
project homegrown crew had basically
grabbed this woman and threw her into
Frank Simpsons family as a maid of sorts
now Frank Simpson himself was subject to
a very you know drunken abusive mother
and his father was more or less a coward
but the idea behind this was that
because he had been targeted this maid
had been brought in for the purpose of
surveying the family and deciding
whether or not it was a good choice and
because of the fact that Frank Simpson
in many ways came from a broken home
basically what it meant is that his
mother had died if his father had died
then he would just kind of be out there
and there would really not be anybody
else and so where this woman it's made
kind of so you know subliminally
implants this idea of you should take
out your mom it's kind of left out there
in the background and then of course you
know where the father of Frank takes the
maid back home we end up having a
Wolverine show up who basically shoots
the maid and then gives the gun to the
father and saying hey look this is your
gun it came from your house the whole
world is gonna believe you killed this
maid after trying to take advantage of
her and so the result is that the father
of Frank Simpson turns the weapon on
himself following this Wolverine goes
back to the house of Frank Simpson to
find that the subliminal implants of
this maid worked when Frank Simpson took
out his mom and so this basically leaves
him an orphan and every single sense of
the word and all loose ends are tied up
but because of the fact that this
combined with wool rain visiting Frank
Simpson later on in his life when he had
enlisted in the Vietnam War and then
basically he planted the subliminal
wording into him basically meant that
from the time he was a child until the
time that he was an adult
Wolverine had quite literally crafted
Frank Simpson into the person that he is
these these memories sort of being
restored back to Wolverine basically
means he's trying to make amends here
but because of the fact that Frank
Simpson spent so much of his life being
mentally tormented and tortured by the
federal government being turned into a
living weapon of sorts having various
biological parts of his body replaced
with cybernetics means that he's almost
completely inhuman now and so as a
response to this because of the fact
that this will inevitably result in the
destruction of Frank Simpson at least
that seems to be the case and because
the feds and you know basically invested
a hundred and thirty million dollars in
it what they end up doing is sending
Captain America in to neutralize
Wolverine to bring him in and to bring
Frank Simpson back so the friendships
can be recovered and it can still
continue to be used as a weapon now this
is interesting because this basically
pits a battle between Captain America
and Wolverine and this is actually a
topic of a pretty big battle that still
goes on on the Internet one of the
questions people ask is who would win in
a fight Wolverine or Captain America
because where Wolverine has studied all
manner of martial arts he doesn't quite
have the super-soldier enhancements that
Captain America has meaning Wolverines
body has not pushed to the peak of
physical perfection and he certainly
doesn't have the learning capabilities
that Captain America has at the same
time Wolverines been around for a few
hundred years and so he does have all
this wisdom and all this experience
under his belt and so even if they stand
on equal footing it does come by two
different means the cool thing about
this is that what it does is it does
actually put them on an equal footing
and that's what's cool about this is it
really just kind of says hey this is
probably how this would turn out Captain
America and Wolverine fighting at the
end of the day Captain America's not
really a better than Wolverine any more
than Wolverines better than Captain
America is we're just kind of the nature
of who they are Wolverines healing
factor combined with his adamantium
combined with all of his experience puts
him on par with Captain America who's
got a healing factor of his own not
quite on the same level as Wolverine but
you know his enhanced stability and
speed reflexes and so on and so forth
and so the fights pretty drag out it's
pretty knock-down drag-out and pretty
brutal in a lot of ways now of course
Frank Simpson who's basically kind of
like half a man at this point really
just kind of throws the Muramasa blade
to Captain America who in turn turns it
on Wolverine so this is kind of
interesting because at this point
Wolverine doesn't have a whole lot of an
opportunity here now the other half of
this is that when it comes to Marvel
Comics with regards to weapons plus
we've talked about this before so if
you're familiar with us bear with me for
a second when it comes to weapons Plus
that's the umbrella
organization under weapons plus you have
weapons one all the way up to ten
also known as weapon acts and even
beyond weapon ten yeah weapons eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
different things like that by and large
it was always believed that when it came
to the weapons plus program that it was
all rooted on the nature of Captain
America Captain America was weapon one
and the goal up until they found
Wolverine was to duplicate Captain
America and create a version of himself
with Wolverine it was Weapon X and
because of his healing factor combined
with the fact that he was the first
successful implantation of adamantium to
a person's bones grafted to their
skeleton the goal after Wolverine was to
not duplicate Captain America it was to
duplicate Wolverine one of the big
controversies in the story is that it
really kind of comes back and it says no
Frank Simpson was designed to duplicate
Wolf Ray but that assumes that Wolverine
came before Frank Simpson which isn't
necessarily true and so because of this
it is kind of interesting because
remember chronologically Wolverine was
weapon ten Frank Simpson was weapon
seven so again it is it is kind of weird
it's a little bit of a controversy here
I mean it still works for the purpose
that it serves but it also kind of begs
the question how far along was the
planning for the character of nuke by
the time he was brought in a project
homegrown but again it's Wolverine
basically saying hey look they were
trying to duplicate you Captain America
they were trying to duplicate me but in
truth they were trying to duplicate
Captain America so again one of those
little oversights made by Daniel way
with writing of this story but the fact
remains here with Wolverine kind of you
know using the distraction of Frank
Simpson to overpower Captain America to
take the Muramasa blade where it seems
as though he's initially gonna go after
him instead we end up with the arrival
of Cyclops
Hellion and Emma Frost but the whole
idea behind this is that Emma Frost had
previously tried to enter the mind of
Wolverine while he was fighting Captain
America and the reason for that was
because by going through and reading the
mind of Wolverine as well as kind of you
know looking around the world or looking
around the world as it exists Emma Frost
started coming to these realizations but
there's a whole nother side of this
equation that Wolverine doesn't know
about specifically the son of Wolverine
Wolverine does not know that he has a
son now of course this also goes in and
it grabs things like Silver Fox
so for Fox was kind of an on you know an
older standard when it came to the
Wolverine comics hadn't really been a
reference for quite some time and she
was never really essential the only real
role she served was kind of like the
reason why it is that Wolverine and
Sabretooth
hate each other so much so if this was a
video on the topic of Wolverine and
Sabretooth and certainly it would be
vastly important but because it's not
because it kind of deals with the early
days of Wolverine
regards to him learning about his own
past and kind of you know consolidating
all this information to the realization
that his sons alive Silver Fox was
really just kind of a person that will
rain fell in love with for a while
saber-toothed ended up showing up and
taking out silver fox now the motivation
for why saber-tooth did that will become
important later on down the line
especially when we get into the
introduction of the character Romulus
but for right now
he was just a person that took out
silver fox and it kind of engendered a
hatred between Wolverine and Sabretooth
now of course you know Wolverine was
overpowered in the experience he was
kind of left for dead and that was
really about it but this kind of led him
on the eeo into this path led him into
the circle of coming across all these
various people and sort of set him on
the path of becoming part of Team X the
CIA you know all those different things
like that you know kind of bring all
that back together again and so on and
so forth but again with this whole
scenario because of the fact that you
know Wolverine realizes that he does
have a son his son has been brought into
the Weapon X project his son it's
basically werewolves reign was however
many years ago when he was originally
brainwashed and part of that whole
system Wolverine comes to the
realization that this is eventually
gonna boil down to him fighting his son
and so if that happens and he has the
Muramasa blade one of them will use it
to kill the other and so as a result he
hands it over to Cyclops he simply says
I do not want this plate with me because
I do not want to be forced to kill my
own son assuming it comes down to that
now of course this also kind of gets
into at by Emma Frost that Wolverine son
hates them which of course you know
we'll see that later on with the
character of Dakin and how all that
unfolds but again you know the Wolverine
Origins stories were very much designed
to sort of introduce these small little
nuances here in there everything will
build on everything else and so we'll go
back and we'll reference this first
story
well reference the story after this you
know as we get further on down the line
we'll end up finding out that the
Wolverine origin line of comics is very
important especially once we get to like
dark Wolverine the rise of day Kent the
events of Dark Reign the dark era of the
x-men all those different things like
that it's all gonna play a pretty
significant role okay so continuing our
x-men chronology we sort of pick up
again with Wolverine Origins now again
those of you guys who saw my video on
the Marvel Cinematic Universe phase 1
one of the reasons why I really
emphasize the idea that Wolverine and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe would
serve the purpose of basically
explaining the back end to everything
that's going on is because of the fact
that Wolverine Origins did exactly that
Wolverine Origins took the character of
Logan as we knew him and basic
went through the entire publication
history of Marvel ever since Logan had
been born and covered like all these
really cool important points that the
other half of this is to remember
because of the fact that Daniel weighs
Wolverine Origins was designed to be
this huge fifty-some-odd issue origin
story for Wolverine basically covering
everything about his past a lot of
former elements a lot of these
disconnected themes concepts that were
sort of out there but we didn't really
know where they stood with regards to
the larger picture and even some of
these concepts that contradicted other
pieces of information they were all sort
of brought together and consolidated
into one great big huge origin and
that's one of the reasons why whenever
people say like what's the origin of
Wolverine my advice is go read daniel
ways Wolverine Origins because while it
does change some things and while there
are Wolverine fans who don't like some
of the things that were changed the fact
remains that as it stands right now even
in Marvel legacy the definitive origin
story of Wolverine is basically found in
this story now remember one of the
things that we found with regards to the
the post house of them event was that
all of Wolverines memories were
basically restored and what this did is
it allowed Daniel way to set the stage
to essentially say there was some hidden
hand behind the scenes someone somewhere
was pulling all these strings when it
came to all these events that took place
in Wolverines life now historically
speaking in Marvel Comics it was largely
just Weapon X there was no singular
person really operating behind the
scenes it was simply just that Wolverine
found himself working for Team X in the
CIA he would do these black ops missions
he was grabbed by Weapon X he was thrown
into the program he had adamantium
bonded to his skeleton he escaped in the
rest is history
what this is designed to do is to say
there's actually someone out there who
was controlling all these things now
with regards to the formation of Weapon
X with regards to like Grant Morrison's
new x-men we found out it was John
sublime this bacterial entity that was
taking possession of different humans
and realized that mutants could
basically withstand his mental control
more or less and he wanted to create
super soldiers to kill mutants hence the
reason why weapons Plus was created and
the web and projects started with Weapon
1 ie Captain America and so the cool
thing about this is that again a lot of
that stuff gets wiped away with regards
to all the original history of the
Weapon X project John sublime and all
those things that went into it all that
stuff gets replaced and so the best way
to really think about Wolverines history
is that if you don't see it in this
origin there's a really good chance it
doesn't exist but of course with this
whole idea that he came to the
realization that someone was pulling the
strings it basically set in motion this
mission whereby he was trying to figure
out who that
person was but Jemmy back to the past
shelling to around 1963 what this does
is this really kind of fills in the idea
that as part of Team X to a degree
Wolverine would go on these missions he
would basically be sent on these tasks
and when that wasn't hot wasn't
happening it was more or less kind of
being held prisoner but he was
effectively fed a red pill and when he
ingested it it turns out it's
carbonadium now with Marvel Comics we've
talked about this before but for all the
new folks who are getting into this just
because it's called Wolverine Origins
with regards to carbonadium this was an
attempt by the Russians to duplicate
adamantium and what it actually did is
it created a kind of you know radiation
aspect to it it's kind of like a death
touch more or less and we'll actually
find out the extent of that with regards
to really Omega red in this particular
story because this will see his return
for the most part but the idea behind
this was that carbonadium was a lot more
malleable it was a lot more durable than
traditional metals but it was nowhere
near adamantium in terms of
indestructibility this carbonadium
basically slows down Wolverines healing
factor now in truth in a lot of ways
Daniel Daniel way is borrowing this from
just the publication history of
Wolverine but that's what carbonadium
does it basically slows down the healing
factor of Wolverine it doesn't actually
end it and so what this does is it
really kind of jumps back to the modern
day which is to say an instance a
Wolverine just kind of sneaks aboard a
freighter and then just basically starts
making his way taking a few people out
here and there and then that's really
about it at this point we transition to
Eastern Washington State where he
finally manages to reach the PIAT sound
and the cool thing about this and is one
of the funny exchanges remember when it
comes to Wolverine it's usually his way
or the highway and where he comes across
the trucker and says I need to make my
way to Queens I need to get back to New
York this trucker is initially just kind
of like look man I can't take you that
far that's kind of ridiculous but if I
do what are you gonna give me and the
funny exchange here is it's not
necessarily what Wolverine is gonna give
him it's what Wolverine is gonna allow
him to keep presumably he's going to
remove the most important thing that any
man has in his possession so following
this of course it really just kind of
allows him to sort of go forward and
basically discover a kind of safe house
and the reason for this is because
Wolverine is looking for a particular
person he's looking for one guy and this
guy's name is Christopher Nord now again
because of the fact that this is part of
a cohesive line of comics of the follow
the events of house of M really running
up until like endangered species is all
just kind of under the umbrella name of
decimation is really what this is but
the whole idea behind this is remember a
lot of mutants lost their powers in fact
all the 100
ninety-eight mutants Loffler lost their
powers give or take a few who in there
who were you know basically undocumented
Jubilee is one of those but this
safehouse is basically a place whereby
mutants who formerly had powers can
basically stay underground in order to
avoid a lot of the anti-mutant groups
who were out there because remember
after the mutant population decrease and
it hit the news and all these different
anti-mutant groups friends of humanity
and the purifiers and things like that
once they began to learn that the mutant
population had been decimated they saw
it as their chance to wipe out what's
left of the mutants or to wipe out those
people who were well known to have been
mutants and lost their powers the other
half of this equation is that along his
journey
Wolverine kept picking up this scent now
this is where Daniel way gets a little
off and that's one of the reasons why
there's a little bit of inconsistency
here historically speaking when it comes
to Wolverine one of the most most well
known aspects of his character is his
ability to pick up smells when Wolverine
picks up a scent he never forgets it and
he never loses it and so because of the
fact that he's getting whiffs of this
scent here and there the idea is that he
believes it to be familiar but he can't
quite put his finger on it if we looked
at the publication history of Marvel he
should have immediately known who it was
and the reason why is because the scent
of the person he picked up is Omega Red
now Omega Red is a character who
actually appeared in x-men vol 2 issue
number 4 but he is a guy called arkady
rossovich oh my god i pronounced it
right but the funny thing about Omega
Red is he was kind of a new influx of
villains you remember back in the
nineteen nineties really the early 1990s
in Marvel Comics stories were moving
from being more character focused to
taking care to development and inner xx
and in with super high octane and
violence stories but the whole idea of
Omega Red is he is basically the attempt
by the Russians to create their own
Super Soldier now he wasn't really
designed to mimic Wolverine he was
actually designed to mimic Captain
America to a degree now the issue with
this was that he was largely
unpredictable there was no real way to
know what did what was he was gonna do
was he gonna follow orders or was he
gonna just kind of go rogue go off and
do his own thing so eventually he was
kind of shunted away but one of the
major aspects of Omega Reds character is
that he has what are called carbonadium
tentacles and what these do is they
basically draw a life energy out of
individuals but he can also use them
just like slash and pail people with
different things like that usually
they're used to ensnare and then drag
the life force out of a person but he's
always been one of Wolverines most
notable enemies with regards to Marvel
Comics now the idea
kind of being a spinoff of Captain
America that wasn't actually introduced
until Edie Brubaker's run with Captain
America vol 5 for the most part in the
original introduction of his story back
in the first the first you know maybe
six or seven issues of x-men vol 2 he
was basically just an attempt by
Russians to create their own super
soldier and faced off against wolves
right now it worked
I mean Omega Red was wildly popular when
he first showed up but the idea behind
this is he's always in pursuit of
something called the carbonadium
synthesizer now what this story is going
to do is this gonna grab a lot of those
themes and it's gonna sort of rework
them so we'll cover the kind of back
into that in terms of how it used to be
versus how it is now as we progress
through this what we end up doing is we
actually end up leaving the modern-day
and we jump back to about 40 years prior
to this and this is after Wolverine
consumes that red pill now of course
after taking the red pill after being
knocked down essentially what happens is
these doctors on staff begin going
through and dissecting him of course
they remove the Canadian pill out of his
system which means he immediately begins
to jump back to because of the fact that
carbonadium suppresses it if carbonadium
is removed his healing factor will kick
back in again so the idea here is they
basically show us that when Wolverine
goes on a mission they feed him a
carbonadium pill the carbonadium hill
knocks him out it basically suppresses
his healing factor he ends up collapsing
they throw him into a machine they wipe
his memories and then when he comes to
they basically say oh man here's
everything that went on and here's
everything that happened that's how they
kept him under control now because of
the fact that you know they had really
kind of undershot exactly how this would
happen what is it taking place is
Wolverines healing factor kicks in
faster than it's supposed to and the
result is that he actually attacks the
doctor now one of the other big changes
that's made here is the time that
Wolverines claws pop now on the surface
people will try to find a way to
reconcile the Wolverine Origins one shot
when his claws popped as a kid to
Wolverine as he exists right now now one
of the things he says here is look I
remember everything I remember at all it
was almost like he basically makes this
connection of yes my claws popped when I
was a kid and my memories have been
altered and I basically forgot about it
all but he'll actually make a comment
later on where he talks about his newly
discovered claws and so that's where
sort of brings in this idea that this is
when his claws pop for the very first
hunt the one thing to bear in mind is
that when it came to the Wolverine
Origins story by daniel way versus the
Wolverine Origins one shot the Wolverine
Origins one shot was rushed by Marvel
Comics
it was basically just throw it out there
and the reason
I was because word hit reached the ears
of Marvel that Fox was going to launch
in an x-men film and it was entirely
possible that they were going to tell
the origin story of Wolverine so in
order to beat Fox to this Marvel rushed
out the origin of Wolverine in a
six-issue limited series and basically
introduced the idea that Wolverines
caused a pop for the first time when he
was a little kid and so the result was
that it kind of went forward as just
part of this origin story because
Wolverines origin was always aiming
matic he was always kind of
cloak-and-dagger which is one of the
things that made him so curious how did
we get to the point from Wolverine
presumably being born up to the modern
day when he joined the x-men who was
part of Team X and all I kind of good
stuff now of course again this is kind
of designed to go back and retell all
that to sort of alter all those things
so again there's really not a lot of
information offered here at least in
this part of the story with regards to
his cause popping for the first time
outside of this so a lot of people
really choose to ignore that and stick
with the original six issue limited
series from 2001 to 2002 now following
this Wolverine basically goes forward
and says look when I'm searching for is
a carbureted synthesizer he's basically
hot on the trail for it he believes that
maverick or I guess Christopher Nord is
the one that has access to it so jumping
back to the modern day Jubilees among
here because she's one of the people
that basically lost her powers but with
Omega Red hunting for the carbonadium
synthesizer the last one to be in
possession of it according to Omega red
wasn't maverick was Christopher Nord now
Christopher Nord exists in a couple
different forms there's basically the
pre legacy virus Christopher Nord and
there's the post legacy virus
Christopher Nord of course legacy virus
basically being this sort of a disease
that was introduced to Marvel Comics
with regards to mutants that presumably
could wipe them away in their entirety
and it was Marvel kind of toying with
the idea of you don't real mutants go
extinct you know and that kind of a
thing but Christopher Nora basically had
the ability to absorb kinetic energy and
then reach handle it now after the
legacy virus that was amplified several
times over so in a lot of ways he had
the same powers as Bishop Christopher
Nord was also on Team X alongside will
rank Christopher Nord was accepted into
the Weapon X program so he's played a
pretty significant role with regards to
the life that Wolverines had and this
goes directly into the origin the funny
thing about this is that with Omega Red
under any normal circumstance when Omega
Red subdued Wolverine he would have
killed him on the spot the issue with
this is that Omega Red basically allows
we're going to be knocked out and then
leaves and so what this means is that
Omega Red was never there for Wolverine
in the first place Omega Red was there
for either Jubilee or maverick or
somebody else but presumably someone who
has the carbonadium synthesizer now
the basis behind the carbonadium
synthesizer and something that will
actually be covered later on so we can
go ahead and sort of jump into this the
carbonadium synthesizer basically means
that it can effectively liquefy or
create carbonadium and so the result is
that if it's sold to someone they can in
turn use it to create something akin to
add a man to remember adamantium is very
very difficult to make but what this
will do and what it'll basically lead to
is the idea of a mega red trying to find
the carbonadium synthesizer and then
selling it off for a cure to his
carbonadium and the reason why is
because the tentacles in his arms are
effectively poisoning him and so if you
can find out find a cure that'll
basically nullify the radiation put off
by the carbonadium that's imbued in his
body then it means he'll continue to
survive up until this point the only way
for what for a mega red to live is to
basically draw the life force out of
other people to sustain his own life
energy so again that's why he functions
the way that he does and that's why he
does the kind of things that he does but
again the idea behind this is that once
wolverine gets inside christopher nord
seemingly appears to be on his deathbed
in the sense that he basically says hey
look what you're looking for is in like
russia or something like that
omega red grabs Jubilee takes off leaves
a message behind says if you come for me
I'm gonna kill Jubilee and so it's
basically a way to keep Wolverine at
Bane I remember because of the fact that
Omega Red had been an on-again-off-again
villain of Wolverines for so incredibly
long he knows a lot about Logan he knows
about his interpersonal relationships he
knows how to keep him at bay that's why
Jubilee is so important here because
Jubilee is like a daughter for Logan and
so if Logan knows that going headstrong
into a megared means that he will kill
Jubilee which he will and it basically
means Logan can stay hands-off for the
most part and so following this he
travels directly to Berlin and when he
gets there he basically does sorts of
thousand code to a person in particular
different things like that and it
basically draws in this idea that he's
well versed in you know accessing all
these different themes for different
groups that operate underground and so
on and so forth now what this does is
this transitions back to the past with
regards to one of the first major
missions really one of the final
missions of Team X with regards to the
carbonadium synthesizer and the only
thing that we're really given here is
their first encounter with omega red in
the sense that Wolverine and Sabretooth
and and maverick had been sent on a
mission to basically retrieve the
carbonadium synthesizer now again the
reason they were still on this mission
is because it was ordered by the hidden
hand pulling things behind the scenes so
again once they go on this mission while
Sabretooth was very much kind of a rogue
guy which is to say he would sell out
his own teammates if it meant saving the
mission ultimately it ends up with
Wolverine kind of saying look
whoever it is it's pulling the strings
here isn't giving us all the answers
they're not telling us the truth
and so Wolverine had intended to
actually go off reservation to take the
carbonadium synthesizer into leave with
it the result is that where he initially
gets the assistance of maverick
Sabretooth actually kills the doctor
that's being escorted out by Wolverine
and company to basically remind him look
your job is to stay on this mission and
if you don't then I'll take out the
people who were closest to you if it
means keeping you in control so it was a
way to basically keep things contained
now back in the modern day once we pick
back up with Berlin what we end up
finding out here is that the whole
reason why Wolverines here is to get
back in contact with natasha romanoff
with Black Widow now a little bit of
history here where this part of the
story will go through and it'll
basically change up a lot of the history
when it comes to Natasha Romanoff one of
the things that I want you guys to know
about is how the history of Black Widow
fits into the larger Marvel picture in a
lot of ways the history of Black Widow
with regards to the average comic book
reader and Marvel Comics is still pretty
ambiguous they know she hails from the
Red Room but in terms of how the Red
Room Academy fits into everything else a
lot of folks find that kind of
cloak-and-dagger but in Russia again
because of the fact that a lot of their
attempts were to basically create a kind
of super soldier program of their own
all that fell under the umbrella of
department X that was really their whole
thing over there but Department X was
not just about traditional super
soldiers and Avengers teams you also had
things like project the Winter Soldier
when they grabbed Bucky Barnes and they
turned him into the Winter Soldier
Omega Red an attempt to create a super
soldier the other half of this was that
not every conflict needs to have
somebody who's super capable and able to
do all these different things the CIA
had Team X and so they basically had
their own covert super black ops team
the Russians wanted the exact same think
they had the KGB they had their spy
organization but what they needed was an
extremely secret organization that could
operate behind the scenes and be
virtually undetectable
just like Team X Russia's answer to that
was the red-room Academy and what they
would do is they would go out and they
would grab these young girls they would
basically be orphans they would throw
them into the red-room Academy and they
would train them to be the absolute best
assassins where they could essentially
infiltrate almost any situation now this
goes into the early days of Natasha
Romanoff and it actually feeds into the
Tasha Romanoff and her ability to escape
the Red Room Academy the way this plays
out is that Wolverine initially stumbled
across a guy named Terrace Romanoff and
he's effectively this guy that basically
wrote the book on espionage and
I work he's like this spy spy and so
because of that Wolverine is kind of
brought in by terrorists for the purpose
of essentially teaching him everything
he knows now it's really kind of
happenstance that leads into it but it
is kind of cool because while Wolverine
is being trained by terrorists he's also
training Natasha Romanoff the way this
plays out is initially she just kind of
seems to be the daughter of terrorists
Romanoff and that's it she's just young
young girl so with regards to Wolverine
from his perspective he's teaching the
daughter of terrorists
how to fight and how to hold her own the
problem with this is that one night she
suddenly vanishes and of course Terris
comes running in with a sword and a
handgun pointing in at Wolverine
thinking he's the reason why it's been
done we end up having all these
different members of the of the guards
who have all been killed how their
throats slit they've all been basically
assassinated now of course Wolverines
response is this is a trap stay here
I'll go out and find your daughter
because they're looking for you you're
the most wanted man in the world right
now when he gets out there Natasha
Romanoff makes her appearance known and
that's what all this information begins
to come out that it's Hacha Romanoff as
a young girl was thrown into the
red-room Academy she was trained to
become an assassin and she's been
operating on her mission this entire
hunt now her mission was to assassinate
Eris the problem with this was that
Wolverine had the exact same mission he
was there for the exact same purpose and
he's the one that killed Harris his
mission was to get there figure out what
Terrace knows and if he knows too much
take him out and because of the fact
that terrorists did know too much he
eliminated him in turn Wolverine
basically tells the Tasha Romanoff as
far as everybody here is concerned
you're dead the world believes you're
dead and what this means is it allows
Natasha to leave the red-room Academy
the red-room Academy will believe she
died in her mission and so she could
escape her captivity then go out and try
to find some semblance of a normal life
now of course she makes a promise I'll
pay you back you know for this you know
I owe you a huge favor and essentially
she doesn't really keep it up here where
we would expect the favor to be returned
what she ends up doing is she basically
says look I know that you're hunting for
Omega Red I know that you're looking for
this carbonadium synthesizer the one
that I have here is a fake the safe one
is locked up somewhere and it'll be kept
there no one knows it is actually there
but what I've done is I basically
contacted shield and I told him there
with Omega Red the problem with this was
that at the time the Black Widow did
that she didn't know that Jubilee was
being held by Omega Red and so we'll
raised initial response it's one of
panic because what this means is that in
turn shield is going to show up at the
location of Omega Red and
is gonna keep his promise and say if
anybody comes here I'm gonna kill
Jubilee effectively meaning that natasha
romanoff is about to get Jubilee killed
and that's when wolf rein immediately
shows up to the scene he basically
travels over there but of course
Wolverines showing up with a fake
carbonadium synthesizer offers a
distraction of sorts for Omega Red
because that's what he wants that's what
he's hunting for and so despite the fact
that Shield is there and despite the
fact that Omega Red could easily just
eliminate every single one of these
shield agents while he does do that his
main focus is a carbonadium synthesizer
so like a dog chasing a bone bull Ryan
throws it over the edge and in turn
Omega red goes to chase after it shield
uses their sticky goo stuff or whatever
it is attaches him to a rooftop and
basically Omega Red is allowed to be
taken prisoner following that wolf rein
goes in and tries to rescue Jubilee now
this is kind of interesting because
Marvel toys with the idea that Jubilee
might die what is up happening is that
where she's on the verge of basically
dying
Wolverine simply hands himself over to
shield he says look save this girl saved
you believe and I'll go with you
willingly I'll go wherever it is you
guys want to go so of course this leads
to Wolverine basically being taken into
custody by shield and kind of being held
in a sort of a medical containment unit
that basically holds him in stasis the
problem with this is that somebody
starts coming along now of course
dum-dum Dugan one of the closest members
of Nick Fury and really part of the
original Howling Commandos who consumed
the Infinity formula which means that
he'll never really aged he's the guy
who's basically watching Wolverine he's
kind of keeping a tab on all this kind
of stuff making sure that nothing really
happens the issue is that somebody comes
walking in and this person has claws
just like Wolverine does they come
walking in they stab dum-dum Dugan in
the chest they slash full frame across
the gut and they free him this character
is a guy that refers to Wolverine is
that just for the sake of immersion
while a lot of this information is
readily known and a lot of you guys are
like I know exactly who that is just for
the sake of immersion I'm not gonna tell
you who he is for those of you guys who
were really immersed in this I'm not
gonna spoil it for you we're gonna kind
of let the story continue on and that
kind of a thing I do not advise looking
at the comments because people will
spoil it in the comments because some
people are just dicks like that but what
I might do is I might go through and
just ban people who spoil the identity
of this guy in the comics I might do
that but the fact remains here ah this
guy just refers to Wolverine his dad and
so this sets the stage that Wolverines
son does exist Wolverines son hates his
father just like Emma Frost said and
this kind of begins the process of
expanding on the origin story and
basically delving more into what's going
on
behind-the-scenes with the character of
Logan as well as dealing more into his
past and how it all really kind of comes
to a head with regards to this
particular character okay so we are
getting me back into Wolverine Origins
and of course we're going through our
whole x-men chronology so this is really
just kind of designed to feed into a
really a lot of stuff that we've covered
so far and the overall idea here is that
in the last video we had talked about
how Wolverine had basically kind of
handed himself over to shield Mears
because of the fact that he had gone on
this crusade to basically track down the
guy who was running the show essentially
this new introduction some character
that have been pulling the strings
behind the scenes the entire time and it
actually just kind of like manufacture
the life of Wolverine which is to say
they had engineered all the
circumstances that led up to Logan being
thrown into the Weapon X program and
even some of those events afterwards all
leading up to the time when he joined
the x-men and so handing himself over
what we ended up having was someone who
basically broke in slashed him and then
freed it what we end up finding out in
this story is that the person who
basically freed Wolverine was his son it
was a sunday kid and this is cool
because Dakin's a new introduction it
had always been this kind of idea that
maybe Wolverine had kids but it was
never really anything fleshed out there
was never really anything to believe
that Wolverine had a kid oh this whole
introduction this whole idea kind of
brings this all to a head kind of takes
the most logical step in the development
of his character and I remember
Wolverine Origins is also designed to
basically consolidate the life and times
of Wolverine and it was cool because you
know following him basically being freed
he does what Wolverine does that
initially goes to free himself you got
to basically get out of the whole
facility now the funny thing about this
too is that this really kind of
highlights the evolution of Logan's
character over the years we know what he
would really want like we first popped
up for example you know the old
Incredible Hulk stories he was really
kind of introduced as a character who
was pretty ruthless to a degree and even
when he was rolled over into the x-men
the giant-size x-men number one and then
was written under Chris Claremont it was
kind of cool because you basically had
this idea that there was like a darker
side to Logan and every once in a while
he would pop up but as the years have
gone on his character's been fleshed out
and a lot of old-school Wolverine fans
will actually say that he's become
softer over the years but when it came
to a situation like this he would have
killed every last one of those soldiers
and left but in this instance he's kind
of like well I mean these are young guys
or they don't really know what they
didn't know what they were getting into
you and they're probably shanghaied into
this situation just like me and then of
course it basically you know ends up
with him taking out one of the GAR
only to steal his costume run out say
hey Wolverines behind me and then
basically make his escape and that's
about it but it is kind of a cool little
tidbit here because switching over to
the character of Dakin
this is what we start to get a lot of
development with him and you know in
terms of how he sees himself and what
his characters about now this was one of
the first indications yeah I mean if we
hadn't really picked it up already in
the first you know 10 issues this is one
of the first indications at the
Wolverine Origins line of stories we're
gonna be moving pretty fast because what
would normally happen over the course of
this as you would see little tidbits
peppered in about the nature of accurate
little things take place here and there
instead we get this development right
off the bat and what we end up finding
out here is that he's pretty
cold-hearted I mean basically ended up
just kind of you know pairing up with
some chick and of course her parents
said hey look this guy's bad for you but
like any young girl and even any young
guy it's all about bad decisions this is
all about making bad choices and so the
result is that she basically been used
by Dakin having no idea that that was
the case and the way he responds to this
is ruthless I mean he basically says
look you're an object you're you you
serve a particular purpose you're a fork
or a spoon you're a knife when your
purpose is served you are discarded and
that's that's the nature of his
character is that he's classic Wolverine
the way he acts here is classic
Wolverine in a lot of ways now what
[ __ ] basically says is when I went
into that bar and I met with that guy I
knew that you were following me I could
smell you you know I knew that you were
there and I knew that you were watching
and I engaged that whole scenario
because I knew that it would send you
back here and you would get drunk and
this whole purpose the whole basis
behind this was that I basically fill
that entire bottle of alcohol with
sleeping pills and I knew that you would
come back and you would be sad and you
would drink all that alcohol just to
spite me and you would basically get
yourself killed and that's how
everybody's going to view it that's the
nature anybody who walks in and they see
this the scene with this girl who's dead
the [ __ ] is gonna say you didn't you
know she did it to herself something
happened and she was sad that guy she
ran off with left her and then she just
took a whole bunch of sleeping pills and
died you know and and that's this is
gonna be the story of her it's actually
pretty intelligent but from this point
we switch over to another part of the
story with a guy named meelo now Mino is
kind of cool in a lot of ways he's a
throwback to the old Colossus character
you know - Pietro when he was first
introduced in giant size expert number
one and the reason why I say this is
because while meelo has the brain of a
child and the but you know the physical
structure of a full-grown man
I mean Colossus was a he like he was
smart I mean he wasn't you know he
wasn't by any means like dumbed down
he was one of those archetypical
examples of like brawn over brains you
know strength over over intelligence for
the character of Neela the way were
introduced to him is that he was petting
the horse and he was cleaning out the
horse's stable and the horse kicked him
and it made me lo mad and Milla punched
the horse and knocked its head off and
so as a result meelo basically has super
strength but it's interesting because
his life and that you know that the fact
that a problem like this has arised
indicates that other problems like this
have arisen because his father's
response is we should have registered
him we basically should have gone to the
government and said here's a person with
superpowers you know here's a person
with super-strength and so on and so
forth and we feel like you guys should
be aware of him and the result is that
they would have taken him and they would
have thrown him into a facility now for
his father is just kind of like look
good riddance to bad rubbish I mean
that's really kind of his father stance
which is pretty cold-hearted but his
mother of course is the opposite that
hey look it's our child and it's our job
to take care of him and so it's really
interesting because in the middle of him
basically crashing out for the night he
is met with a kind of psionic presence
basically met with a guy that really
calls himself cyber I have no idea why
they brought him back for this story
cyber is not relevant at all cyber had
like a very short stint of relevancy and
that basically happened in the old
Marvel Comics presents stories and then
in the old x-factor stories that's where
he got one of his biggest appearances
really he was just kind of like a main
enemy of x-factor sabra was killed off
pretty quickly he was literally eaten
alive by like cybernetic bugs that was
really about it it wasn't until this
story came out years later you know in
2007 that he was basically brought back
so he was absent for really over 20
years you know he was gone for quite
some time now the cool thing about this
is that cyber has different abilities
and different aspects to his character
the most notable is that in his old
appearances he had these kind of
adamantium tips but he also had like an
adamantium coating on his body so he
looked like Colossus except for his face
but it basically made him indestructible
and so the whole idea was that because
it coated his skin all you'd have to do
is take out his head and the bugs just
eat him from the inside out but one of
the other abilities he had this is
actually something that's kind of
introduced here is he had the psionic
ability to basically detect anybody
anywhere and so the result is that it
kind of allowed his consciousness to
sort of exist out there basically he
ended up taking over the body of Neill
oh and that's it you know essentially
kills his dad and calls it a day but it
is kind of intriguing because what this
also does is it feeds into the idea of
who it is that's pulling the strings
now with the character of Dakin you know
we're not initially told all we're told
is that it seems like to a degree he's
terrified of this guy and we're you know
this this head honcho sends a messenger
and says stay away from your dad and not
mingle with Wolverine do not do anything
with him the time will come when you can
fight but for right now you need to say
hidden away and you need to stay removed
they can of course kills the messenger
but ultimately it seems like he's
basically gonna defy these instructions
he's gonna go off and he's gonna do his
own thing now what this also does is
this picks up with the character of the
tinkerer now Phineas Mason he appeared
back an amazing spider-man number two in
1963 he was made by Stan Lee if Steve
Steve Ditko and the funny thing is he's
just like this super genius or not
really super genius but he's a really
really good at like inventing things or
working on things different stuff like
that and the funny thing about this is
that originally he was a villainous
spider-man he was called a terrible
tinkerer eventually he was basically a
guy whose services were available for
hire but so he was brought on board by
people like Quentin backhand rocket
racer and so on and so forth but he's
one of those characters that you see in
Marvel Comics where he'll just appear
from time to time and he'll never really
have any major role aside from the fact
that like some villains somewhere will
go to him or even some some heroes will
go to him and say I need you to work on
this or I need you to tell me how this
works or where it came from
or something along those lines and
that's what is up happening with the
character of cyber he ends up showing up
and basically you know telling his whole
back story to the tinkerer and what we
end up finding out here is that
somewhere along the line he was brought
on board at a training academy where
Wolverine had worked and this seems to
be the Academy he partook in up in
Hudson before he became part of like
Alpha Flight so the whole idea behind
this was that he was basically designed
to Train Wolverine that was really about
it and the result was that eventually
his escapades and exploits led him to
Nick Fury whereby he became an informant
for shield just providing him with all
manner of information now eventually he
was freed and that run into when he ends
up you know being killed basically by
these little robot bugs it is kind of
crazy and then of course he provides a
little bit of an explanation with
regards to him basically showing up on
the doorstep of meelo and then taking
over his mind and so on and so forth but
for the character of Wolverine remember
the carbonadium synthesizer is what he's
been hunting for this entire time we had
that in the last in the last video the
carbonadium synthesizer basically
synthesizing a metal that can weaken
people healing factors and that's what
will range hunting for especially now
because his hunt as son is hunting for
now notice Wolverines not going after
the Muramasa blade the initial
indication here is that his goal is not
to kill Dakin his goal is to disabled a
it would allow him to injure Dakin just
enough that his healing factor would
shut down and then in turn subdue him or
whatever it is if he ends up you know
feeling like he wants to do and so where
he ends up going into this to this bacon
Brussels more or less to access the
safety deposit box where he'd been told
by a black widow natasha romanoff that
the actual carbonadium synthesizer was
being held
he suddenly met with the arrival of
bacon now again this is old-school
Wolverine versus new-school will rank
they give is designed to represent
classic will rank ruthless hardcore
hunting but also remember he's
headstrong and he's a bit arrogant here
the other thing to bear in mind here is
that Dakin does not have adamantium he's
just got bone and so again that's one of
the reasons why it's character works
here is because it's kind of a response
to the way Wolverine used to be now
again this is kind of cool because we're
in even comments this does look like
you're weak and again that's true I mean
we're talking about classic we'll rant I
mean let's say for example this fight
took place when Wolverine was in his
feral State then like naked would get
torn to shreds but again because of the
fact that he's grown soft over the years
because of the fact that he's not nearly
as hardcore and ruthless as a you used
to be and because as his son and he's
not really fighting to kill ultimately
bacon gets the upper hand temporarily
now of course again slashing across the
throat doesn't make much of a difference
in terms of killing Wolverine what it
does is it slows them down because while
his healing factor will kick in and
it'll basically heal his throat the
problem with this is that he's bleeding
out which means oxygens not reaching his
head and it'll ultimately cause him to
become woozy and then pass out now of
course once the healing factor kicks in
his throat heals and Blood starts
pumping to all the veins like its
supposed to he'll be right as rain but
until that time comes
we're met with the arrival of cyber and
this is interesting because the
responsive cyber is I'm here for you
like I have been sent here on a mission
to find you by the person who's pulling
the strings and so again this hidden
hand behind everything is the one that's
running this entire show and that's
what's cool because with cypher
basically having gone to Tinker and said
I want you to put adamantium on this new
body while Deacon is capable big is not
strong enough to be able to take on
cyber by himself I mean in this body
cybers got super strength and he's got
adamantium bonded to his physical form
and so there's no way that they getting
to be able to take this guy down and so
if the result is that we just kind of
end up having wolf rain of course coming
to he subdues cyber for a bit of time
trying to give taking the ability to
take this guy out and then of course
they can just kind of says whatever and
then just ultimately ends up leaving but
we also end up finding out here is that
this body that cyber is in is an
happening at the moment actually has a
heart defect his body grew too fast for
his heart to be able to handle and so
the result is that you know if you push
himself too hard too fast
he'd suffer a heart attack and that's
exactly what happens to cyber he
literally starts to suffer a heart
attack will reign just kind of you know
takes some rescues him and then that's
really about it now this is not done
because Wolverine is legitimate like a
good guy where he's like oh man no I
can't let you die because that would be
the wrong thing to do instead it's
basically like I need information and in
the here and now you're the only one who
has it it's really more of like I'm
going to preserve you if for no other
reason than in fact I need your help
with this and so if the result is that
it's really kind of an exchange of
source so that's what theme to bear in
mind when you get into this level and
that's one of the reasons why I like you
know a lot of the Wolverine stories and
even street-level heroes stories when
you get into this level of storytelling
what you're talking about is people who
have been forged in the fires of
conflict and there is a kind of bond
that forms between those two guys even
if they're the most mortal of enemies
there's a bond that forms between the
two of them and with regards to you know
Wolverine and with regards to cyber
because of the fact that they have such
a lengthy history together it really
kind of works now the other half of this
is that when Wolverine takes a cyber
back to the tank work just because of
the fact that you know so hours like
Halo tinker is the one that put this
stuff on me ultimately wolf right hands
the carbonadium synthesizer over so say
look here's what I need tinker ends up
giving harbor you know some pills to
basically help him recover from his
injury and then we start to get this
whole backstory and what we end up
finding out here is that the training
facility that Wolverine had been
stationed at was actually ran by a guy
named Frederick Hudson now
Frederick Hudson is the grandfather of
James Hudson also known as Vindicator
for you know those of you guys who are
familiar with Alpha Flight if you're not
familiar with Alpha Flight the only
thing you really need to know is they
kind of feed into the history of
Wolverine which is to say that James and
Heather Hudson had basically come across
wolve reign while he was in the woods
and the result was that they brought him
in and then wanted to induct him into
the Alpha Flight team but ultimately
Wolverine turned it down awful flight is
is really kind of like a black ops super
human team more or less early it's kind
of super human team in general operating
as a joint venture between canada's
department h and their federal
government so the fact remains here that
what we're told is that on the back end
a part of the story that we didn't know
about was that where wolverine was being
trained in this facility by you know at
least that was being led by frederick
hudson that silas burr had been brought
in due to the fact that there was a
previous point in his life when he had
managed to convince a handful of guys to
engage in all these heinous acts and so
Frederick Frederick
bring him in was basically saying your
job is to train specifically wolf ray to
make him an animal because the whole
idea here was that's who he is that's
his nature is to be an animal is to be
violent sadistic and your job is to make
sure that happens and so why not what
Silas ver basically ends up bringing up
is that werewolves reigneth fall in love
with a woman named Janet and then Silas
bird had killed Jen and under the orders
of Frederick Hudson that this was
actually a recurring theme every single
relationship that Wolverine was ever in
you know all the women that Wolverine
loved and were killed that was done
intentionally it wasn't just because
Wolverine was in the wrong place at the
wrong time or because he brings doom and
gloom to everyone he ever falls in love
with it was orchestrated to be that way
by this guy pulling the strings behind
the scenes in addition to that we also
enough finding out that Wolverine had
basically had the tanker of foreign
bullets out of carbonadium using the
carbonadium synthesizer the other half
of this is that with a character of
cyber because of the fact that he
literally suffers from a heart condition
what the tinkerer did is essentially
attach a pacemaker to his body but it's
funny because he's you know when cyber
says like like how in the world is you
pull this off like what is this I know
is this thing adamantium the teacher
says no it's carbonating what called
radium is radioactive it'll kill you if
you have it on you long enough
and that's what's I were really you know
immediately realizes this dude no way
this is gonna get me killed man you have
to take this off you have to get this
off of me and what Tigger says is
there's no way you can it's stuck on
there forever
there's no feasible way to remove it now
what this does is it creates a ticking
clock some point along the lines in the
story a cyber is gonna die that's
basically what that means is it's really
the only conclusion you can draw from
that just because of the fact that we
know that again if a person is exposed
for carbonadium for any measure of time
meaning if it's part of their body if
they walk around with it and they keep
it that way for however long it'll
eventually it'll emit so much radiation
it'll just kill them so again that's the
that's the crazy thing about this but
the fun little tidbit of the story
basically comes in an epilogue and what
we end up having is Bucky Barnes and
essentially Bucky Barnes has been told
by Wolverine Hey look we got to settle
up you know and again this all goes back
to the origins and endings video if you
haven't seen that yet but it's basically
saying we gotta settle up and so in a
bus station at Locker number 93 you'll
find something and you'll find a note
and when he gets in there he ends up
fighting those three carbonadium bullets
and of course a note that's left there
by Wolverine that says I'll let you know
when to use them so again Bucky Barnes
being drawn back in the story is really
kind of progressing and actually moving
pretty well I love
Wolverine Origins it's definitely one of
my favorite stories okay so continuing
on with our x-men chronology which we've
moved to Sundays we're gonna cheat a
little bit we're actually gonna kind of
take part of a story and cover that not
really part of a story here's the deal
so as part of the whole aftermath to the
House of M which is to say the Scarlet
Witch taking everybody's powers there
were a whole bunch of ancillary stories
that came out of this and it was really
kind of like reworking and revitalizing
the x-men for the villain apocalypse who
had long stole Ong stood as one of the
x-men's most dangerous villain he had
always had something called the four
horsemen and the four horsemen
originally as they were introduced well
really with Louise and Walter Simonson
the whole idea was to basically have the
four horsemen be this kind of Marvel
Comics embodiment of like the Four
Horsemen of Bill of the biblical
apocalypse from the Book of Revelations
now the idea was that originally
Apocalypse would grab mutants whose
powers complemented the role he would
give them so for example one of the the
really one of the first members of the f
were horsemen was a Morlock called
plague who had the ability to spread
like disease and illness and apocalypse
turned her into pestilence now because
of the fact that apocalypse having
horsemen was such a popular concept
which is really kind of like bolstered
by exid in the animated series the idea
of the horse and themselves became
wildly popular and so it was one of
those things where every time apocalypse
showed up he usually have a different
set of horsemen just because of the fact
that the horsemen he had before had been
defeated but over the years Marvel began
to kind of move away from the powers
have to complement the role they play to
just what would make a really cool
horseman now by and large when
apocalypse has his four horsemen really
like the beam death it's kind of like
the the cut above the rest
usually when apocalypse sits down and
says Who am I going to make it to my
horsemen there's pestilence there's
famine these different roles that people
play and then there's death and death is
like usually the most popular one that
was a trend that was set in motion with
angel with when Warren Worthington
became the horseman death and it was
cool because I mean he was leading like
famine and war and pestilence and it was
cool to see him leading those those
particular roles but the fact remains
here that the the character the person
who plays death is always the most
popular the only exception to that I
think is the Incredible Hulk who was war
but like Wolverine for example was the
horseman death at one point along line
and so the idea and we'll talk more
about this once we actually cover the
blood of apocalypse story but the idea
was that with this story blood of
apocalypse it was essentially a scenario
whereby apocalypse had been woken up
from his slumber by virtue of the fact
it's
many mutants had lost their powers just
this massive reduction in energy I just
kind of snapped him out now remember
when it comes to apocalypse he usually
lays down and slumbers to kind of
rejuvenate his abilities and it could
depend marvel he just kind of plays it
fast and loose on how long he sleeps for
the most part it's usually for anywhere
between a few thousand years sometimes
even a short is like a few hundred years
but the idea is that ever since
apocalypse first woke up within the last
you know couple thousand years or so the
idea was that he's been on a constant
crusade to try to take over the world
now eventually he'll go back into its
slumber and he'll sleep for like another
two thousand years and then when he
emerges he'll try to take over the world
again which he successfully dead in
cable's future but the whole idea is
that when he emerged when he basically
woke up he actually showed up on the
grounds of the X of the Xavier Institute
of the x-men mansion and was like I come
here with vials of my blood those who
believed in me drink my blood and you
will basically gain your powers you'll
get your powers back or get some kind of
powers back and those of you who don't
feel free to just kind of live down here
in the slums so to speak and so what you
ended up having was kind of like this
mutant civil war to a degree you had
those who were faithful to apocalypse
and those who were not the idea was that
gambit turned himself over to apocalypse
and we didn't know why what this does is
it explains why but it kind of gives us
like the transmogrification of gambit
which is to say the process he undergoes
to a degree on how he becomes the
horseman death now it's kind of funny
because when he first showed up to
apocalypse it was well the x-men never
appreciated me so I'm turning myself
over to you because hopefully you could
show some measure of appreciation I
remember most all the x-men know who
apocalypse is and for those of you guys
who were not familiar the apocalypse you
saw in the Fox movie that was a sham
that's that's nowhere near how powerful
apocalypse is apocalypse is crazy
powerful like he can augment any of it
he can honor in his body to become
anything he can give himself the power
of flight he can change his lens and
like weapons and shields and like energy
projections and you know like like shoot
energy beams and things like that he can
grow to like any size he can shape-shift
it's crazy the kind of powers he
displays he's a one-man army and if it
really came down to it this is kind of a
funny thing about the character of
apocalypse but because he's so powerful
you don't really see him fight the x-men
all that often and usually the way the
fights happen is apocalypse shows up he
sends forth his horsemen his first were
defeated apocalypse says you know he
says fine I'll see you guys next time
but if it came down to it and apocalypse
like you know you wanted
right a story where apocalypse killed
the x-men he would just show up in the
Xavier Institute he would just blast the
entirety of the Xavier Institute every
single x-man that tried to face off
against him would stand no chance they
would be totally obliterated and
apocalypse would just walk away that
story would be like three pages long it
would not be huge and it would fit in
because he's just that damn powerful
it's crazy how capable he is but gambit
showing up it's one of these interesting
things because when you're gambit and
you've been part of the x-men in a lot
of ways he has the right to feel
betrayed because he has been multiple
times you're a gambit first showed up
back in the old Exedy on the old uncanny
x-men stories his appearance came with
the fact that he was very ambiguous
nobody really knew anything about his
past when the x-men discovered that he
had basically led the the Marauders of
mr. sinister into the tunnels of New
York and then the Marauders had engaged
in the Morlock massacre while gambit did
not partake in the massacre the x-men
thought he did and they immediately
kicked him off the team they wouldn't
even let him plead his case they just
kicked him off the team and that was the
end of that no gambit eventually came
back but has always been this idea -
despite the fact that gambit is been
part of the x-men the x-men have never
fully trusted him now a lot of us
because gambits never really like put
all his cards on the table so to speak
he's never laid his whole life to bear
for the x-men to see he has with rogue
to a degree but even the conversations
with rogue have been like don't tell
anybody else what I've told you because
this is very important to me that kind
of a thing and so because that is it's
one of those scenarios where he really
is very mysterious even in the eyes of
the x-men in a lot of different ways and
so when he shows up here and he hands
himself over to apocalypse in a lot of
ways he kind of wants to believe it's
kind of a desire to belong somewhere you
know where apocalypse shows up it says I
will make this world better I will give
you guys your powers back you know
gambit kind of wants to believe that it
wants to say look you're going to make
the world a better place I hope you will
because you can but it's also kind of
funny too
because gamma ask questions like what in
the world is that thing do and an
apocalypse is like ah that's the cloth
Horace and I actually don't really know
it just kind of messes with your body a
little bit I guess
now this is kind of funny here because
in truth apocalypse inherently like
let's say for example we strip away all
the technology of apocalypse he's just a
mutant who's immortal and is like really
strong and that's really about it
apocalypse is the ability to access
celestial technology that's what grants
him all the special powers that he has
that's what elevated him from just like
an external illegitimate Lee immortal
mutant
you like ungodly like a demigod you
that's that's the only thing that really
elevated him to that position is a
celestial tech but it's fine having
meddled with it to a degree
apocalypse doesn't understand it fully
he understands like if you expose
someone to it and you set the Machine in
motion it'll start augmenting their
powers and they'll come out either with
a new set of powers or with like a
heightened heightened level of their
existing powers but apocalypse doesn't
understand it 100% of the way and that's
kind of the interesting thing is because
for him if you go back and you read the
old like cable and Deadpool stories
where it talks about how cable was the
traveler and he went back and met
apocalypse for the first time and like
fought him and was the reason why
apocalypse was able to augment with
celestial technology anyway despite the
fact that he had this access his mind
couldn't necessarily comprehend this
technological stuff that was there that
was hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years way ahead of anything
humanity was able to achieve even it
right now in the modern day apocalypse
being able to use celestial technology
is essentially you being exposed to like
an alien spacecraft and then being able
to turn it on that's basically what it
amounts to like okay cool you turned it
on awesome all right now like you know
if I do this this thing happens but I
don't really know why it happens I just
know that it does happen that's just
kind of how apocalypse functions when it
comes to that celestial tech now the
other half of this is also ascribe
Ozymandias now remember Ozymandias was
one of the generals of kay in the
conqueror back when Cain the Conqueror
lived in ancient Egypt an apocalypse
first rose to power
now parklets of course uses power to
essentially turn Ozymandias into like
living stone and the idea was that from
that point until the end of time
Ozymandias would be doomed to do nothing
more than just chronicle the events of
apocalypse every action apocalypse makes
every action that takes place as a
result of apocalypse all those different
things that's the entire role Ozymandias
plays and nothing more than that but it
is kind of funny because apocalypse
initially tries to play on the idea of
gambit feeling abandoned by the x-men
which game it kind of allows them to do
to a degree but then we learn gambits
true motivation and what gambit
basically says here is I'm not doing
this because I truly believe in you I
believe you might do something good I
believe that like you're you say you
want to do some good things but I'm
doing this because somebody's got to
keep an eye on you that as the horseman
death my powers which were already
formidable will be augmented and
heightened and in your hubris you will
likely believe that I cannot take you
down and so when these events unfold
when everything begins to come to
fruition if what we find out is that
this whole charade
like I'm here to make everything better
and I'm here to bring you guys to a
better place you know if that's all just
a facade and if it's really just classic
apocalypse who's using the moment to try
to seize control of the world if that's
really all it is
then gambit will be there to stop him
now whether or not gambit could truly do
it on his own
we'll have to wait until we get to the
story to find out but this is the
process by which gambit undergoes to
become the horseman death and let me
tell you some man like as horsemen death
he looks amazing dude he looks so good
he's one of the coolest looking Horsemen
of apocalypse that there's ever been
with like the all-black and the red eyes
and like the long hair it looks so beast
he's pretty amazing but I figured you
guys might enjoy this I thought you guys
might dig this whole thing of like
gambit becoming a horseman of apocalypse
becoming the horseman death all right so
continuing our videos on the x-men
chronology which we need to get back on
track with this remember all this stuff
comes after house of M and this is kind
of cool because this is basically like
the return of pockle of apocalypse after
the events of house of M now apocalypse
has always been a really really
interesting villain he's one of these
characters that nobody ever really knows
how to write and the reason why is
because from the time he was introduced
in over the years especially in the 90s
and like the x-factor stories with the
original team and the x-factor stories
with the second team the
government-sanctioned team apocalypse
was always one of these villains where
it's like if he chose to he could
eradicate the x-men he could just
destroy them in their entirety he's just
that powerful so the question became
what do you do with a villain like that
now in truth all that goes back to
x-factor issue number four or five when
he made his first appearance by Louise
Simonson at Walter Simonson and he
always used horseman and that was kind
of the caveat that Marvel would
introduce but it was always kind of a
skewed I like okay apocalypse sends out
his horsemen the x-men are the x-factor
defeat the you know defeat the horsemen
so why does an apocalypse step in
instead of just leaving apocalypse just
kind of takes off and the way that
Marvel works to basically explain this
was essentially saying but Apocalypse
believes in a social darwinism
apocalypse makes efforts to conquer the
world because in his mind he believes
that he's making people in the world
stronger and so if he has horsemen and
if he sends those horsemen out and the
x-men defeat the horsemen the x-men have
proven themselves worthy for the time
and apocalypse just leaves that's kind
of how a Marvel managed to work that
whole thing in in terms of providing an
answer of why apocalypse doesn't just
destroy all the x-men now there have
been times where apocalypse has made
moves and jumped into different schemes
that are outside of determining whether
or not the x-men are worthy and is for a
specific goal and
it's taken the power of multiple groups
the Avengers the x-men Fantastic Four
x-factor so on and so forth to like get
him to go away but one thing to bear in
mind it's really as far as I'm aware
when it comes to the character of
Apocalypse he's never truly been
defeated he's just kind of been staved
off it's kind of been like okay I don't
feel like dealing with this anymore and
then he just leaves but the cool thing
about this is that after the events of
house of M because 98% of the mutant
population lost its powers apocalypse
just woke up and I remember apocalypse
slumbers right like he goes through like
these one or two thousand years slumbers
or he'll just kind of stay dormant for a
while and it's away from all over to
kind of ride him out and then just bring
him back you know five years or ten
years down the line whenever they want
him to return but he basically shows up
here with this massive Sphinx that he's
built of course modeled after himself
alongside a character named gazer and
gazer was just one of these mutants out
there that was pondering ending his life
more or less and the result was that he
was basically taken by apocalypse and
he's gonna be transformed into a
horseman now this is one thing to keep
in mind whenever apocalypse turns
someone into a horseman he usually
doesn't take individuals who lust for it
there are people out there who want to
be a Horsemen of apocalypse and he
usually rejects them because what he
wants is to basically grab a person who
is deemed to basically be weak whether
they're weak in mind or spirit or
they're weak physically you know it's
the idea that like he can push them and
make them worthy by subjecting them to
genetic modification to brainwashing and
turning them into a horseman so it's
kind of like you know I'm making you
someone worthy and then in turn you'll
go forward and do my bidding but at this
point we switch over to the horseman of
pestilence and of course the whole role
of pestilence is to basically spread
illnesses across the world now depending
on what era were talking about this can
be done in different ways whenever
Apocalypse chooses a person to become a
horseman
he usually selects an individual whose
powers will complement whatever role
they're going to be playing and so
historically speaking when a person
became pestilence it was usually a
mutant sometimes a human but usually a
mutant that had the ability to basically
kill things with you know they had like
a death touch of sorts or the ability to
like spread disease or to make a person
sick or something along those lines that
was the original pestilence in this
instance with the mutant population
being so low to be quite frank the
pickings are slim that's really all it
is and it's kind of cool because in this
instance Essos is actually going to like
various places around the world and
grabbing all these different diseases
that bubonic plague and smallpox and
things like that just rallying all these
illnesses that humanity
would normally have a kind of cure for
and then in turn destroy the various
cures that exist for those illnesses so
it's essentially having all these
illnesses in his possession and no way
to stop it now at this point we jump
back to gazer and again this is the
nature of becoming a horseman for the
most part most horsemen are already like
tried and proven in the sense that like
they've been forged in the fires of
combat or they know how to fight or
whatever the case may be but this goes
all the way back to the original
x-factor story the idea was that when
apocalypse first made the horsemen there
was no real leadership among the
horsemen it was just four horsemen and
so what he did is he had them all fight
each other and whoever won would be the
leader and it turned out to be angel or
I guess arc angel who was the horseman
death who became the leader of the
horsemen the result is that in this
instance and because of Apocalypse is
basically in a rush it's let's test
these guys let's see what they're worth
we're gonna put their mettle to the test
essentially to see if one of them is
gonna become a horseman and whoever wins
they're the one who will become the
horseman war of course Ozymandias steps
in and takes out one of the other guys
and spares gazer now Ozymandias is of
course the chronicler of apocalypse the
only real role he serves is to
essentially write down the whole life
and times of Apocalypse and so the
result is that awesome anteus has really
kind of become the scheming guy now a
lot of that goes into the origin of
Ozymandias which you're welcome to watch
the video down in the description which
will give you the origin on his whole
character suffice it to say he was
unwillingly forced into his position and
the result is that he's really been
working over the millennia to try to
find a way to like destroy apocalypse
and free himself from his imprisonment
and possibly even replace apocalypse and
so that's the whole basis behind his
idea the issue with this is that for
Apocalypse himself he has to find a new
Horseman you know he's fine you know the
the third horseman that he's looking for
and so what we end up doing is switching
over to Sun fire now this picks up out
of an existing story that would there
really was no reason for us to cover it
was basically an idea where Sun fire was
you know had kind of jumped into a
conflict he was double-crossed and he
had his legs cut off by Lady Deathstrike
who was the one time love interest of
Wolverine turned into a villain having
cyborg modifications the reason why he's
kind of in this infirmary is because of
that because his legs have been removed
but the idea was Sunfire is he's always
been exceedingly proud if not arrogant
now he had a huge empire under his belt
and that's why he was all really happy
that's why I kind of maintain that
mindset but the idea that he's now
bedridden because he lost his legs is a
pretty crushing blow because in his mind
he's kind of like half the person he
used to be but the idea is that
apocalypse showing up on his doorstep
and basically saying hey look I
recognize you lack faith in yourself now
I can give you the means to return
yourself to who you were before
Sunfire almost leaps at the opportunity
the problem with this is that Sunfire
knows who apocalypse is and when the
devil makes deals those deals always
have caveats and that's what this is
about it's really kind of this situation
where sun fires like yeah you show up
this gift is too good to be true there
has to be something with it but in the
end he ends up going with it he ends up
taking the offer it's provided to him by
apocalypse and so what we end up doing
is jumping back to the Xavier mansion
now one thing else wanted want you guys
to bear in mind this takes place before
the events of deadly Genesis and I'll
throw this under that playlist before
that story so that you guys don't really
get confused in terms of where it's
supposed to reside but the ideas that
Xavier hasn't returned yet the issue
with this is that Polaris has basically
gone missing now of course Lorna Dane
the daughter of magneto or at least you
know it was believed she was a daughter
of magneto at this point in time was a
love interest of both havoc and Bobby
Drake havoc being the brother of Cyclops
Bobby Drake being Iceman the issue of
this is that while she wasn't really
dating them at the same time they've
dated her at different points in time
and so they both have a romantic
interest towards her now at this moment
havoc was the one who was believed to be
romantically involved with her but
ultimately things kind of went awry and
she just sort of vanished and that was
about it but the issue is that
apocalypse pops up on the scene and
suddenly people begin to panic and the
reason why is because again when
apocalypse shows up your head turns
because that's when things are about to
pop off the guy can do all manner of
things he's one of the most powerful
mutants to ever exist and when the x-men
face off against apocalypse is always
preceded by the horsemen and then the
question has to be asked is this the day
of ha caliphs will kill us and by all
rights he should be able to destroy them
the other half of this is that
apocalypse doesn't show up looking for
battle he shows up and says I'm here to
save you all now what you guys are at
right now because of the fact that you
guys are basically at 10% of the
population that you used to have you
guys have proven yourselves worthy now
that's kind of the irony of it because
they had no hand in that it was like a
massive battle went on in the you know
whatever 198th mutants survived to be
the ones who'd be allowed to keep their
powers they have them all stripped away
by the Scarlet Witch but apocalypse
deems them worthy and that's kind of a
thing to bear in mind when is with this
character when it comes to who the who's
worthy and who's not its we'll just kind
of left to his own devices its whoever
he likes the most it is cool because
when apocalypse shows up he basically
says I am planting the seeds of like
plague in disease
illness and like 90% of humanity is
going to be destroyed but what I have
here is something that can keep you
protected the other half of this is that
famines suddenly start showing out now
of course famine like you would expect
basically has the ability to force
people into believing that they're
they're basically starving that they're
you know dehydrating you know because
they're exceedingly thirsty an
apocalypse says well I have this this
drink here one sip of this drink will
quench any thirst you have it'll satiate
any hunger that you have if you want it
all you have to do is pledge your
loyalty to me
people just come flying at them some of
them kind of stand back and sure they're
struggling just like everybody else and
they're they believe they're starving
just like everybody else but they don't
really give in and those individuals who
don't really give up are the ones who
are experienced with this we're like
look this is the game that apocalypse
plays this is how he does this but for
the most part people don't care they're
just kind of like whatever you know this
guy has the ability to satiate whatever
hunger I have I will do whatever it is
he asks me to do if he gives me some
measure of nourishment so again this is
why he kind of shows up as a messiah of
sorts the issue is that in the middle of
all this we're suddenly met by the
arrival of gambit who effectively hands
himself over to apocalypse now again we
covered this in terms of like gambit
becoming the horseman death so if you
want to know what happens after this
moment between you know what we're about
to talk about here in a second and like
this point where he shows up that's
covered in that particular comic but it
is kind of intriguing because gambits
always been one of these guys who's kind
of an on-again-off-again an x-man and
you know felt betrayed by the x-men but
he always comes back so there is a lot
of loyalty to the x-men there and in
fact that's something that he says when
he's being turned into a horseman I'm
not doing this because I believe in your
cause I'm doing this because someone
needs to keep you in check but again
there's a lot of scheming and stuff
going on here behind the scenes with
Ozymandias and this is kind of the funny
moment because Ozymandias is talking to
apocalypse and he's basically saying
look you should have just obliterated
them like why not destroy humanity like
why not wipe out humanity in its
entirety they're weak and if though if
they're weak and the weak don't deserve
to live then destroy the weak destroy
humanity and war apocalypse kind of
counters with this and saying you have
no idea what's going on Ozymandias his
initial response is well you've grown
weak over the years and apocalypse slams
his head into a wall and that's what I
love so much about that because he's
like I've had enough of your trash talk
man like and that's that's that's what's
so ironic is apocalypse could just kill
him apocalypse his belief system of
social Darwinism
of the fittest only the strongest
deserve to survive it is both a platform
by means by which he makes his case and
his own prison will only the strong
deserve to survive and a person who's
strong enough to kill me
must be exceedingly strong if I'm
destroyed by this person then that
person deserves to destroy me I deserve
to die whereas he looks at this
circumstance and it is well we can't
destroy humanity because they have to
prove themselves worthy but life would
be easier if humanity was obliterated
off the face of the earth and all that
was left his mutants but again with this
whole idea of scheming sneaking behind
the scenes all this cloak-and-dagger
stuff
initially Ozymandias tries to strike a
deal with with war simply showing up to
gazer and saying look man I saved your
life when you were gazer so that you
could become a horseman you are now I
told you a debt would be owed I'm asking
you this favor I need you to help me
destroy apocalypse and initially gage
doesn't really offer an answer war
doesn't really tell him what direction
he's gonna go in he just kind of
shuffles around a bit now this is
something else I also want you guys to
notice too when it comes to characters
and Marvel comics take like Franklin
Richards for example exceedingly
powerful as powerful as they always are
Marvel always builds in caveats or at
least they try to
in this instance there is a way to
basically shut down the powers of
Apocalypse you have this guy named pulse
who seemingly has the ability to do that
you know pulse has this ability to kind
of take down of how apocalypse has
powers even if it's only temporary even
if it's only for a short amount of time
the issue is that a being of that
caliber a being of that power almost
seems beyond pulses ability to basically
take down on his own
and so of course you'll play the role
and you'll do whatever it is that he
needs to do but it is kind of cool
because it's like you trying to
benchpress 500 pounds having never
lifted weights before and so ultimately
we basically pick up with the idea that
Sunfire is famine having made his
arrival and you know forcing everybody
to believe they're starving and so on
and so forth he basically been captured
by the x-men and what this did is it
allowed the x-men to hold him in stasis
and then in turn decide how they were
going to revert him back to being
Sunfire because bear in mind when a
person becomes a horseman there are
modifications genetic modifications that
are made to them sometimes they're given
new powers and their old powers are
wiped away sometimes their old powers
are enhanced sometimes they have no
powers and they're given powers but when
it comes to like believing that they're
horsemen death or their horsemen war or
famine or pestilence they're brainwashed
into believing that for the most part it
usually works depending on the character
but Marvel always builds that in is like
a way to bring them back when Wolverine
became a horseman of apocalypse it took
like I think it was
Lior kitty pryde I could have remember
which one it was one of the two who
basically showed up and said it look
like you have to come back like you have
to be one of us remember who you are and
then he regained his mind and that was
really about it but of course Ozymandias
shows up basically sneaks into the x-men
mansion you end up having war who runs
through apocalypse spills the beans
about the traitorous nature of
Ozymandias and so Ozymandias says look I
want to take down apocalypse just as bad
as you guys do our motivations for why
we want to take him down are different
but we both want to take him down he
leads them inside the Sphinx through a
secret passage and when they arrive
apocalypse is basically ready for them
all and that's what's so ironic this
moment right here this moment when like
havoc shows up and rogue shows up should
have been the destruction of these guys
apocalypse should've just been like nope
and then just wipes them all away you
know and just obliterates them in their
entirety which he could but instead he's
just like I am NOT alone here are those
who follow me as well as my horsemen and
it's just kind of like okay I mean I
guess that works but then you also
haven't revealing the newest Horsemen of
gambit the horsemen death and I want to
say right now
he looks so amazing as the horsemen
death my lovely he's got the whole like
you know like early 2000s goth like I'm
so misunderstood by the world you know
the whole emo look but initially Rogue
tries to bring him back and again you
know the the kind of inner turmoil that
you deal with when it comes to these
various individuals who end up being
turned into horsemen rogue tries to
bring him back by sort of building on
that connection the two of them have
shared over the years of fact that
they've been in love it doesn't really
work not initially anyway Lisa doesn't
seem like it instead he just kind of
continues this campaign to take on these
various x-men now of course this leads
to the destruction of the cure which of
course forces apocalypse to kind of
scrap the plans as they exist now and
modify them a little bit apocalypse says
okay fine look it's time to go we got to
get out of here like like we'll go
modify our plants we'll worry about the
x-men later for right now we need to go
focus on bigger things on better things
and so what is up happening is
apocalypse alongside his horsemen shows
up at the United Nations and essentially
makes this giant declaration to all of
humanity he but you know he basically
says look here's what's gonna happen
only 10% of the mutant population is
left and so humanity will call its
population by 90% meaning they'll
eradicate 90% of their own population
you guys will be on an even keel but
it's kind of cool because he backed him
into a corner he says right now my
horsemen pestilence has all these
illnesses and diseases that are out
there and will unleash them across the
world either you can sacrifice
90 percent of humanity or
we'll wipe out 100% of humanity the
choice is yours and you have a week to
decide what you want to come up with now
this is kind of cool because logic would
dictate you would wipe out 90% of
humanity like you you would say okay
fine we got to wipe out 90% and maintain
the last 10% is utilitarianism the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few but when you're dealing with numbers
that are almost that small when there's
there's a 10% difference between the
mini and the few is there really a
difference at all percentages make huge
differences when it comes to like
numbers and things like that so it is
kind of funny when you look at it from
that perspective but the fact remains
here that what is up happening is we end
up switching over to you know Valerie
Cooper meeting up with x-men and havoc
now of course Valerie Cooper was at one
point the liaison between the
government-sanctioned
x-factor team and like the federal
government itself and so she would pass
information to them and she would keep
the government abreast of what x-factor
was doing and they would usually get
their missions from the federal
government and the result was that once
Valerie basically left that position she
kind of went on to other things but
still worked alongside the government in
fact she was originally part of project
wide-awake which was the government
program to control and contain the
mutant threat when it first started
popping up so she's been around for
quite some time but the idea here is
that what they basically been working on
or like these more advanced versions of
sentinels basically signals that are
still man that are still controlled so
they don't have to worry about like a
Days of Future past event but they are
they are more capable of taking down
more powerful threats
it's basically them just kind of
stockpiling weapons and planning for
like bigger and more dangerous things
and so what we end up doing is switching
back over to apocalypse in a
conversation that he's having with with
pestilence only for us to find out that
pestilence is actually pilars that when
she had gone missing it's because
apocalypse had taken her and shanghaied
her into becoming one of his horsemen
where she fought and she didn't want to
have anything to do with it ultimately
she was pressed gained into it and she's
become a horseman this entire time and
so she's the one kind of operating
behind the scenes now the cool thing
about this is that with apocalypse you
know at the United Nations in New York
what we end up having is like the
arrival of the Avengers and the x-men
these massive superhero teams but the
Avengers aren't really there to like
defeat apocalypse I mean they're there
to beat him if they can but the whole
idea is to try to like take him out take
out his various forces take out his
horsemen which for the most part happens
now this is usually what goes on with
apocalypse in comics these horsemen pop
up and by whatever manner and whatever
means the horsemen are systematically
destroyed and it's away from all this
kind of
knock over the different pieces remove
two different pieces from the board so
they can whine this story down and so in
this instance apocalypse basically just
kind of retreats he disorder says okay
come to get while the getting's good and
that's one of the things about him is
usually whenever he leaves he's always
got a back-up plan to bail out as fast
as he can of course gambits defeated
essentially knocked unconscious
Colossus knocked unconscious and so
they're basically taken away and so
apocalypse retreats to the core of the
ship with the intention of just
sacrificing himself and killing himself
and that's what's so important about
this story is because apocalypse has
never done that before he's come very
very close to dying but apocalypse
usually always escapes sometimes by the
skin of his teeth sometimes because he
just walks away and says enough is
enough but this is one of the first
times if not the first time they
basically sacrificed himself and tried
to die and the reason why is because
what we end up finding out is when
apocalypse was younger and he first
encountered celestial technology he
didn't know how to use it now largely
that was all due to the fact that he was
living in ancient Egypt and so I mean if
I went back there with a TV he wouldn't
know how to use it but he was basically
a technology way beyond his ability to
understand even right now in the Marvel
Universe for the most part with the
exception of like Reed Richards and
maybe Tony Stark so let's show
technology is way beyond anybody on
Earth's ability to understand it's you
know thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of years into the future in
terms of how advanced it is and what it
is that people can do with it but what
apocalypse is given is basically all the
information on how to access this
technology and how to use this
technology so for those of you guys who
are familiar with the cable and
Deadpool's story where we basically get
the the origin where like cable jumps
back in time and he basically fights
apocalypse and then apocalypse merges
with celestial technology and then
becomes uber powerful this takes place
right between that that particular story
this one right here takes place between
that cable and Deadpool story before
that story happens but when apocalypse
is basically you know met with the
arrival of the Celestials they basically
say we'll teach you like we'll give you
all the information you need you know
what Wilson is like well beam it into
your brain and you'll know exactly how
to use all of our technology but there
will be future payments now this is
where things are ambiguous because we're
not told what those future payments are
but because of the fact that this is all
part of x-men reload which again was
Marvel's way of basically getting rid of
all these older characters or shuffling
them around or taking them off the board
or whatever the case may be it was away
from woful to essentially remove up ha
clips who had just kind of being been a
lingering villian for a couple decades
who just floated around from time to
time you know honesty Marvel didn't
really need to do that it's not like
apocalypse showed up all the time you
know he'd show up whenever so I mean if
he never if we didn't see him again for
20 years fans would've been like yeah he
was probably just sleeping you know
whatever and they would have just
written it off that way but Marvel
decided to kind of take this story to
basically remove him from the equation
and as far as I'm aware the original
intention was to actually kill him off
so that we would never see him again
which of course didn't happen because he
comes back later on okay we're getting
into x-men deadly Genesis and to be
honest there are a couple of stories
that we've left out so far a lot of
those stories are because I'm just kind
of pacing them out to cover them later
on
for example uncanny x-men the first
Forsaken that deals with the idea of
storm moving to Wakanda and taking up
residence in Africa then of course
there's a Black Panther story which
follows that up where storm and black
panther get married there's also cable
and Deadpool like bosom buddies and
living legends and so on and so forth
we're gonna cover that when the when
cable and Deadpool drop or at least when
Deadpool 2 comes out and that brings us
to what it is that we're gonna do next
so right now x-men deadly Genesis leads
into a few stories I mean really
expedited genesis kind of wraps up the
decimation branding so to speak which is
to say the aftermath of House of M and
it starts moving the x-men into the new
era of storytelling which is really I
call it like the Dark Age of the x-men
and that goes into things like Messiah
Complex Messiah War and all that kind of
cool stuff you know but because of the
fact that Deadpool 2 has been moved up
to May from June or July whatever it was
supposed to be one of the things that
I'm thinking about doing is going back
to the mid 90s and covering the story of
x-men of Nate gray after the events of
Age of Apocalypse and covering the solo
series and then running into cable and
Deadpool so regardless the cool thing
remember when it comes to the after you
know the the House of M aftermath and
really when it comes to like the x-men
titles as a whole for the most part
they're really just kind of stand-alone
you don't have to read through all the
x-men publications that again I'll
provide a reading order for everything
that that happens between house of M
running up two deadly Genesis so you
guys can kind of pick and choose what
you want to read but you can read them
in isolation if you want to for example
if for whatever reason you're interested
in like
multiple Man and x-factor you can just
read the x-factor stories you know if
you really care about the x-men you
could read uncanny x-men new x-men
different things like that there's a lot
of stuff that you can do when it comes
to picking and choosing what it is that
you want to cover but deadly Genesis is
a read con so for those of you guys who
have been on my channel for a while or
you're new to comic books or something
like that and you've heard me referenced
the phrase of a retcon
this is that in real time so you're
literally gonna be watching it unfold in
real time now what this does is it picks
up with regards to the you know office
of national emergency well the whole
idea behind this was that following the
events of decimation when a Scarlet
Witch stripped 98 percent of the mutant
population of their powers the office of
national emergency mobilized and then
they basically stationed sentinels
around the Xavier Institute to keep
anybody from going in and to keep
anybody from getting out and so the
x-men are prisoners but they're also
protected from any external threats but
regardless of the circumstance what we
do is we pick up out in space with a
giant chunk of the earth that was
catapulted into space and it's a guy who
basically wakes up and this is cool
because when this person wakes up what
he does is he basically obliterates the
entirety of this astronaut team and then
in turn goes into their ship and starts
analyzing everything going on only to
find out that he's in the 21st century
and this is cool because again we'll
figure out who this guy is because he's
actually crazy powerful but from here we
pick up with you know how each
individual person is largely dealing
with not only the events of decimation
but the vanishing of Charles Xavier
remember when it came to the main House
of M storyline one of the things that
was established was the Charles Xavier
had died you know well at least it was
believed that he had died nobody could
find Charles Xavier and for the most
part he's just largely been presumed
dead and that was a big question people
were asking where's Professor X and was
he just wiped from existence how did he
die that was a lot of the questions that
were being asked here now of course
picking up with Emma Frost and of course
the use of cerebral which is the huge
computer system they use to basically
analyze mutants across the planet
different things like that this is
basically one of those attempts where
Emma Frost goes in every day and sees
whether or not there were new mutants
who were popping up because remember it
from their perspective the number was
reduced but beasts made a really really
good point one of the things that Marvel
does is they'll use like real world
science but only when it's convenient
and this is one of those things where
it's convenient when they basically say
look you know mutant power whether it's
telepathy whether it's reality warping
whether it's energy projection or
what-have-you it takes a physical form
when you shoot energy out that energy
comes out like it impacts things if it
can impact something it has mass and
according to you know the law of
conservation of matter mass can't simply
just disappear because of the fact that
these powers whether it was telepathy
that was influencing the mind of others
you know whether it was energy
production someone who can just like
shoot energy out of their body or
something along those lines that energy
had to have gone somewhere
I can't simply just vanish now as we
know that energy is orbiting earth is
nobody's really aware of it most likely
because it's kind of a you know
noncorporeal form and it's just kind of
out there and you know just it's not
necessarily detectable regardless of the
circumstance with Emma Frost going into
cerebra and trying to analyze whatever
mutants are out there she's suddenly hit
by this massive blast of energy that
actually knocks her unconscious and the
first question everybody has is one of
the world's going on here because
remember Emma Frost is one of the most
powerful telepaths in the world and in
fact right now at this moment with
Charles Xavier out of the picture she's
the most powerful telepath on the planet
the fact that somebody was able to
overwhelm Emma Frost and send her into a
catatonic state is insane because it
means that their power is so extreme
that her mind couldn't handle all the
energy that was put off but the fact
remains here because this energy
signature emanated from a shuttle which
is since crash-landed into the earth of
course the x-men respond the other half
of this is that varying members of the
x-men begin to see these like horrific
images for example Kitty Pryde sees a
dead body Nightcrawler is forced to
basically relive his experience living
in West Germany and this is kind of a
big deal because what this means is that
all these different mutants are
basically being forced to kind of relive
some of the most horrific moments in
their lives once they also arrive on to
the scene they end up finding out like
this giant hand was basically reached
out of the ground and you know grab the
space shuttle to keep it from smashing
into bits but at this point we kind of
pick up with with a couple things that
are going on the first is with Sean
Cassidy and the second is with the
arrival of the x-men now Sean Cassidy
has been in Marvel Comics for quite some
time and he was a Chris Claremont
creation I want to say but he goes by
the name of banshee and he's actually
the love interest of more McTaggart
who's long since died in the realm of
Marvel Comics but Shaun Cassidy of
course was was head of like Cassidy keep
and part of like the whole Cassidy
family but because of the fact that more
has been gone for quite some time when
Cassidy are you know when Shaun
basically cut it has these visions where
he sees more on then the question is
what in the world's going on so of
course like anybody he chases after her
now the exact same thing happens with
the x-men with regards to like Cyclops
and Rachel summers and so on showing out
with a Shuttle crash and then Cyclops
seeing Jean Grey and chasing after her
now of course once Cyclops and Wolverine
chase after Jean Grey because of course
you know back in the day they were both
in love with her they turned the corner
only to find out that Rachel Summers has
been captured and she's being held by
this super powerful guy now picking up
with Shaun Cassidy for a second this
kind of a mental image of more McTaggart
that he's seen has led him to this
office that she had that he never really
knew about and inside this office she
kind of has like this diary
she basically talked about how terrible
the human being Charles Xavier was that
he was a horrible person he was
manipulative he was duplicitous that he
didn't really do anything that wouldn't
benefit him and this is huge
because this is one of the first times
in Marvel Comics where they basically
come along and they say that while
Charles Xavier on the on the outset was
like really firm and really harsh with
students with regards to their training
but was more of a loving father figure
this is them coming back and saying
actually he was a horrible human being
he was a terrible person and it's really
really interesting because when this
story first dropped things like this
were huge why the fact remains here that
with with regards to the the current
moment in the x-men dealing with you
know Rachel summers who's been captured
this guy dominates the x-men I mean it's
crazy well really at Cyclops and
Wolverine but like dominates them in
their entirety like he levitates
Wolverine
you know knocks him unconscious he slows
down the impulses to the brain of Rachel
summers effectively knocking her out but
the coolest Display of power this is one
of the things that I love the most is
when Cyclops goes to shoot his optic
blasts the guy forces the blast to go
around him and right back to Cyclops
which is cool because we've never seen a
person control optic beams like that
before and you know initially when I saw
this I was like okay so this guy's like
a reality warper which is crazy but he's
not he's not really a reality warper but
he almost might as well be because of
the kind of things that he can do but
the fact remains here that we end up
having the Office of National Emergency
responding due to the fact that the
x-men had basically left the grounds
without permission more or less they
just kind of you know flew the coop
without telling anybody and of course
you know once they arrive Cyclops and
out Rachel summers have been taken and
Wolverines the only one left and so I
mean from here is kind of a
straightforward moment in this sense
that Emma Frost and the other x-men fly
over to where the military's hanging out
at where they're holding like Wolverine
and so on and Emma Francis uses through
telepathy in order to free Wolverine and
that's really about it I mean it's it's
pretty straightforward in terms of what
we would expect for them to break
Wolverine out the cool thing about this
comes with Rachel summers and Cyclops
now we'll talk about Rachel summers here
in a second because she's a character
that we really really really need to
explain in order for you guys to
understand where it is you know her
character's coming from and why she's
here but the initial exchange between
the two of them is that you know with
with this guy basically using his powers
to slow down the brain impulses of
Rachel summers it's all she can do to
stay awake but the other half of this is
that where she and Cyclops are talking
to one another
what we end up finding out is this guy
shut off the powers of Cyclops now
technically speaking this should
be possible and and in truth it's kind
of interesting because this means a
couple of different things one it means
this person can control the mind of
Cyclops and effectively turn off its
powers but Cyclops those powers don't
work that way if there's any scenario
where Cyclops has this as a visor off
and its eyes open optic beams are gonna
come flying out because his eyes are
portals to another dimension and so what
this seems to indicate is that this guy
was basically you know by virtue of
shutting off Cyclops his powers blocked
access to his eyes being portals to this
other dimension and again if that's the
case it's still pretty extreme but for
the character of Rachel summers I want
to talk about her for a second so Rachel
summers is basically a time-displaced
character one of the things that we've
talked about when it comes to Marvel
comics is the nature of like alternate
realities Marvel uses something called
branch universe theory Marvel basically
says here's a singular universe there's
well there's the main Marvel Universe
and then at some point along the line
and you know events will take place like
spider-man will get the venom symbian
and the Fantastic Four will get their
powers and Charles Xavier will form the
x-men or something along those lines but
like an event will occur that will
branch off to a different universe and
sometimes it creates a new universe
sometimes it's the guaranteed future of
the existing universe for example the
guaranteed future of the main Marvel
Universe was Days of Future past at some
point in the future mystique was gonna
form a new Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
and they were going to assassinate
senator Robert Kelley more McTaggart the
mutant geneticists and Charles Xavier
and response humanity would jump start
the Sentinel program the centrioles will
become autonomous and they would
basically conquer North America that was
the absolute future what Chris Claremont
also said is in this future this Days of
Future past landscape Jean Grey and
Scott Summers would have a daughter
named Rachel and Rachel would have all
the powers of Jean Grey and none of the
powers of her father the result is that
Rachel summers would use her powers to
send the mind of Kitty Pryde into the
past and stop Days of Future past from
happening now this is where Marvel began
to experiment with the idea of the
multiverse because the questions fans
had is okay if the Days of Future past
is a guaranteed future and then Rachel
summers sends the mind of Kitty Pryde
into the past to stop the Days of Future
past then it creates a paradox if the
Days of Future past is stopped then why
would Rachel summers send the mind of
Kitty Pryde into the past to stop a
feature that never happens and so what
Marvel did is he said well it's an
alternate reality now because of the
fact that Days of Future past was
stopped now it's an alternate universe
and that alternate universe Days of
Future past continues on just like it
always did but the the guaranteed future
in the main
universe is still unwritten now we don't
really know where that future is going
to hold and so because of that Marvel
started using that as a way to basically
explain all these alternate universes
all these alternate realities but
because of the fact that the Days of
Future past became an alternate universe
after it was stopped Rachel summers
didn't understand why her future didn't
change and so in an effort to understand
why it didn't change she traveled into
the past
and because she went back she basically
travelled along this line and then back
to the point before Days of Future past
was supposed to happen that before the
assassination attempt basically by
mystique in the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants what it meant is that she jumped
from her universe into the main Marvel
Universe and into the past of the main
Marvel Universe and so that created a
story called Days of Future present
alongside like adult Franklin Richards
showing up going insane different things
like that but the whole idea behind this
was that with Rachel summers in the
present day she was one of those
characters that Marvel had just kind of
brought in and then never really knew
what to do with and so she was rolled
over onto like the Excalibur team
different things like that but she's
just kind of been free-floating in the
Marvel Universe ever since because
nobody ever really knew what to do with
her she was originally designed to kind
of be a stand-in for Jean Grey but fans
immediately rebuked it they were like we
do not want anyone but Jean Grey and so
eventually of course Jean Grey made her
return different things like that and
which was so much a relationship with
Jean Grey was a little tenuous you know
but it was still a pretty cool scenario
but the fact remains that's why Rachel's
here so having said that hopefully we
didn't know we didn't burn your mouth
your mind out too bad we didn't fry your
brains but at this point we pick up with
havoc with Alex Summers now Alex Summers
is actually a pretty cool character when
it comes to his whole story I mean he
just kind of shoots an energy and
different things like that the fun fact
about this is that he and Cyclops are
immune to the others powers because the
brothers so it's actually a cool little
caveat when it comes to the two of them
but the cool thing about Alex summers is
that this deals with the idea of Iceman
Bobby Drake and then Lorna Dane pilars
and the cool thing was that originally
he was having him pilars who were
together and then she bailed on him for
body drink and it was kind of cool
because that really went into like
x-factor that line of storytelling the
kind of dealt with this whole tenuous
love triangle the fact remains is really
just you know Alex summers being forced
to relive these darker memories that he
was really just kind of rather avoid now
the other half of this is it again this
guy shows up and just kind of taught
Cyclops to a degree basically saying I
know everything about you I know
everything that makes you who you are
we've met before you just don't know it
and so again it's kind of cool when it
comes to these characters interact with
one another because what we ultimately
end up having is
Sean Cassidy reaching out to a
Nightcrawler and and Wolverine is saying
hey look I have something you guys need
to see it's effectively the last will
and testament of Maura McTaggart and so
you guys have to be aware of this what
we end up having is that the actual
Blackbird is basically being controlled
and she's gonna fly directly into the
plane that you know Shaun Cassidy's
flying on he basically jumps out and he
attempts to try to stop the plane which
he might have been able to do using his
voice but it's just not powerful enough
and the result is that he's actually
killed in the explosion which is big I
mean it was one of those things where if
you were only reading uncanny x-men then
basically you had house of AM you had
destination and then like three story
arcs later Sean Cassidy dies and it's
not really often that Marvel kills off
an x-men like that at least you know of
one that's been around for so long and
so it was kind of crazy because the
response is Neil from the x-men okay so
anybody who looks at this crime scene is
basically gonna say the x-men's
blackbird tried to fly into a commercial
aircraft a mutant jumped down and was
killed in the explosion what are the
x-men doing and they're immediately
gonna come in and they're gonna start
storming the place because remember the
office of national emergency kind of
takes precedent here and so while it is
one of those things of you know hey
we're here to keep you safe it's also we
can raid your house anytime we want to
we're basically gonna have the Office of
national emergency raid the place trying
to figure out what in the world is going
on why someone took the Blackbird and
try to fly it into another facility now
picking back up with Alex summers with
havoc the cool thing about this too is
we end up having this sort of mental
image that he picks up when he sees
Charles Xavier talking to Corsair now
course Eric's is a really really cool
character him and the starjammers we're
actually really really fun and he was an
attempt by Chris Claremont back in the
70s and 80s to kind of expand the
greater Marvel landscape remember when
it comes to like the model cosmos one of
the things that we talked about is that
there were a lot of people who were
working on building the marvel cosmology
but it wasn't a cohesive effort it's not
like Chris Claremont sat down with jim
Starlin roy thomas i said okay so like
how do we flesh this out it was one of
those things where they each contributed
their own piece and isolation from the
other and so course eric was basically
the father of Scott Summers and Alex
summers now what's going on is that this
whole idea at least in terms of Charles
Xavier talking to Coursera what he's
really saying is Scott Summers and Alex
summers they can't know you know and it
seems to be you know seems to indicate
that easterly course Eric you can't tell
them that you're their father
that's the the impression that's being
put on we're actually gonna find out is
that's not necessarily the case not only
that with regards to you know everything
going on with Scott inand Rachel summers
what we end up finding
is these psychic images that are being
put into the minds of people are being
done by this guy he's effectively
seizing control of Rachel summers mind
and then forcing her to put all these
images into everybody's head now a lot
of this is because of the fact that
Charles Xavier kind of left the psychic
imprints what it does is it allows this
guy to use the telepathic abilities of
Rachel summers to scan the Xavier
Institute and grab these key moments
from either his own life or the life of
Xavier when he was there and then
broadcast those images into people's
minds or take some of the most horrific
moments from their own experiences and
forced them back into those people's
minds so it's basically this guy pushing
the powers of Rachel summers in order to
instigate his own ends but not only that
the Rachel summers provides these little
tidbits where she says look you know
when this guy was controlling my mind I
was also reading his a little bit and
I've learned that he trained with the
x-men as there is these small little
tidbits this guy was at some point along
the line in x-men but piecing together
this this you know this video of more
McTaggart after rating the crash site
and basically grabbing what it was a
banshee was bringing beast and Wolverine
kind of break it all down and in this
last little moment what more McTaggart
says is that Charles Xavier was a
terrible guy because he had gone to more
McTaggart and asked to use her x-men and
then got them all killed now this is a
very important part of her characters
history because with more McTaggart she
was a mutant geneticist but it was one
of those things where she also helped to
Harbor and find mutants that were
basically kind of cast offs now whenever
it was as she found care it was like
Wolfsbane or somebody along those lines
the characters that would basically go
on to form the new mutants Charles
Xavier would serve the purpose of being
a training ground for them so more
McTaggart in Charles Xavier who actually
quite the team and it was really cool
and so what this does is this jumps back
into the whole idea of the Battle of
krakoa
now longtime x-men fans will be well
aware of this and in fact as soon as
this was called x-men deadly Genesis
they were like giant-size x-men number
one this goes up to the nature of the
x-men right and we talked about this
before when Stanley Jack Kirby Roy
Thomas you know these major contributors
I think Alan fine when they were working
on the x-men stories back in like the
1960s and going into the early 1970s the
x-men were not popular after about 63
issues running over the course of like
seven years the comic was canceled and
then reprints were issued for the next
thirty some-odd comics this ran into
1975 when Marvel relaunched with a
giant-size x-men number one by Lynn Wan
and the whole idea is this told a story
of krakoa and this was basically a
living Island it was a sentient Island
that had captured the x-men the original
man of Jean Grey and Scott Summers and
Iceman beast and Angel and Charles
Xavier had to form a second team which
is where he brought in the new
generation of x-men Colossus
Nightcrawler Wolverine all those guys
the ones that you're most familiar with
with regards to the x-men roster the
result is that with those newer
characters being rolled in with them
being brought in what it meant is that
fans kind of got the best of both worlds
they got a more diverse lineup of x-men
combined with the x-men they were
already used to now eventually that went
out into Bob Layton's whole you know
initial launch of x-factor with like the
first like five issues and then Walter
Simonson and Louise Simonson took over
and they wrote it for a little while but
the fact remains here that this is how
this all kind of kicked off and this is
basically what ends up happening in this
store we have this flashback of sorts
where Charles Xavier shows up to two
more McTaggart and says okay my x-men
have been captured and the psychic
League I had with him has been cut off
but here's the last few images that I
saw before that happened and it was the
x-men doing the best they could but the
problem is that it seemed as though the
x-men it either had been killed or had
been captured and so the result was that
the desire of Xavier was to find a way
to bring them back now following this
what Xavier did is he had gone to more
McTaggart and said I need to use your
x-men team and so in effect this was a
secret x-men team that nobody ever knew
about the first of these members was a
girl named zwei and so I had the ability
to like slowed down or stopped on in a
localized space meaning it was only in
like a small vicinity and so basically
it would be like in a bubble and so if
you traveled outside her sphere of
influence ty would pass just like normal
but after zwei came a character by the
name of Petra and Petra was basically a
Geo morphine he could alter the
structure of earth she could basically
you know create things she was able to
evolve a coal into a diamond different
things like that but she was basically
able to manipulate the planet earth
funneling this is the character of
Darwin we've already done an origin
video on him but Darwin was basically a
guy who could adapt to any circumstance
he could adapt to anything it didn't
matter what it was if it was fire he
wouldn't really feel it his body would
adapt so the fire wouldn't burn him if
it was dark he would develop you know
night vision I mean his body would
physically adapt to any situation but
one of the more powerful versions of
these characters are one of most
powerful characters on this team was a
kid named Gabriel and nobody really knew
anything about Gabriel's past all they
knew was that he was an orphan somewhere
along the line but his power was to
manipulate energy and it didn't matter
what that energy was exotic normal
whatever he could control it and
manipulate it so if you had like a gun
and you shot a gun at him that
let's off kinetic-energy he can
effectively stop it that's why one of
the arguments that's made is that Vulcan
border lines on reality-warping because
everything is composed of energy and if
he can manipulate exotic energy in the
form of energy blasts or something like
that what would stop him from
manipulating the energy of the universe
and so if it's pushed high enough he
could be a reality warping character on
the highest order because he would be
manipulating the energy of the universe
as opposed to just energy beams and
different things like that so again
Charles Xavier basically enlists these
kids as hey look I need your help we
have to go rescue the original x-men
they're immediately on board because
they're all vying to be part of the
x-men and so Charles Xavier instead of
training them in real time throws him
into the mindscape but doesn't tell them
and this is where Charles Xavier starts
to demonstrate this kind of duplicitous
dishonest nature in the sense that as
far as you know Darwin and Gabriel and
Petra and swag as far as they're aware
it's real everything they're
experiencing is real but xavier is
basically tricking them and not
necessarily telling them the truth but
the reason why is because they're on a
tight schedule tom is in such short
supply xavier does not know how long the
original x-men are gonna last and he
needs them to be rescued as fast as
humanly possible and so trading these
characters in the mindscape seems to be
the most efficient way to do it but it's
not and so what ended up happening is
Charles Xavier had basically sent these
kids out into a mission and they all got
killed and so what we end up having is
Scott Summers and we end up having
Rachel Summers who basically make their
way out of this holding facility that
you know that this guy was putting him
in and we find out this is Gabriel
summers this is the energy manipulator
that we were seeing and he's also the
brother of Scott summer she's a brother
of Cyclops the Cyclops never knew about
now the cool thing about this is we do
have an origin story on Vulcan I'm
pretty sure either it's an origin story
or it's an Omega beyond Omega level
video
I can't before one but basically he's
not born of Earth instead what ended up
happening is in the history of Cyclops
in and have it alex summers where you
know they were basically kind of thrown
out of a plane by corsair when you know
Corsair and his wife were being
kidnapped by the Shiar empire and in
turn you know Cyclops and have it were
given parachutes and they were said hey
get to safety you know what have you
worked for Sarah and his wife were taken
by the Shiar empire to basically be
thrown into a work force and what we
ended up finding out was that Cyclops
his mom was about two months pregnant by
the time that Gabriel had popped up and
so the result was that when they were in
the Shiar empire she effectively gave
birth to him and then he in turn was
thrown into a matrix where his growth
was sped up and then he
is kind of forced into a work him now
eventually he was able to make his
escape he arrived back on earth the rest
is history but the idea was that he was
just kind of inducted into the x-men and
that was really about it and so
following this because of the fact that
he's made such a huge display and the
fact that you know the office of
national emergency is able to lock on to
his energy signature after realizing
that he's the one that Cynthia said the
Blackbird crashing into banshee
effectively killing him he of course
overpowers the entirety of the you know
the Sentinel and kind of obliterates
everybody but his whole stance here his
whole goal is to draw out Charles Xavier
which works because when he goes to Muir
Island what we end up finding out is
that Charles Xavier is alive the trials
Xavier is not dead not only that Charles
Xavier when he shows up basically
confirms everything that that Gabriel
Sommers has been saying that like yes
Gabriel summers is the brother of
Cyclops yes Gabriel summers was one of
the egg one of the members of the secret
x-men team that no one was supposed to
know about and so again it's a huge deal
because what ends up happening is that
in response to this all the other x-men
basically starts showing up it was kind
of this huge audience that Gabriel
Somers was shooting for in the first
place the problem with this is that
where Gabriel Somers says show everyone
the truth use their powers show everyone
the truth where Charles Xavier shows up
with the ability to walk he also shows
up without his powers and so he can walk
around but he can't use telepathy and
this is kind of like a curses that he
really kind of interprets it as but the
Scarlet Witch said fine I'll give you
your legs back but I'm gonna take away
your powers just like 98% of the rest of
the meeting population and so the result
is that we end up having this branching
scenario that takes place you know where
Rachel summers steps up and says okay
fine you can use my mind to broadcast
the truth into the minds of everybody
else and again this is what we thought
end up finding out the whole situation
that this Gabriel summer's LED x-men
team did show up they did seem to rescue
the original x-men but Cyclops was the
only one who was able to get away with
the help of the original team where
Cyclops took off you know where he was
told go find help that the reality of
the situation was that for Gabriel
summers and for Charles Xavier himself
that this x-men team was seemingly
obliterated the living Island had
basically adapted itself to all their
attacks
it killed sway it killed Petra you know
it seemed to kill Darwin and it seemed
to kill a Vulcan at least that seemed to
be the case the problem with this was
that while this battle was going on and
these younger xmin were being killed
Charles Xavier modified the memories of
Cyclops
so the sock ops would believe the island
sent him back to the x-men to find more
mutants which is what the original
giant-size x-men number one story told
us
and so what we end up finding out here
is a Charles Xavier mess with the -
Cyclops tricked him into believing
something happened that didn't actually
happen and in turn the rest of the
mutants that were left on that island
they all effectively died now Gabriel
Summers in Darwin technically lived but
nobody else knew that and so when
Charles Xavier had rounded up this new
generation of x-men Colossus
Nightcrawler Wolverine so on and so
forth and sent them to the island
alongside
Cyclops to rescue the original x-men
team where that version was successful
and Jean Grey took the giant landmass
and shot it into space what they didn't
know is that Vulcan and Darwin were
still in that chunk of land and so
because of that they were basically sent
out there you know and they were just
kind of floating in space
Darwin basically merged with with with
Gabriel summers in order to keep him
alive and then they've just kind of
float in there ever since because of the
fact because of the events of house of
am with this massive amount of energy
being given off by the 98% of meetin's
that lost their powers it woke up
Gabriel summers it kicked him up out of
this you know catatonic state and then
he in turn went on this warpath because
he remembered virtually everything and
the question was why doesn't anybody
else know and so as a result of this
Darwin basically reconstitutes himself
more or less because it's Darwin and in
response to this with Cyclops learning
the truth that his mind had been tricked
by Xavier that Xavier was being
duplicitous he was lying
Cyclops kicks him out of the Xavier
Institute and says you're no longer
welcome here this works because remember
Cyclops and Emma Frost had been running
the Institute following the vanishing of
Charles Xavier they've been running it
for quite some time not only that as far
as Cyclops says he says you're not a
mutant you don't have to live with the
anymore so you don't really even have a
place here if we've told every person
this that's not a mutant that they can't
come here that same rule has to apply to
you so you have to leave and so what
this does is it sets in motion the story
called rise and fall of the Shiar Empire
where basically Gabriel summers races
into space in order to gain vengeance
against the Shiar Empire who are
responsible for the death of his mother
and the presumed torture of his father
you know Corsair and so on and so forth
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the robb cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]